Was machen wir eigentlich zu unserer hundertsten Sendung? Hier ist sie, die Frage Nummer eins. Wieso hast du denn einen Elefanten auf dem Kopf, Max?
Dieser 4-Stunden-Sendung hab ich 30 Sekunden.
25.
Das wollt ihr nicht.
Ja, was machen wir jetzt eigentlich zur hundertsten Sendung?
Wir fahren in Heidepark-Soltau oder nach Tropical Island.
Tropical Island? Das war gut. Wer war das schon mal?
Ich im Prinzip.
Ich auch.
Aber noch nicht seit es Tropical Island ist.
Ich sag bloß du warst da, als da noch die Zeppel, die rumhängen.
Ja, ich hab ja für die Firma gearbeitet.
Ach nee, erzähl.
Echt erzähl.
Haben wir da schon mal drüber geredet? Haben wir. Und dann waren wir auch genauso überrascht und so und haben oh gesagt.
Ich glaube ja.
Und wir gingen so kalender.
Das ist das Schöne, Roddy. Du kannst uns immer wieder überraschen. Wenn auch immer wieder mit den Sälen faszinieren. Was?
Der hat doch nicht von mir erzählt.
Ich kann mich auch nicht dran erinnern. Also ich kenne das schon. Ja, du hast auch mal in so einem Zeppelin drinnen gesessen.
Nee, die flugen ja nie.
Ja, schade eigentlich, ne? Ich meine, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob...
Und bist du schuld oder eigentlich wer?
Ich bin doch nicht schuld.
Ah, ich weiß nicht, so ein Zeppelin fernsteuern finde ich auch mal ganz cool. Wie war das eigentlich geplant in der Zeit, dass die Dinger irgendwie so autonom durch die Gegend? Das waren diese Cargo, Transport, aber schon so mit Fernbedienung oder waren die autonom oder beides so ein bisschen?
Also die Dinger waren geplant, ungefähr 130 Meter lang, ungefähr eine halbe Million Kubikmeter Traggas. 160 Tonnen Zuladungskapazität auf einer Ladebrücke, die, wenn man das Ding beladen wollte, wurde die Ladebrücke runtergefahren oder hätte runtergefahren werden sollen. Da sind dann so Wassertanks in der Ladebrücke. Und damit das Ding nicht zu leicht wird oder zu schwer, hast du halt Wasser drin, wenn du keine Zuladung hast. Und wenn du was reinladest, dann fährst du das auf die Ladebrücke, lässt entsprechend Wasser ab und bist hinterher genauso schwer wie vorher. Und das Ganze versuchst du aber irgendwie in anderthalb bis zwei Stunden über die Bühne zu bringen, weil du nicht weißt, ob das Wetter länger als diese Zeit so weit hält, dass dir das Teil nicht weggepustet wird.
Ungefähr. Das war jetzt die Kurzzusammenfassung.
Und wird dann selber geflogen oder wird gefernsteuert?
Da wird im Prinzip selber geflogen. Das Problem an dem Teil ist, dass es so groß und langsam ist, dass es sich so langsam bewegt, dass du es als Mensch eigentlich nicht steuern kannst, weil du nicht mehr wahrnehmen kannst, ob du übersteuerst oder nicht. Also du nimmst die Beschleunigung als solche viel zu spät wahr und übersteuerst die ganze Zeit. Also ich habe da ja irgendwie an dem Flugsimulator mitgearbeitet und wir haben das Teil natürlich auch im Simulator geflogen und das ging halt nicht. Man konnte das Ding überhaupt nicht fliegen. Es ging überhaupt nicht. Wir hatten irgendwann mal so einen Prof da, der hat irgendwie Simulatoren, so Schiffsimulatoren für Öltanker gemacht. Der war der Einzige, der das Ding halbwegs fliegen konnte. Der war das gewöhnt, dass so ein Teil sich langsam bewegt. Aber so dieses flieg einfach mal nach Norden, das geht halt nicht. Also ein Luftschiff fliegt immer labil, weil das Leitwerk immer zu klein ist. Weil da hast du zwei Dinge, die du nicht willst. Erstens Gewicht, willst du nicht? Und Gewicht ganz hinten, wo der Hebel am längsten ist, willst du schon gleich gar nicht haben. Deswegen macht man das Leitwerk immer so klein, wie du gerade noch irgendwie mit wegkommst, dass das Teil irgendwie geht. Und das hat aber zur Folge, das Ding ist halt, pfff, wird halt so stabil wie ein Wildwasser-Kajak. Also gar nicht, es dreht sich halt nur. Und als Pilot machst du nichts anderes, als das Ding ständig nachzusteuern, damit du geradeaus fliegst. Und wenn es aber so langsam dreht, dass du als Pilot nicht mehr wahrnehmen kannst, dass es sich dreht, dann hast du halt ein Problem.
Und das wollten sie dann alles mal mit Software schlagen. Sensorik und Pipa Pro.
Da waren, na ich sag mal so, da waren so Instrumente, Cockpit-Instrumente in der Entwicklung, die einem mit Hilfe von so ein paar Zeigern angezeigt haben, ob man jetzt den Steuerknöppel nach rechts oder nach links tun muss. Weil der das irgendwie so integriert hat, dass du immer versucht hast, den Strich in die Mitte zu tun. Und damit flog sich das dann auch.
Aber jetzt ist der Roddy dafür hier in unserer Sendung.
Aber es sollte hier jetzt um Luftschiffe gehen.
Naja, wir wollen dich ja verkuppeln, Roddy. Da können wir ja auch mal deine bisherigen Leistungen ruhig noch mal in den Mittelpunkt stellen. Roddy for sale. Falls jemand irgendwie einen finnigen Programmierer braucht, Roddy wäre gerade mal so zu kriegen.
So nicht mein Freund.
We're not in Kansas anymore.
Gut.
Was wir aus der 100. machen, wissen wir immer noch nicht. Vielleicht gehen wir dann irgendwie nach Soltau. Vielleicht auch in die Möglichkeit. Vielleicht machen wir aber auch was Tolles.
Aber hier hat gerade ein Hörer vorhin vorgeschlagen, wir könnten auch die 100. Sendung im Apple Store Berlin...
Nee, die 100.
ist ja noch dieses Jahr.
Flughafen, also auch nicht.
Vielleicht sagen wir erstmal Hallo, hier ist Mobile Max, Ausgabe 94. Also das mit der 100. ist jetzt noch nicht so unbedingt Ante Portas, aber es zeichnet sich ab. Es zeichnet sich ab, dass wir es vielleicht tatsächlich schaffen. Und zur Feier dieses vorausliegenden Ereignisses haben wir dann hier schon mal die große Runde einberufen, komplettes Team. Die haben wir schon gehört, auch schon gehört, noch nicht so viel gehört, haben wir von Max.
Ist das Netz hier irgendwie kaputt?
Ich wink mal. Hallo, Max winkt.
Man hört das laut winken.
Dennis.
Beschwätzt sich übers Netz.
Atmest du noch?
Ja, bin da.
Und dann haben wir noch einen Star-Gast, nämlich Martin.
Also du hast dich schon beschwert, dass ich gar kein Star bin. Insofern weiß ich nicht, ob du das richtig angekündigt hast.
Natürlich hab ich das richtig angekündigt. Du bist unser Star-Gast, du bist heute der Star. Also known as Mapp und den meisten Hörern wahrscheinlich schon aus vielen Kanälen bekannt. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass wir dich hier nicht auch mal ordentlich vorstellen können, oder?
Ja, können wir. Ich mein, gerade im Moment mach ich irgendwie Fanboys und Retro-Zirkel und Ponytime.
Du castest Pott.
Ich caste Pott.
Genau, du hast schon drei. Du bist mir auf der Spur, Mann.
Ich bin dir auf der Spur.
Das ist ja nicht die schlechteste Spur.
Der Stream ist tot, der Stream ist tot.
Wird sich hier auch gleich gesperrt.
Sechs Leute sind zuviel. Ich hab aber auch dauernd irgendwie Konnektivitätsprobleme mit dem Eric.
Ich hab hier auch irgendwie so, aber hier kommt auch am laufenden Meter was rein. Naja, das wird sich schon lösen. Ich sende auf jeden Fall. Ich kann nicht jetzt nochmal irgendwie, was soll ich machen? Kann man nichts gegen tun. Außerdem beschweren sich jetzt schon wieder die Hörer, dass wir darüber reden, dass der Stream nicht geht, was die Leute, die meisten ja gar nicht betrifft, weil sie hören es ja gar nicht im Stream.
Ja, dann ignorieren wir den Stream jetzt einfach.
Ja, wir schauen mal, was sich da machen lässt. Naja, aber wir waren bei dir, wie nennt man dich denn eigentlich korrekt? Aber nicht Mapp.
Nein.
Es wurde mir angetragen, dass das korrekterweise Mapp ausgesprochen wird und dem püge ich mich. Genau.
Wer hat dir das gesagt?
Der Herr Urbach.
Der hat dich so getauft, oder was?
Ich war mir nur der Aussprache nicht bewusst.
Der hat dir die Sprachregelung vorgegeben.
Na gut, wenn der das sagt, dann muss es schon.
Wer bin ich, da zu widersprechen?
Genau, aber du bist einer von zwei, oder eigentlich genau genommen sogar von mehreren, Coding Monkeys. Wie viele seid ihr jetzt in eurem Team?
Jetzt sind es momentan fünf. Also ich und Dom, die das Ganze mal initial losgetreten haben, damals noch zusammen mit zwei anderen, die mittlerweile diese Selbständigkeit nicht so ganz verkraften. Aber wir zwei sind noch übrig aus dem Originalgründungsteam sozusagen und haben jetzt zwei Angestellte und einen freien Mitarbeiter.
Und dann habt ihr irgendwie mal angefangen mit Hydra?
Genau.
Das dann nicht so heißen durfte?
Ja, da war so eine SAP-Zulieferfirma, die irgendwie diese Marke hatte. Und wir waren ja irgendwie dumme Studenten und dachten so, wir machen hier...
SAP-Zulieferfirma?
Wir waren dumme Studenten und dachten so, wir machen hier Freeware, uns kann nichts passieren. Wir verdienen ja kein Geld und bla. Und dann nennen wir das mal Hydra. Ja, und dann waren wir irgendwie in der CT und ein paar Tage später kam dann irgendwie ein Post vom Anwalt und ja, hier Marke und so. Und zahlt mal und geht weg.
Dann habt ihr einen anderen schönen Namen gefunden. Seitdem heißt das Ding...
Sub-Ether-Edit.
Genau. Wer einen Anhalter gelesen hat, kennt, kann auch was mit der Anspielung anfangen. Ja, ist auch so ein bisschen eins meiner Lieblingsprogramme. Da können wir auch nachher nochmal drauf kommen. Dann habt ihr aber irgendwie so ein bisschen den Kurs geändert und seid eurer Gaming-Tradition bewusster geworden.
Ja, vorher haben wir noch Boeingstv mitgemacht.
Stimmt.
Ein bisschen Videoschnitt-Kram. Das macht so quasi Fernsehstudio in einer Kiste drin.
Als ihr euch noch getraut habt, es mit der Audio-Abi von Mac OS X aufzunehmen.
Ja, das war ich damals, der da irgendwie mit Co-Audio gekämpft hat. Es hat mich Hören gekostet tatsächlich. Ich hör seitdem auf einem Ohr schlechter. Aber Geschichten aus dem Krieg.
Wow, das ist ja dramatisch.
Ja, wenn Bugs richtig weh tun. Dann sind wir irgendwie auf den Trichter gekommen, Brettspiele für iOS zu machen.
Das war dann Carcassonne?
Das war Carcassonne, genau.
Eine Umsetzung von einem, ohnehin schon. Ich muss ja zugeben, dass ich mich in diesem Segment wenig auskenne.
Ja, das sind wir beieinander. Ich bin da auch relativ unbefleckt.
Aber Dom ist da ja infiziert schon immer gewesen.
Also Dom ist irgendwie, hat als Jugendlicher schon einen Test gespielt für diverse Verlage und hat da irgendwie Prototypen aus Papier gezockt. Er hat irgendwie Siedler gespielt, bevor es Siedler hieß und so und den ganzen Kram. Also der ist da Hardcore-Nerd, Sachen und Brettspiele und dann haben wir uns gedacht, wir setzen unsere Ursprungsidee eines Spielestudios dann ebenso mit Brettspielen um. Weil wir wollten, ganz ursprünglich wollten wir DS-Spiele schreiben. Das scheiterte dann aber daran, dass man...
Was ist Nintendo DS?
Nintendo DS, ja.
Welches von diesen Plastikgeräten ist das?
Ja, so tragbare Nintendo-Devices. Das zum Aufklappen. Das zum Aufklappen. Also das 3DS muss nun auch aufklappen insofern. Ja, aber so. Das mit den zwei Wärtschärmen.
Dafür steht auch DS-Dual-Screen.
Gut erfasst. Das scheiterte dann aber daran, dass SDK erstmal zehnstellige Summen gekostet hat damals. Und dann dachten wir uns, machen wir lieber was anderes.
Äh, nein, ich meinte fünfstellige.
Zehntausend.
Ja, das ist ein ganz anderes Developer-Modell, was sich da mittlerweile so durchgesetzt hat mit Apples Upstore-Klimbe. Ich meine, es wird immer viel geflucht, aber an der Stelle haben sie ja im Prinzip den Markt komplett umgedreht. Weil das läuft doch bei allen so, Xbox, Sony etc. Da muss man sich erstmal fett einkaufen, damit man überhaupt erstmal anfangen darf.
Ja, es wird langsam ein bisschen besser, aber es ist immer noch so, dass man da massiv Vorleistungen machen muss. Und gerade Xbox ist irgendwie in letzter Zeit auch in den Nachrichten wieder gewesen, weil irgendeinen Patch nochmal fünfstellige Dollar-Summen gekostet hätte, um den zu submitten und zu reviewen. Und ja, das ist dann eben ein bisschen doof, wenn man so Software nachpatcht und die nochmal komplett durch den Review-Prozess bei Microsoft muss, der dann einen Haufen Geld kostet.
Da beklagt man sich dann nicht mehr, wenn es irgendwie kostenlos eine Woche dauert.
Ja, dann ist man erstmal kurz wieder still. Der macht ein paar Tage später erst wieder.
So, aber jetzt wart ihr ganz fleißig und habt irgendwie das letzte Jahr damit zugebracht. Das letzte Dreivierteljahr, ja. So, und wenn ich es richtig sehe, ist jetzt zum Zeitpunkt dieser Ausstrahlung bereits schon irgendein Knopf gedrückt, oder?
Naja, das ist ja alles so auf... Du kannst ja einstellen, wann es released wird und wenn du so ein koordiniertes Release machen willst, dass es irgendwie um die Welt, immer um 0 Uhr, dann musst du quasi einen Tag vorher zumindest einstellen, dann soll es released werden.
Kann man das so für jeden Abschnitt... Also kann man auch weltweit zeitgleich machen, dass es sozusagen ein Zeitpunkt ist, oder kann man nur eine Uhrzeit machen?
Ja, wenn du manuell den Knopf drückst, dann ist es weltweit zeitgleich, aber so...
Also kannst du sagen, jetzt.
Aber wenn du eine Zeit einstellst, dann nur eine, und die ist dann zeitzoneabhängig.
Die ist dann zeitzoneabhängig, genau.
Das heißt, wenn du es wirklich alle auf einen haben willst, dann brauchst du da irgendwie so ein...
Ein F, das den Knopf drückt.
Einen für alle. Oder muss man dann für jede Region nochmal einen einzelnen Knopf drücken?
Du kannst da einen für alle drücken, ja.
Einer für alle.
Dann dauert es aber ein bisschen, bis das drin ist. Die Erfahrung hab ich sammeln müssen, weil dann... Für die eine ist es dann schon da, für die andere nicht. Und das ist total eigentlich... Ich glaube, das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Ach so, dann rollen sie, wenn du den Knopf drückst, rollen sie sozusagen das Deployment dann erst aus. Und dann dauert es, aber wenn Zeit eingestellt ist, dann ist es auch wirklich genau die Zeit. Und da habt ihr euch gedacht, das könnt ihr euch auch sparen. Okay, mit anderen Worten, es ist schon Release. Und was ist Release?
Lost Cities.
Also es ist Release in Japan und in Neuseeland und überall schon morgen.
Ganz Japaner kriegen immer alles zuerst.
Null Uhr.
Das heißt, wenn wir es jetzt hier durch Mitternacht schaffen, dann können wir das miterleben, ja.
Wie spannend.
Habt ihr es vier Wochen vorher eingerichtet, eingericht, so wie diese üblichen...
Wir haben es zweieinhalb Wochen vorher eingericht, um es nochmal live testen zu können auch. Weil so mit Game Center hast du echt das Problem, dass du es in der Sandbox nicht vernünftig testen kannst. Und haben dann nochmal so ein bisschen was gefunden, haben auch schon den ersten Patch submittert, der schon durch ist. Und sind jetzt dann relativ entspannt in Sachen Bugs und so, was jetzt Game Center angeht.
Weil ich hab mal so gehört, dass man, wenn man im App Store gefeatured werden will, dass man das dann hinreichend lange vorher einreichen muss. Also, ist natürlich dann trotzdem kein Automatismus, wenn man es ein halbes Jahr verrotten lässt, dass es dann gefeatured wird. Aber wenn du das willst, dann musst du es lang genug vorher einreichen.
Oder auch 3 Mark.
3 Mark?
Ne, 3 Euro natürlich. Ja, mit dem vorher einreichen ist es halt so, du brauchst zumindest, du musst wissen, zu welchem Datum du released. Und da musst du natürlich dann irgendwie so eine gewisse Vorlaufzeit haben.
Und habt ihr euch Hoffnung darauf gemacht, dass Apple da ankommt und sagt?
Also, wie das halt so ist, man wird dann mal gefragt, ob man schon Artworks abmitten möchte, so falls mal sowas passiert. Und dann drückt man mal die Daumen, man erfährt ja nichts, aber so potentiell könnte das passieren.
3 Euro oder 2,40?
2,99 ist glaube ich der Tier.
Ist doch aber mal 80 Cent, wie geht das?
Ist doch ein Euro-Preis. Die Euro-Preis sind ungefähr 80 Cent, oder?
Ja, genau.
2,99, also das sind dann...
Aber eben ungefähr nur.
2,59?
2,79, 1,59, immer 80 Cent weiter.
2,39. Seid ihr sicher?
Ich dachte, das wäre 2,99 und 3,99.
Scheiße, das ist das ganze Business-Modell.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt das gut durchgerechnet. Tja, na dann. Können wir nachher mal gucken. Stell dir den Wecker.
Der ist sowieso schon gestellt und was nicht alles.
Der Chat sagt uns bestimmt Bescheid. Wenn sie uns überhaupt hören.
Wie kriege ich denn das auf meinem jailbroken iPhone kostenlos zum Laufen, ohne euch 92 in den Rassen zu schmeißen? Ihr Kapitalisten.
Hattet ihr mal ein Promo-Code?
Jaja, das ist eine E-Mail, die ich in letzter Zeit häufiger bekommen habe.
Kein Zweifel. Was du mir vorhin erklärt hast, das war ja für mich auch so ein bisschen neu.
Hier bei SÜTA gibt es das schon.
Ich würde mich jetzt nicht gewundern.
Wird auch passieren. Was er eben schon erklärt, man kann eine App einreichen und dann schon Promo-Codes rausgeben. Das war mir so auch noch nicht bewusst. Sodass Leute das quasi schon benutzen und testen können. Und dann sozusagen auch unter echten Bedingungen. Also nicht so wie diese ganzen Deployment-Dienste das machen. Man muss da erst seine ID vom iPhone hin und dann kriegt man ein Special-Bild, wo man mit drin ist. Sondern halt so richtig runterladen vom App-Store, als hätte man es gekauft, obwohl es eigentlich noch nicht sichtbar ist.
Also diese ganzen Deployment-Dienste, die du natürlich trotzdem haben willst, für eine Beta im Vorfeld, klar. Aber wenn du halt gerade sowas wie Game Center benutzt, das sich halt in echt anders verhält als in deiner Entwickler-Umgebung, dann ist es halt wirklich Trick-17, dass du das mal schon in App-Store stellst, aber das Veröffentlichungsdatum hochdrehst in deinen iTunes Connect Settings. Dann ist es da quasi, aber man sieht es noch nicht. Und du kannst eben über Promokurs das dann trotzdem schon runterladen.
Und du kannst auch Updates einreichen. Das heißt, in der Phase kann man schon mal checken, läuft alles und dann wird das, was dann wirklich released wird, ist dann sozusagen auch schon so ein bisschen...
Abgehangen. Bulletproof. Bulletproof ist Software ja nie, aber es ist immer so ein bisschen abgehangen. Aber es ist halt so, das funktioniert halt zufällig. Das ist keine von Apple dokumentierte Art und Weise Dinge zu tun.
Bist du überhaupt irgendwas dokumentiert?
Nein, aber das schließt sich ja nicht gegenseitig aus. Auf jeden Fall, ja, das sind halt so tradierte Werte zwischen Entwicklern, dass man so weiß, das geht irgendwie so, wenn du da Promo-Codes machen willst, dass das dann schon drin ist und du siehst es aber nicht. Aber man kann sich nicht darauf verlassen, dass es in Zukunft so bleibt.
Dann sag noch mal kurz, was das Spiel jetzt eigentlich macht.
Naja, es ist im Prinzip so ein bisschen solitär, aber mit zwei Spielern. Das heißt, du hast Karten und du musst die in einer Reihenfolge auf einem Spielfeld ablegen. Und der Witz ist, du spielst das gegen jemand anderes und ihr zieht vom gleichen Stapel. Es gibt fünf verschiedene Farben, in denen du die Karten hast. Die gehen jeweils von zwei bis zehn.
Das ist jetzt das normale französische Blatt oder was?
Ne, das ist einfach nur Zahlkarten. Zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn. Du legst dann aufsteigend diese Karten hin. Wenn du die drei gelegt hast, kannst du die zwei nicht mehr legen. Du musst aufsteigend eine Reihe bauen und bekommst dann Punkte dafür, wie weit du diese Reihe gebaut hast am Ende des Spiels. Du kannst dann mit Wettkarten darauf wetten, dass du diese Reihe besonders weit kriegst und deinen Einsatz verdoppeln oder verdreifachen. Im Prinzip baust du eine Solitärreihe von X-Karten und bekommst dann dafür Punkte gegen jemand anderes. Da gibt es dann ein bisschen Strategie und Taktik-Zeugs, dass du dann auf den Ablagestapel legen kannst und der andere dir die Karten klauen und gedönst. Aber das ist alles in der App viel besser erklärt, als man es jetzt hier so schnell.
Und was hat das mit Cities zu tun und warum sie Lost?
Das Ganze hat so ein bisschen so ein Indiana Jones-Setting. Diese fünf Farben stehen jeweils für eine Expedition. Diese Karten, die du legst, da kommst du dann weiter in diese Expedition. Du kannst irgendwie in die Wüste gehen und da irgendwie die Pyramiden erforschen oder in den Dschungel und irgendwelche Maya-Tempel. Und das ist so der Rahmen quasi außenrum um dieses Spiel. Also die Thematik, dass da so Archäologenkram passiert.
Vielleicht kann man das ja auch nochmal verfilmen irgendwie.
Ja, ja.
So Indiana Jones geht in den Tempel und legt Karten.
Könnte man auch ein schönes Fahrwerk, Fahrdienst für Dings draus machen. Mit Looping und so und dabei Karten legen.
Was ist der Kick?
Was ist der Kick? Es macht relativ schnell süchtig. Also man wird da reingesaugt und ist dann irgendwie, man merkt, man könnte jetzt, man hat gerade verloren, aber bei der nächsten Revanche klappt es bestimmt. Also es hat eine sehr schnelle, es saugt einen sehr schnell ein mit dieser Spielmechanik, mit der Rainer Knietz hier, der ist irgendwie dafür auch bekannt, dass er solche Spiele baut. Der ist ein relativ bekannter Brettspielautor, er hat schon 100 oder so insgesamt in seiner Laufbahn zusammengedöelt und der kennt sich halt mit solchen Mechaniken ziemlich gut aus, ist irgendwie auch Doktor der Mathematik und was nicht alles und dreht da immer sehr an seinen Taktikdingern.
Also das Ding ist ausgefeilt?
Das Ding ist ausgefeilt und saugt einen schnell ein und gerade so gegeneinander ist das definitiv sehr spaßig.
Na, ihr habt ja jetzt schon ganz schön Brett-Spiel-Kompetenz aufgesogen durch die eigenen Sachen und Herr Zeitweise ist ja auch umtriebig bei euch.
Herr Zeitweise ist auch bei uns, ja. Da gibt es auch einen CRE zu.
Genau, da gibt es auch einen CRE zu.
Zum Thema Brett-Spiele.
Zum Thema Brett-Spiele, ja.
Bei dem Herrn Zeitweise.
Sehr schöne Sendung.
Bin ja nicht so der Mega-Brett-Spieler, sag ich mal.
Nee, ich auch nicht, aber die Sendung ging deutlich auch, das war schon recht meta.
Über das Brett hinaus. Das Spielbrett hinaus.
Ja, das war mehr so Spieltheorie, ne?
Ja, es kam viel rein, wie man das halt so macht und was man auch aus Spielen lernen kann so für Strukturen, gesellschaftliche Strukturen, Demokratie und so, pipapo. Also so ein Kram.
2010, Donnerlittchen.
So, noch Fragen an den Gast?
Vor wir ins Eingang kommen?
Ich dachte, wir müssen hier vier Stunden sitzen.
Dafür, dass du uns jetzt hier ein Sponsorgeld vorbeigebracht hast, hast du doch jetzt genug Promo-Zeit bekommen eigentlich.
Wir machen immer nur fünf Minuten und loopen uns dann.
Nee, der Mapp, der hat ja auch sonst noch immer kluge Beiträge beizutragen. Deswegen bist du ja auch hier. Trotzdem, ihr könnt ja in der Zwischenzeit, während wir hier labern, schon mal checken, ob Lost Cities online ist.
Also ist noch nicht online, meinst du?
Ist noch nicht online.
Und die Preise sind wirklich 79 Cent, 1,59 Euro, 2,39 und so weiter. Also ihr verdient wahrscheinlich viel weniger.
Viel weniger, ja.
Oder ihr nehmt 3,19 oder so.
Ich hab immer nur die S-Preise im Kopf, und das sind 399 USD.
Ja, nee, da kriegst du jetzt nur 2,39 Euro.
Nee, kriegste nicht. Kriegste nicht, genau.
Ja, und dann noch den Abzug natürlich.
Ja, hier Stachelbeerkuchen hat ja ganz gut funktioniert, Huckel, wa?
Nee, hat nicht funktioniert.
Hat nicht funktioniert? Bei dir nicht vielleicht.
Also, na, wo ist er? Ich hab meine...
Er steht hier nicht auf die Tränen.
Also ehrlich gesagt hab ich auch ein bisschen damit gerechnet, dass wir jetzt auch einen Stachelbeerkuchen kriegen. Aber ich war doch schwer überrascht, dass tatsächlich so extrem viele Leute das bis zum bitteren Ende hören. Hätte ich mir tatsächlich nicht träumen lassen.
Kannst mal sehen.
Ja, doch, war eine sehr positive Überraschung. Also ich hab, hat irgendjemand gezählt, also ich hab auf Twitter, wenn man jetzt nach Stachelbeerkuchen sucht...
Ich hab irgendwann aufgehört.
Dann kriegt man ja hier immer noch die komplette Liste bis ganz zum Anfang, aber irgendwie gibt es hier nicht so einen Count.
Man weiß bei dieser Twittersuche auch ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr so richtig, was man davon heißt.
Obwohl, jetzt ist es schon wieder weniger Results, das cappen sie jetzt schon wieder. Naja, aber es waren so gefühlte 200.
Also bei 100 habe ich aufgehört zu zählen.
Ja, und dann ging es ja noch jeden Tag weiter. Ich kriege ja heute noch Stachelbärkuchen.
Mal gucken, wie lange noch. Mal gucken, wann jetzt der Stachelbärkuchen kommt.
Also der letzte war vor 25 Minuten.
Ja, und dann gibt es ja noch die Leute, die irgendwie Stachelbärkuchen so schreiben, als ginge es da um ein Pelztier. Also das ist irgendwie...
Ja, stimmt, da gab es auch ein paar.
Und wer jetzt überhaupt nicht weiß, wovon die Rede ist, der muss sich die letzte Sendung bis zum bitteren Ende anhören.
Ja, das war eigentlich mal ein schöner Weg, da ganz leicht Feedback zu kriegen. Am Ende der Sendung noch mal so einen kleinen... Eigentlich könnten wir auch da noch ganz andere tolle Sachen machen. Zum Beispiel Tickets zu unserer 100. Sendung verlosen. In den allerletzten 30 Sekunden.
Die 100. Sendung.
Dann machen wir es an 5 Stellen in der Sendung. Dann ist es schon anstrengend genug, durchzuskippen. Dann ist es fast einfacher, einfach 5 Stunden...
Oder an 5 Enden von 5 Sendungen.
Dann kannst du ja immer gleich zum Ende. Das ist ja dann zu einfach. Ja, Stachelbärkuchen. Also zur nächsten Sendung, ihr habt noch eine Chance. Also ich weiß, dass zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich getwittert hab, scheint auch gerade so Stachelbärzeit noch gewesen zu sein. Weil es haben einige Leute...
Ich hab welche in meinem Minigarten und die sind schon weg.
Dein Minigarten in Berlin Mitte.
Da wachsen Stachelbären.
Ich hab Stachelbären und ich hab Himbeeren. Und ich hab dieses Jahr schon 2 Himbeeren geerntet. Die anderen beiden dachte ich, die müssen noch ein bisschen. Als ich 2 Tage später raus bin, waren sie weg. Die hat mir einen Scheißvogel geklaut. Die hat sozusagen 60% meiner Ernte gemoxt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass du so einen grünen Daumen hast.
2 Stachelbären, das ist jetzt nicht so der Expekt.
Das ist so ein ganz kleiner Busch, man muss ja irgendwie geduldig sein und so. Und ich meine, wie viel hast du denn?
Klarer Gewinner. Also die Stachelbäre, die hat besonders hohen Ansprüche an Boden und Klima. Warm und nicht zu trocken. Regelmäßigen Schnitt im Frühjahr. Und wann ist Ernte? Ernte, Wikipedia. In der Wikipedia in der Deutschen steht nicht, wann die Stachelbärernte ist. Nee, wir fragen einfach das Universum. Egal, aber auf jeden Fall haben wir einige Leute Bilder von Stachelbärkuchen geschickt. Und den gibt es ja nun wirklich nicht oft. Bei meiner Oma schon. Bei dir läuft die Stachelbeere stark in Familienstrande.
Soll ich mal einen beauftragen für das nächste Mal?
Ja, sehr gut.
Du bist jetzt der offizielle Stachelbärkuchenbeauftragte.
Also trotzdem, also auch nochmal vielen Dank an die Wertehörerschaft fürs treue Zuhören.
Was machen wir denn jetzt mit M100? Ich bin ja gerade an so einem Google-Dokument, so ein Formular, da könnte man ja mal eine kleine Umfrage machen.
Ja, also wir könnten ja schon irgendwas in Berlin machen natürlich. Und dann kann man ja mal gucken, ob da irgendwelche Leute Lust haben, hinzukommen. Und dann ist die 100. Sendung, welchem Monat ist denn das? Das ist schon zu kalt für draußen, ne?
Ja, nee, für draußen ist das nicht so...
Wir könnten abgrillen vielleicht.
Also wenn wir so richtig nach Plan sind, wenn wir nach Plan laufen, dann müssten wir so die 99. Ende Oktober durchhaben. Das kann, oder Anfang November, also das würde sozusagen November...
Mitte November-risch.
The 5th of November.
Die steht hier sogar schon auf einem Samstag.
15 November ist... Montag.... nicht geeignet. Keine Ahnung.
Na, wir überlegen mal.
Ja, man muss ja irgendwie wissen, äh...
Wie das Interesse ist.
Ja, also ich frag mich gerade, was man so irgendwie vielleicht wissen wollen würde, um da die richtige...
Na, erstmal die erste Iteration...
Unter welchen Bedingungen?
Ja, macht man erstmal die erste Iteration und fragt überhaupt, wer Bock drauf hat. Und dann kann man ja da vielleicht schon mal sinnvolle weitere Einschränkungs...
Mit Sitzplatz, Raucher, Großraum, Loge, Abteil.
Und so weiter. Aber Tim, vielleicht können wir das ja nochmal gegen Ende der Sendung verfestigen und vielleicht haben wir ja sogar tatsächlich heute mal auch noch ein Thema.
Ja, wir haben richtig viele Themen. Ich dachte nur, das kam ja gerade auf hier auch schon im...
Aber es fühlt sich jetzt schon zu Beginn an, als wären wir schon im Abklingbecken quasi.
Ach quatsch, blödsinn.
Wir sammeln die Kräfte so. Wir haben sogar eine Halbwegs-Mobilität.
Da taucht die Stimme gerade ein.
Und jetzt hab ich das falsche Bild im Kopf.
Deine Fantasie ist eureklig.
Pervert.
Czernienko-Strahlung.
Sauschalt love thy listener. Und nicht durcheinander quatschen.
Quatschkuchen.
So Berlin. Letztes Mal haben wir hier ein bisschen philosophiert, wie es mit dem neuen Apple Store so läuft. Das scheint ja alles eine gewisse Konkurrenz aufzuwarten. Da gab es ja so dieses Gerücht, dass die Mitarbeiter jetzt alle schon so heiß gemacht werden auf den Oktober.
Das war die richtige Frage.
Das war die richtige Frage. Aber ehrlich gesagt, Oktober.
Also wir sind hier in Berlin und gelegentlich fahren wir natürlich vorbei und gucken durch die Schlitze bei den schwarz zugeklebten Fenstern. Die, solange wie es jetzt da schon zugeklebt ist, haben natürlich schon ein bisschen Risse durch die Sonneinstrahlung bekommen und so. Wählt schon langsam ab. Und wenn man da so seinen Augen Glauben schenken mag, auch so von...
Wir haben unsere Apple Sichtgeräte aufgesetzt. Da schaut man halt auch durch den schwarzen Vorhang durch. Und da kann ich euch sagen, mit Oktober, das wird nischt. Also, sieht schlecht aus. Das würde an ein Wunder grenzen.
Aber so langsam...
Man möchte meinen, da ist noch nicht mal eine Entrauchungsanlage drin.
Ich hab auch so den Eindruck, dass die Fluchttunnel nicht richtig dimensioniert wurden. Also, keine Ahnung, was ihr so aus diesen Informationen herausseht, aber ich denke mir, mit Chance, mit Glück ist das Ende des Jahres vielleicht unter Umständen irgendwann fertig. Aber ich kann mir das irgendwie nicht so richtig vorstellen, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, das würde dann den Ausdruck sportlich schon neu definieren, oder?
Ja, das wäre in der Tat sportlich.
Aber so langsam interessiert es mich auch gar nicht mehr, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, vor allem, es gibt ja auch ganz andere Events, die in Berlin abgehen. Berlin ist ja überhaupt das Zentrum der Welt, wie wir auch diese Woche gerade wieder mitbekommen. Eine ganz heiße Veranstaltung findet hier statt, auf der wir heute auch waren. Also ich zum Beispiel und der Mapp.
Venus 2012.
Als Lein-Darsteller, oder?
Kategorie Internet-Nachwuchs.
Ja, wir haben natürlich den Preis bekommen, den goldenen Rory für die sinnloseste Verwendung des Wortes Pony in einem Podcast. Nee, Campus Party heißt das Trainwreck, was da gerade irgendwie am Start ist.
Trainwreck ist das jetzt schon...
Was?
Das ist schon der Anfang.
Vielleicht, wer noch nichts davon gehört hat, und das dürften wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute nicht, weil es ist irgendwie allein diese Veranstaltung irgendwie bekannt zu machen.
Aber die haben schon sehr viel getrommelt.
Ja, wo denn?
Doch, überall.
Ja, aber die haben halt einfach auf Basis von Zero Credibility getrommelt. Und das ist nun mal nicht ganz...
Aber das machen die doch nicht zum ersten Mal, oder?
Naja, in Berlin schon. Also das Ganze hat wohl irgendwie eine lange Geschichte. Die sind nun schon seit zehn Jahren oder länger unterwegs. Und das Ganze hat sich so aus dieser LAN-Party-Szene herausentwickelt. Die haben da irgendwann mal mit 200 Leuten angefangen. Und ist dann irgendwie immer größer geworden. Und macht so einen Eindruck, als träumen sie halt davon, diese Veranstaltungen einfach so multiethematisch zu verorten, wie es irgendwie geht. Und halten sich da auch selber ganz ordentlich ab. Und dann haben sie das auch in andere Länder getragen. Also von Spanien, wo es herkommt, dann eben so im lateinamerikanischen Raum. Ich glaube, in Mexiko waren sie. Und auch im Südamerika irgendwo. Brasilien. Und es sei immer ja total groß und erfolgreich gewesen. Aber tausende Leute seien da hingekommen. Und da haben sie dann auch dieses Konzept entwickelt, der Discount-Teilnahme, so dass man da irgendwie hinkommt. Und dann stellen sie da irgendwie tonnenweise Zelte auf, wo man dann halt übernachten kann. Naja, und jetzt weiß ich nicht, was sie so gerockt hat, aber irgendwann hat wohl einer im Schlaf von...
Ich hab Gerüchte halber gehört, das hätte eigentlich in Barcelona stattfinden sollen. Und in der letzten Minute haben sie es dann irgendwie, weil es in Barcelona nicht stattfinden konnte, nach Berlin verlegt.
Ach.
So. Und deswegen hätten sie jetzt auch so viele Menschen aus Spanien mit dem Bus hierher gefahren, weil die schon Karten hatten.
Ach, darum ist auch Telefonica Sponsor und sowas.
Ja, ja, genau. Also das ist extrem spanisch geprägt in jeder Hinsicht. Das merkt man auf dieser Webseite an. Also da, wo sie irgendwie nicht vollständig auf Englisch übersetzt, das schimmert immer so spanisch durch.
Ja, ja, auch in der Ull oben ist immer irgendwas spanisch.
Ja, das kommt einem ganz schön spanisch vor.
Ich hab mir die ganze Zeit diesen Witz verknüpfen.
Ich bin mir ja für nichts zu schade. Und naja, dann haben sie irgendwie EU-Förderung bekommen. Das Ganze ist irgendwie auch hoch aufgehängt. Und so gefühlt seit einem halben Jahr trommeln die halt hier in der Berliner Szene ein. Und versuchen irgendwie an allen möglichen etablierten Institutionen zu zupfen, ob sie denn das nicht auch total toll finden würden. Und wer denn da nicht alles reden und kommen würde. Und haben sie da irgendwie Tim Berners-Lee eingeflogen oder werden eingeflogen haben oder ist ja schon da?
Ich glaube es ist irgendwie Freitag oder Samstag.
Ja, sowas und andere bekannte und weniger bekannte Namen. Und es ist ein wirres, ein wirrer Misch aus irgendwie Security, Hacking, Bastel, Robotik. Also es ist wahllos, ja. Auf Biegen und Brechen, so breit thematisch, wie es nur irgendwie geht. Naja, und haben dann die ganze Zeit damit gewedelt, dass da ja 10.000 Leute kommen. Naja, und dann haben sie sich ausgerechnet Tempelhof ausgesucht als Location. Ja, okay, kann sein, dass da vielleicht mal jemand irgendwie auf eine Idee kommt, wie man das ordentlich bespielen kann. Bei dieser Bread & Butter funktioniert das so in etwa, wenn man da irgendwie viel Geld in Couches und Sofa steckt und ansonsten nur wichtig ist, da Leute ihre Klamotten ausstellen und ein Laufweg irgendwie aufgebaut wird. Dann mag das irgendwie hinhauen. Aber für so was wie eine Konferenz mit Vorträgen, naja, sind diese Räume etwas ungeeignet, weil wer noch nicht da war, Tempelhof besteht im Wesentlichen aus einer Empfangshalle, mehreren Hangars, dann elend langen Büroschläuchen, wo in diesem Halbrund man mehrere Kilometer gehen kann und links und rechts kleine Mini-Büros sind, tonnenweise, und dann halt das Flugfeld davor. Beziehungsweise der bedachte Bereich davor, den sie dann auch genutzt haben. Das heißt, das Ding ist irgendwie Open Air, aber dann doch wieder nicht Open Air, weil sie dann das Loch zum Tempelhofer Feld irgendwie vollgestellt haben mit Containern.
Na wär's Open Air gewesen, wären die jetzt alle nicht mehr da bei dem Regen letzte Nacht.
Das stimmt natürlich, aber naja, nur eine Konferenz willst du halt, also wohl, wenn diese Vorträge wirklich diese Rolle spielen, denen sie ihnen zu, wie sagt man? Zuschreiben, genau. Dann müsste das ja auch wichtig sein. Und dann müsste man ja auch für eine Situation sorgen, an dem man solchen Vorträgen auch, wo man auch teilhaben kann. Das ist nur so, alles ist jetzt in diesem Vorfeld, also alles ist in diesem überdachten Bereich da, wo früher die Passagiere in die Flugzeuge eingestiegen sind bzw. zu den Flugzeugen gegangen sind, die dann vielleicht noch ein paar Meter weiter vorne stehen. Also unter dem Dach und das große Loch, das ist ja kein abgeschlossener Bereich, zum Tempelhofer Feld hin, ist so mit drei Etagen Containern zugestellt. Ab und zu mal ein paar Schlitze, dass man auch noch zwischendurch gehen kann, aber im Wesentlichen ist da irgendwie so eine riesige Wand.
Ich hab ja auch gerade mal zwei Links reingepäßelt von der Zeltstadt, die sie da indoor aufgebaut haben.
Ja, da wollen wir gerade noch draufkommen. Das ist völlig absurd.
Weil das sind größere Zelte als die wirklichen. Also die wirklichen sind noch kleiner hier im Tempelhofen.
Ja genau, das ist schon die Deluxe-Variante. Das ist ja nicht das Tempelhofen, das ist schon irgendwo anders.
Ich hab schon ein Bild irgendwo gesehen, also irgendwo war es schon heute bei Spiegel oder Heise gestern, heute, weiß ich gar nicht.
Ja, komm ich gleich zu. Ich wollte jetzt noch mal kurz die Situation machen. Das heißt, man kommt da so hin und dann ist alles findet quasi in diesem einen Bereich statt. Und dann haben sie acht Bühnen, sechs, acht?
Sechs oder acht.
Ich glaub acht Bühnen so in der Größenordnung. Eine größere und dann sechs, sieben kleinere. So, die alle sich gegenüber liegen und ineinander hineinschallen. Genau. Und die Akustik ist aber auch schon so scheiße, dass selbst wenn nur eine einzige bespielt wird, die Hauptbühne nämlich, dass man nur eine Chance hat, irgendwas zu verstehen, wenn man so in der fünften, sechsten, siebten, achten Reihe vielleicht steht. Und wenn du da nur 20 Meter im Plan bist.
Also, wenn ich ehrlich bin, ich hab in der dritten Reihe schon Probleme, was zu verstehen ist.
Ja, soweit bin ich vorgedrungen.
Aber du bist ja auch Co-Audio erfahren.
Ich weiß.
Das könnte helfen.
Aber ich bin nicht alleine mit dieser Erfahrung. Ich hab mich da schon mit anderen Menschen gesprochen. Aber wenn da noch diese anderen kleinen Bühnen da reinplärren, dann hast du halt endlich keine Chance, mehr irgendwas zu verstehen.
Und die Leute rennen da halt auch noch irgendwie rum und reden und zwischen den Bühnen sind dann halt so die Tische aufgebaut, wo man dann so dran sitzen kann mit seinem Rechner. Und naja, jetzt ist die Versprechung, dass da 10.000 Leute hinkommen. Also nie und nimmer sind da 10.000 Leute. Also das kann man schon mal festhalten. Da sind bestenfalls, was würdest du sagen?
Also ich hab heute, ich weiß nicht, ob das eine offizielle Zahl war oder eine geschätzte, aber irgendwas 2.200 hieß es. Und das könnte so knapp hinkommen.
Warum sagen die auf der Webseite so, ausverkauft 10.000?
Weil sie die Tickets irgendwie in das Fahrt geschmissen haben.
Ich hab ja auch ein Ticket in der Haunen.
Die Spanier haben den Bus nicht gekriegt.
Also diese ganze Organisation hat sich im Vorfeld auch schon als dermaßen verpeilt und durcheinander herausgestellt. Also ich hab von so vielen Gruppen gehört, die angesprochen wurden, denen irgendwie das Blau vom Himmel herunter erzählt wurde, womit, ja, ihr könnt irgendwie hier auch noch diesen Raum nutzen und alles, kein Problem. Dann haben die ja irgendwie schon zugesagt und irgendwie ihre Leute angeschrieben. Und dann ein paar Wochen vorher so, ach ja, ne, übrigens den Raum können wir doch nicht benutzen. Was ist denn so die Nummer? Und dass sie die ganze Sub-Veranstaltung wieder abgesagt haben. Also sowas geht schon mal gar nicht. Dann stellte sich auch heraus, dass die Leute, die da irgendwie Zusagen gemacht haben zu den Zeitungen, noch nicht mal auf diesem Flughafen vorher selbst gewesen sind. Und das war so zwei, drei Monate vor der Veranstaltung. Das muss man sich einfach mal vorstellen. Und viele andere Szenen sollten halt mit reingezogen werden. Manche sind halt dann jetzt gekommen. Einige Leute, denke ich, die wir so kennen, werden da auch mal irgendeinen Talk halten. Nur, das ist ziemlich sicher, dass dir dann niemand zuhören kann.
Also du stehst da auf der Bühne und dann so...
Dann weiter in Spanisch.
Weitere Bahnen...
Weitere bahnenbrechende...
Ich hab das mit diesem Tweet gelesen, da schrieb jemand, oh, ich bin wohl bei der falschen Bühne. Egal, man hört eh von allen Bühnen alles.
Und dann diese Hungars. Also Tempelhof hat ja links und rechts drei große Hungars. Also sechs große Hungars. Und in diesen Hungars befinden sich halt nur diese Zelte. Das sind so blaue O2-gebrandete Zelte.
Ich würde ganz sagen, wessen Idee ist das denn, die alle blau zu machen? Und kommst du mich nachher noch im Zelt? Und mein Zelt ist das blaue, auf dem der Motor drauf steht.
Und halt auch alles irgendwie werbungsdurchsetzt, das so sponsordominated.
Man hätte vielleicht auch andere Farben nehmen können.
Und dann kommst du wirklich in so einen Hangar, der wirklich so komplett einheitlich mit diesen Zelten ist. Und ich dachte sofort, Alien. Also überall solche Gebuchtspots irgendwo dann so gleich so Kreaturen heraus. Aber das ist der erste Hangar links und rechts. Sie sind so halbwegs belegt. So in dem darauffolgenden Hangar vielleicht noch bestenfalls die Hälfte ab und zu. Und dann so der dritte Hangar, auch schon der zweite im Wesentlichen leer. Also da stehen komplette Hangars, die man schön hätte für irgendwas nutzen können, zum Beispiel einen Vortrag zu halten, der nicht überstrahlt wird von irgendwas anderem. Einfach leere Zeltstädte, wo irgendwie gelangweiltes Security-Personal rumsitzt und irgendwie unbenutzte Toiletten bewacht.
Also es ist völlig über die Hälfte aller Zelte leer, definitiv. Man hätte da ein Zelt haben können, um dann dort zu übernachten, oder was war die Idee davon?
Ja, du kannst dann da Geld dafür zahlen, dass du da...
Man zahlt da Geld für nein.
Naja, es ist bisher... Ich weiß nicht, also ich hab jetzt noch niemanden getroffen, der schon jemanden mal getroffen hat, der Geld bezahlt hat.
Also alle haben irgendwie...
Also ist das so wie bei der Next?
Irgendwie weiß ich nicht, ist das da auch so?
Also ich weiß das... Oder wie heißt diese Web 2.0, diese aus Amerika gekommene Konferenz?
Ach, O'Reilly.
Genau, die dann im ICC war.
Jaja, diese O'Reilly Konferenz.
Kann ich da auch mit meinem Telekom-Zelt hin? Überhaupt mit einem eigenen Zelt?
Nee, nee, nee. Wenn du rein willst, wird nämlich dein Gepäck komplett durchkempt.
Die Security, das ist immer ein großer Spaß. Also die durchsuchen dein Gepäck.
Die durchsuchen dein Gepäck. Du musst alles auspacken. Ich glaube, es geht hauptsächlich darum, dass du keinen Alkohol mit reinträgst.
Ja, die sind ja auch sehr straight.
Du kannst da keinen Alkohol kaufen, du darfst keinen Alkohol reintragen. Sie nennen das Party.
Eine Party ohne Alkohol, wer was kann?
Aber es gibt alkoholfreies Bier. Also ich finde, unsere 100. Folge sollte auf jeden Fall unter Alkohol stattfinden.
Jetzt bei den Zuschauern oder?
Sowohl als auch.
Also zwangsmäßig. Zwangsmäßig. Jeder, der reinkommt, kriegt erst mal ein Drink.
Weil ich will keine Security, die irgendjemandem Alkohol abnimmt.
Nee, du willst auch nicht irgendwie Leute, also auch alles wird da irgendwie gebadged und gepiept. Und das ist irgendwie vollkommen übertrieben. Wir haben dann mal ausgerechnet, diese Turnaround-Zeit, die man da beim Check-In hat, also wie viel Zeit sie damit verbringen. Man hat selbst genug Zeit, das mal auszumessen. Das ist jetzt wirklich sehr grob geschätzt so. Aber würden wirklich 10.000 Leute kommen, dann würde es allein 100 Stunden dauern, diese Leute abzufertigen. Also im Wesentlichen würde die gesamte Zeit, die diese Veranstaltung dauert, benötigt werden, bis dann der letzte auch noch ordnungsgemäß ein Eintrittsticket bekommen hat.
Das heißt, ihr habt länger am Check-in gestanden, als ihr tatsächlich dann am Ende da wart.
Ja, so schlimm war es nicht, aber es war schon alles relativ verspult und es war einfach alles so...
Es ist alles total Kafkaesque. Du kommst da rein, kriegst irgendwelche Aufkleber, du weißt nicht, was diese Aufkleber bedeuten. Die einen haben blaue Aufkleber, die anderen haben orange Aufkleber. Die wird nicht gesagt, was jetzt eigentlich? Da musst du dich irgendwie zurechtfinden und suchen, wo dein Badge herkommen soll, weil das hat irgendwas mit Aufklebern zu tun, aber du weißt nicht genau, was. Und dann musst du dadurch Security durch, wirst irgendwie einmal komplett durchgefilzt, fühlst dich dann irgendwie auch schon komplett verwirrt, stellst dich dann für Zelte an, wirst dann irgendwie rumdirigiert, je nachdem welche Aufkleber du bekommen hast im Zuge vorher.
Für Zelte angestellt? Wieso das denn? Ach, du übernachtest da? Ach so, ach so.
Ich geb mal das volle Programm. Ich muss ja irgendwie auch fundiert jammern können. Das Geilste ist, wenn du was trinken willst. Bei mir wird immer fundiert gejammert. Wenn du was zu trinken oder zu essen willst, dann musst du dir erst eine Marke besorgen. Und in dieser Marke kriegst du dann was zu essen. Oder was zu trinken. Die Marke besorgst du dir draußen, wo es nicht überdacht ist. Und Trinken besorgst du dir drinnen, wo es überdacht ist. Und wenn es regnet, wie sau, wie gestern Abend, dann musst du einmal durch den Regen, um eine Marke zu kaufen, und dann im Trockenen was zu trinken.
Spanien, da regnet es nicht. Aber das ist ja auch sehr interessant. Sie haben da Busladung Spanier angekarrt. Und überhaupt hatte ich den Eindruck, dass die Mehrheit der Teilnehmer im Wesentlichen alles Spanier sind. In Berlin. Das heißt, wenn du die Spanier weggelassen hättest, wäre wahrscheinlich niemand da gewesen.
Was ja für Berlin eigentlich noch ein relativ typischer Zustand ist.
Naja, also zumindest hätten ja auch... Also ist jetzt nicht so, dass da jetzt kein Deutscher oder sonst irgendeine andere Nationalität zu sehen gewesen wäre. Es ist nur extrem auffällig, wie überproportional offensichtlich spanische Menschen dort repräsentiert sind. Da hab ich ja auch gar nichts gegen. Das ganze Orga-Team ist auch spanisch. Also die reißen das sozusagen komplett mit ihrer eigenen... ähm, mit ihrem eigenen Team. Die natürlich hier alle fremd sind. Und die hier eben, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich etwas bei Null anfangen müssen. So kulturell, tralala, etc. Nicht unbedingt die besten Voraussetzungen für so eine Veranstaltung. Ich hab das Gerücht gehört, dass die nächstes Jahr das wieder machen wollen in Berlin.
Fänd ich mutig. Fänd ich mutig.
Das fände ich allerdings auch sehr mutig.
Aber es kann nur besser werden, ne?
Dass du das vorher erstmal alles sagen und alles positiv darstellen, ist ja klar. Wart mal ab in fünf Tagen.
Ja, aber man merkt auch, dass das ganze Konzept einfach nicht aufgeht. Also das ist so offensichtlich, dass dieses ganze Konferenz-Getur und irgendwie Rösler einladen und Nelly Gröss und keine Ahnung und Tim Berners-Lee, der dann irgendwie da vor so verspulten Lahn-Party irgendwie eine Rede hält, die in der dritten Reihe schon nicht mehr verstanden wird. Ich meine, was soll das? Hätte man das ganze Geld, was sie auf diese Veranstaltung genommen, so und es einfach direkt in die Projekte, die sie sich da vorstellen, reingesteckt, dann hätte man wahrscheinlich echt Fortschritt gemacht. Aber so ist es einfach nur eine Ausgabe in Containermiete, Security, Personal, Bauzaun und keine Ahnung.
Ja, ich hab halt so das Gefühl, es wird eigentlich nur Promomaterial für die nächste Campus-Party generiert. Es werden irgendwie schöne Fotos gemacht, es werden die Teile fotografiert, die nicht komplett leer sind und irgendwie man kann dann hinterher sagen, es waren 10.000 Leute da, weil überprüft ja eh niemand mehr. Und man hat dann irgendwie für das nächste Mal schon mal die Eckdaten, dass man wieder irgendwie...
Um wieder EU-Gelder abzugreifen.
Genau und sagt so, das Las Vegas der Nerds oder was auch immer, der die Trackline war. Ja, also es ist alles mehr Schein als Sein an der Stelle, glaube ich.
Was ist denn das, also was ist denn das für eine Veranstaltung? Also Vorträge kann man nicht hören, was machen die Leute, die da sind? Also sich langweilen, sitzen die rum an ihrem Computer oder...
Im Wesentlichen sitzen da alle rum, laufen von links nach rechts und schauen, ob irgendwo da hinten in der Ecke irgendwas passiert, was sie bereichern könnte.
Und dann haben sie noch nicht mal Alk und Bund ist auch nicht.
Die haben nicht mal WLAN.
Es gibt zwei Sorten von WLAN.
Naja, also sie haben gesagt, es gibt keinen WLAN, das war so die vorherige Aussage. Es gibt WLANs. Ich hab es mir aber nicht gelungen, mich in eins einzubuchen, die sind natürlich total überlastet.
Ja, die gehen aber so halbwegs.
Das ist vollkommen unklar. Ich meine, da stehen auch so Desktop-Rechner rum. Also rein so von der typischen Rechner-Art, die so da vertreten ist bei den Leuten, die halt wirklich da an den Tischen sitzen, was eben nicht so viele sind. Also die meisten Tische sind leer. Das ist so ein bisschen wie Kongress vor 10 Jahren, als sich Laptops noch nicht so richtig durchgesetzt hatten. Also sind so richtig so diese gepimpten, blau leuchtenden oder weiß lackierten Gamer-Oldschool-PCs.
Die meinen alle Bitcoins.
Hätte man sowas denn mitnehmen können? Also ich meine, da kannst du doch locker eine Flasche drin verstecken, oder?
Mal eine neue Club-Mate-Kühlung. Das ist ganz wichtig hier. Ja, ach ich weiß nicht, also das ist, ich will ja jetzt gar nichts, will es hier nicht, nicht so eine Szene schlechtreden, weil ich kann mir ja durchaus vorstellen, dass das so in Spanien, dass das da auch so mal eine lebendige Kultur hat, dass sie da auch wirklich diese Teilnehmerzahlen erzielen, die sie behaupten, erzielt zu haben. Kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen. Aber was ihnen einfach überhaupt nicht gelungen ist, wo ich glaube auch, dass sie sich einfach maßlos überschätzt haben oder das einfach blind ignoriert haben, das weiß ich auch nicht, man geht nicht einfach so nach Berlin und macht hier eine Großveranstaltung. Nee, da geht man nach Hamburg.
Ja, da geht man nach Hamburg.
Weil, die haben zwar alles probiert, hier irgendwie auch Leute, die hier irgendwie organisatorisch in andere Veranstaltungen eingebunden waren, akquiriert, die dann hier quasi die Agenten waren und die auch alle möglichen Gruppen angesprochen haben. Aber das Paket hat am Ende keinen überzeugt, weil es war halt so, hallo, wir wollen irgendwie alles sein, alles gleichzeitig, ja, und wir haben vor allem viel, viel Bühnen, viel Themen, viel Leute, die sie nicht haben, viel Security, viel Bauzaun und wenig Alkohol und das soll jetzt sozusagen, das soll jetzt hier irgendjemand begeistern, aber sowas, ich meine, sowas jagt hier einfach in Berlin keinen vom Stuhl. Das ist einfach, hier willst du irgendwie eine Veranstaltung haben und besuchen, die irgendwie einen klaren Fokus hat, die irgendwie sagt, das ist das, worum wir uns kümmern, das ist irgendwie unsere Community, davon wird das getragen und hier gibt es das Bier. Und da drüben könnt ihr rauchen. Was ist überhaupt der Grund für diese Alkohol-Para? Ist das so, weil wir so jugendlich, also so jugendlich war das jetzt auch nicht. Ich meine, es war jugendlich, aber es war ja nicht alles so Minderjährige, die jetzt irgendwie geschützt werden müssen.
Ich hab in der FAQ gelesen, dass sie ja dann irgendwie Sorge haben, dass da irgendwie der große Riot ausbricht.
Na wahrscheinlich ist das dann in Spanien so, dass wenn sich dann alle besaufen, aber das ist ja hier auch in Spanien.
Wenn es so scheiße ist und dann noch Alk dazu kommt, dann rasten ja natürlich alle aus.
Was ich nicht verstehe, sie hätten ja genug Security vor Ort.
Vielleicht haben sie Angst, dass die Security am Alkohol vergreift.
Wobei die hat ja öfter mal eine Alkoholfahne.
Ich hab da auch so Horrorstories gehört, dass man seinen Laptop vor allem mit Seriennummern registrieren muss und so.
Das kommt wahrscheinlich auch aus dieser Landpartyszene, dass du die Rechner halt nicht einfach raustragen darfst. Sie wollen halt damit sicherstellen, dass nichts geklaut wird. Ja, die Intention ist irgendwie so, dass du dir hier unten so einen Aufkleber draufkleben lassen und deine Seriennummer irgendwie abgeben dafür. Und dann wird er halt, wenn du rausgehst, wird er auch nochmal drüber gepiepst über diesen Barcode und dann ist es okay, weil dann gucken sie halt, dass du das bist, der den rausträgt.
Aber die Seriennummer haben sie so auch nicht gecheckt, du hättest deinen Aufkleber auf eine andere Büchse draufmachen können und damit rauslatschen.
Ja, ja, das ist auch total absurd, weil die, die diese ganze Seriennummerverwaltungsding machen, das ist der spanische Team und die, die kontrollieren, ist natürlich die zugemietete Berliner Security und dann hab ich mich halt mit dieser Berliner Security unterhalten und dann meinten die so, sie verstehen auch nicht, was der Scheiß soll und sie piepsten hier einfach nur, damit es halt piepst. Und dann fragte mich so, muss das du eigentlich die Seriennummer hinterlegen überhaupt für das Gerät? Und dann meinte ich so, ja, ja, ach ja, dann ist das hier sicher.
Ja, und dann ist es auch so völlig absurd. Ich hatte so meine Tasche oben und dann fragte ich, ist da noch ein Computer drin? Und dann meinte ich so, ja, zog den halt so raus, zeigte ihm, war alles okay. Nicht, dass jetzt einer geguckt hätte, ob ich da noch einen drin hab oder so. Also es war totale Sicherheitssimulation. Und ich meine, wenn du das zu Ende denkst und du jetzt wirklich ein, in Anführungsstrichen, sicheres System etablieren willst, dann musst du da ja so Nazi-Orville-mäßig unterwegs sein, wie es ja auch schon nicht mehr zu vertragen ist. Und vor allem für so eine Baller-Baller-Veranstaltung wirkt das einfach so dermaßen neben der Spur. Da findet man einfach echt keine Worte mehr.
Wäre es nicht sinnvoller gewesen, einfach irgendwo Tresor hinzustellen, wo man, also Schließfächer, wo man die Dinge einschließt?
Kann man die Wasserflaschen mitnehmen?
Ja.
Da gibt es nämlich ein schönes Video auf YouTube, wie man eine 05er-Wasserflasche mit Vodka befüllt und die so aussieht, als wäre das Siegel nicht gebrochen. Du wirst lachen, sie riechen an Flaschen. Ja, aber wenn die noch zu ist, also weißt du, so das Verschlusssiegel abwärts. Da könntest du Glück haben, aber sie sind sich echt nicht so blöd an Flaschen zu riechen.
Also völlig...
Ah, Vodka riecht doch nicht.
Du kommst da an und du kriegst nur die Botschaft, irgendwie wir trauen dir nicht und Spaß sollst du ja auch keinen haben. Willkommen auf der Campus-Party. Na, weil sie, ich meine, andere Kultur. Ich meine, dass das in Berlin...
Aber Spanier sind ja nun nicht gerade irgendwie ein total abstinentes Volk, wenn ich das Recht in Erinnerung habe.
Nein, aber keine Ahnung, welche Erfahrungen, die in ihrer LAN-Party-Szene gemacht haben, mit Saufen. Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Es ist nur meine Vermutung, dass das auf Erfahrung basiert. Die andere Theorie könnte sein, dass das irgendwie, weil EU-Förderung und Jugend, dass sie da so eine Auflage haben, mit aber bloß kein Alkohol. Also das ist einfach unrund.
Haben wir mehr Themen mit Alkohol vielleicht? Jetzt, nachdem wir quasi schon 15 Stunden über Alkohol-Sympathie stehen.
Wir können das glaube ich mit der Campus-Party auch abschließen. Ich will auch nochmal über einen anderen Aspekt dann auf das nächste Thema kommen und zwar Telefonica und O2 sind ja sozusagen da Sponsoren. Und da ja WLAN da sozusagen nicht drin war, versuchte ich halt irgendwie anderweitig mit meinem iPhone, also meinen Laptop habe ich gar nicht rausgeholt, ich versuchte halt irgendwie mit meinem iPhone eine Kommunikation zu betreiben. Das ging gar nicht. Also es war einfach dicht und ich ja O2-Netz und so. Also ich befand mich sozusagen auf der O2-Veranstaltung, schaute mich um und tatsächlich haben sie da sogar eine eigene Basisstation, wie ich später erfuhre, 2 vor Ort. Also sie haben tatsächlich das noch gemacht. Die Situation wurde aber allein dadurch schon, wenn WLAN nicht funktioniert, gehen sie eh alle auf Mobilfunk. Das kennen wir ja schon mal so. Aber dann haben sie natürlich für die ganzen Spanier tonnenweise, weil die natürlich alle nur spanische Mobilfunkkarten haben, wo sie sich hier zu Tode bezahlen würden, haben die da tonnenweise kostenlose Prepaid-Karten rausgegeben, sodass also auch noch alle Telefone in dieser Halle von diesen 2000 Leuten dann auch noch extra zusätzlich in O2 eingebucht wurden. Und telefonieren konnte man zwar irgendwie, aber so Datenverkehr ging irgendwie gar nicht. Und dann war ich schon so ein bisschen gelangweilt und wollte eigentlich los und dachte mir so, hier ist doch bestimmt ein O2-Stand noch irgendwo.
Die Arme sind die! Auf der Suche nach dem Balken.
Ich hab eine halbe Stunde zugeguckt, wie Tim diesen O2-Menschen fertig macht und hab mir dann gedacht, jetzt geh ich woanders hin.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn Tim, wenn die Amerikaner von Tim wüssten, würden sie nach Guantanamo Bay als Folter-Experten schicken, oder?
Also ich muss gleich mal...
Was weißt du über Kalender?
Ich muss gleich mal vorweg sagen, ich hab da mit dem O2-Guru gesprochen, der irgendwie ein T-Shirt anhatte, wo draufsteht, frag mich alles. Nach der wievielten Frage hat er gepasst? Der Typ war total cool, wusste wirklich Bescheid und war voll nett und zugänglich und alles. Also ich hab auch wirklich auf meine Fragen interessante Antworten bekommen. Und kam dann auch gleich hier so mit meinem schon beklagten Urlaubsthema und O2 im Ausland und so weiter hat man ja auch schon besprochen, so wir drosseln dich mal und dann versuchen wir über diese gedrosselte Leitung eine Website abzurufen, womit du dein nächstes Datenpaket kaufen kannst und so. Da meinte er so, ja, da hätte er auch so einen Tweet gesehen, wo sich jemand so ähnlich beklagt hätte. Und da habe ich ein paar interessante Informationen rausbekommen. Also erstens, du wirst im Ausland nicht nur auf GPRS gedrosselt, sondern du wirst noch mal unter GPRS gedrosselt. Du wirst auf zwei Kilobit.
Ja.
Also ein 500er Modem, also ein 56k Modem wäre wirklich schon unvorstellbar schnell im Vergleich dazu.
GPRS könnte schon noch ein bisschen mehr. Da geht dann so 64k, aber das geht dann halt auch nicht, weil teuer.
Ja, gab es bei den Browsern ja noch den ohne Images-Button, den gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Doch, den gibt es.
Hat er sich denn weggeduckt, nachdem er das gesagt hat?
Na, der war Customer Service, der war glaube ich schon so einiges gewohnt. Ich hab übrigens im Ausland, das hab ich glaube ich gar nicht erzählt, hab ich iCAP benutzt. Also das war sozusagen die einzige Möglichkeit, mit dieser Datenmenge noch überhaupt seine Informationen zu kommen. Entweder Twitter so lange offen lassen, bis irgendwann mal ein Request auch durchkommt, das funktioniert so ein bisschen. Oder halt iCAP mit Bilder aus und Google-Mobilizer benutzen, das hat er nämlich als Option. Und dann kriegst du halt so extrem mega verschlangte Essenzen, die zwar nicht mehr schön aussehen, aber...
Essenzen von Webseiten.
Keine Spuren von ein bisschen enthalten.
Keine Spuren von Informationen enthalten, genau.
Naja, so. Und dann priesen sie da halt irgendwie vor Ort natürlich LTE, etc. Ich hab mir da erstmal nahegelegt, dass doch mal die Mobilfunkbetreiber überlegen sollten, mal generell einen Nerd-Tarif anzubieten. Also erstmal nicht so ein Quatsch mit irgendwie, du hast jetzt dein Kontingent verbraucht, wir drosseln dich jetzt runter. Ich mein, das geht einfach nicht. Ich bin ja nicht beim Provider, damit er mir dann nicht mehr providet. Wenn ihm das zu teuer ist, dann sollen sie mein Geld nehmen. Aber sie wollen ja mein Geld nicht. Da hab ich dann die Information herausbekommen, dass man wohl seit kurzem, irgendwie seit ein paar Monaten tatsächlich, wenn man seine 5 GB verbraucht hat, ein halbes GB dazu kaufen kann. Für 5 Euro, glaube ich. Aber auch nur einmal. Warum auch immer.
Na die wollen halt, dass du dauerhaft den teuren Tarif nimmst.
Es gibt theoretisch noch den alten Tarif, den ich ja auch vorher hatte, wo 10 GB waren. Das waren die dann doch zu teuer. Nur der war halt mit dieser Kostenfalle verbunden, dass wenn du über die 10 GB rauskommst, dann zahlst du sozusagen für jedes Bit auch eine Marke.
Stimmt, das wär ja so mal ein Problem.
Ja, genau. Über Weihnachten haben die mir eine irrsinnige Summe an Daten ausgewiesen, die ich angeblich verbraucht hätte. Die ich aber nicht verbraucht habe, weil da war ich auf dem Kongress und hab...
Da gibt's ein perfektes W-Laden.
Da gibt's immer noch das beste W-Laden. Aber ich hab da nicht die ganze Zeit... Ich bin da rumgelaufen, hab mit Leuten geredet. Ich hab da nicht die ganze Zeit gesurft, schon gar nicht hunderte von Megabytes hoch oder runtergeladen. Also das war definitiv eine Falschausweisung. Hab da jetzt nicht angefangen, einen Rechtsanwalt anzurufen, das ist mir dann auch zu blöd. Ich hab einfach die Konsequenz gezwungen. Hab gesagt, okay, dann bucht mich mal auf euren Normaltarif. Das waren dann halt diese 5 Gigabyte, die dann aber eben abscheiden. Aber das ist natürlich einfach Blödsinn. Das müssen die einfach ändern. Dann meinte ich so, na ja, hier so O2-Netz und Einzelfall. Und so meinte er, na ja, das wäre mal ganz gut gewesen, die Aktion, wir sind Einzelfall. Weil das auch so ein bisschen so ein Wandel auch befördert hätte. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass der jetzt so vollständig eingeleitet wurde. Aber so dieses Grundprinzip, dass man doch vielleicht mal eher offen ist und vielleicht mal so da hingeht und sagt, hier gibt es Probleme. Was ja auch gut ist, weil dann auch die Kunden nicht immer gleich durchdrehen. Und dann kam er irgendwie auf Zugnetze. Weil ich meinte ja hier so O2 im Zug. Ist ja immer richtig scheiße. Und ich dachte halt immer, das liegt am Ausbauen. Meinte er, nee, das hat einen anderen Grund. Das war mir echt neu. Und das habe ich jetzt noch nicht gedoublecheckt. Ich gebe das jetzt erst mal so weiter, wie ich es gehört habe. Vielleicht stimmt das auch nicht so genau. Aber es war auch nach ein paar Nachfragen für mich immer noch halbwegs plausibel. Und zwar haben alle die CEs und Züge halt Repeater drin, weil die ja generell irgendwie so verredetische Käfig sind. Das ist ja sozusagen defaultmäßig immer installiert. Übrigens auch in Regionalzügen, was ich nicht wusste. Genau. Und die sind aber alle so vor 10, 15 Jahren, 20 Jahren da irgendwie reingebaut worden. Und waren sozusagen geeicht für die damals verfügbaren Mobilfunknetze. Und das waren Telekom, D2 Mannes Mann, also jetzt Vodafone und E+. Und Viac Intercom war da halt noch nicht da. Und Viac Intercom hat Frequenzen benutzt in diesem E-Band, die diese Repeater nicht unterstützen.
Aber jetzt mal ganz kurz Stopp, weil ich als Telekom Opfer, bei mir ist das Netz im Zug auch scheiße. Also es muss...
Aber weniger scheiße als O2.
Du warst im Nicht-Handy-Netz, im Nicht-Handy-Abteil.
Es ist noch beschissener bei O2.
Ja, aber 3G können die gar nicht. Welches Netz? Diese Repeater, das ist ja sowieso nur, nur altes D-Netz halt.
Ja, oder E-Netz.
Oder E-Netz, also aber 3G oder sowas, das können diese Repeater ja eh nicht.
Genau, es gibt neue Repeater, die das natürlich alles können. Und die werden auch von der Bahn nach und nach eingebaut. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie bei der Bahn eine Task Force Repeater gebaut zusammengestellt hätten, die jetzt irgendwie in schwarzen Anzügen sich von Hochhäusern abseilt und anfängt irgendwie diese Repeater an allen Zügen zu verteilen.
Wie es jetzt so erwarten gewesen wäre.
Sondern das ist sozusagen, wenn der Zug dann mal irgendwann saniert und restauriert und renoviert wird, so nach 20 Jahren, dann bauen sie auch neue Repeater ein.
Das heißt, die ICE3 und die abgedateten 1, oder welche haben sie abgedatet, die 1 haben sie abgedatet.
Also wir kriegen dann alle 3.
Da soll es, und das wäre jetzt nochmal interessant, da Erfahrungsbilder auch zusammen, da würde es dann besser auch funktionieren. Ich meine, ich kann nicht behaupten, dass ich immer schlechten Empfang habe, sondern ich hab's mal, das ist katastrophal, aber du bist ja auch immer woanders. Deswegen kann man das nicht so ohne Weiteres immer auf den Zug Münzen so. Aber das würde mich jetzt auch mal interessieren, ob da was dran ist. Und ich hab mir jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt dieses Frequenzbild noch nicht jetzt genau angeschaut, was da eigentlich Viac Intercom für Frequenzen verwendet, die die anderen nicht verwenden etc. Aber na gut, das war zumindest jetzt die Theorie. Müssen wir mal schauen. Sprich, die Bahn müsste handeln.
Gibt's nicht so Repeater für selber so ein USB-Stick-Format?
Wo willst du den ranmachen?
Wo machst du den im Zug ran?
An's DSL?
Der Zug hat halt eine Hände draußen und hat eine innen drin und strahlt sie da durch. Wie willst du das machen?
Du bist halt im Käfig. Du bist halt im Metallkäfig.
Zum Fenster raus. Ach so, die kann man die Fenster nicht aufmachen. So ein kleines Hämmerchen, ein Loch reinschlagen und dann aufs Fenster hängen.
So ein Mikroloch in die Scheibe und dann von außen mit so einem Saugnapf irgendwie.
Dieses Handy-freie Zone ist wahrscheinlich sozusagen einfach nur ein Wagen, wo sie den Repeater wieder abmontiert haben. Also das müsste man nochmal bestätigen oder vielleicht mal testen. Da wäre ich mal für Feedback auch.
Was ist denn da dran, dass irgendwie die Bahn zusammen mit Vodafone D2 irgendwie im Boot sitzt?
Naja, Vodafone ist ja auch Aqor und Aqor ist das alte Netz der Bahn. Also die Bahn hat ja mal ihre Wegstrecken. Wie hieß Aqor, bevor es Aqor hieß? War das auch Mannes Mann oder war das nochmal, war das schon D2 auch und dann haben sie das Aqor genannt?
Aqor ist doch, die haben doch irgendwann mal sich zusammengetan. Aqor und Vodafone.
Ja und auf jeden Fall das, was Aqor sozusagen, das was unter Aqor an Wegerecht genutzt wird, wo die Glasfaserkabel durch dieses Land laufen, das ist sozusagen oder war ursprünglich Bahnwege. Das haben ja alle, quasi die Wegerechte in Deutschland haben, haben ja bei diesem Glasfaserspiel mitgespielt.
Aqor, ein Joint Venture von Mannesmann und Deutsche Bank. Daraus sind die hervorgegangen. Namens Communications Network International, CNI, das war der Vorgänger von Aqor.
Genau, also wenn du jetzt sagst, dass da was ist, dann könnte das auf diese historische Herkunft leiten. Ansonsten haben sie im Wesentlichen die mit der Telekom, soweit ich weiß, was jetzt diese Internetverbindung betrifft. Es gibt ja WLAN mit Telekom Hotspot in manchen. ICEs. Und das ist nicht LTE, wie heißt noch mal dieses andere? WiMAX?
Ja, WiMAX ist das.
Habe ich das schon mal gesagt und es war falsch? Ich weiß es jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau. Das habe ich auf jeden Fall mal gehört. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz sicher. Aber ich glaube, dass diese Züge quasi über WiMAX angebunden sind. Dass sie deshalb in der Lage sind, da Internet-Performance reinzukriegen. Es ist nicht so, dass sie sich von 3G-Mobilfunkstation zum Mobilfunkstation hangeln. Sondern der Zug hat quasi WiMAX-Connectivity entlang dieser Strecken. Deswegen ist es ja auch nur auf bestimmten Strecken. Also da Köln, München, Frankfurt, da gibt es ja so ein paar Löcher. Und das wollen sie jetzt wohl auch ausbauen. Ich glaube, da gab es eine Ankündigung. War das von der Telekom oder war das von der Bahn oder von beiden? Dass sie da wohl so in den nächsten Jahren dann mal Attacke machen wollen, dass es mal überall Internet gibt. Was ja auch mal zu begrüßen wäre.
Aber es gibt sich ja noch ein paar Facts, ja.
Wobei das ja nicht so unser Ding ist eigentlich.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß. Aber heute, weil wir einen Gast haben, können wir mal so einen Eindruck hinterlassen, als wären wir jetzt... Also 1996 hatte die CNI 49 Prozent der DB KOM dem ausgegliederten Telekommunikationsbereich der Deutschen Bahn übernommen. Also die haben das dann auch im Nachhinein übernommen, quasi sozusagen. Und dann Festnetz haben sie sich von Otello gekauft.
Otello?
Kennt ihr das noch?
Verdankt.
Otello, die hatten auch so Internet by Call und so. Daher kenne ich die vor allen Dingen, weil ich irgendwie früher... Internet by Call, ja. Mit einem Kabel durchs Wohnzimmer der Eltern.
Ich hab jetzt meinen Provider gewechselt, weil ich ja mit O2 so unglücklich war. Und hab mir so eine Kongstar-Karte geholt.
Hast du die letzte Sendung schon gesehen?
Da hatte ich sie ja noch nicht. Oder ich weiß es nicht mehr, oder war die noch nicht aktiviert. Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall hab ich mir jetzt diese Kongstar-Karte geholt. Hab eine Anrufweiterleitung. Also hab erst mal noch nicht die Telefonnummer gewechselt auf Anraten eines freundlichen Followers, was glaube ich auch ganz gut war. Das Netz ist soweit ganz okay. Hier in Berlin nicht wirklich besser als bei O2. Aber hier in Berlin ist ja auch das O2-Netz eigentlich ganz gut. Mal gucken, wie es dann außerhalb ist. Was eine totale Katastrophe ist, ist deren Service. Das ist echt schlimm. Von Kongstar. Also es ist sehr offensichtlich eine weiße SIM-Karte. Da steht nur eine Nummer drauf. Da steht kein Provider oder sonst was drauf. Wenn man die reinsteckt, dann hat man hier oben, da wo normalerweise der Provider steht, steht einfach nichts. Das ist doch mal geil. Ich hab die Balken und dahinter hab ich meistens das 3G-Symbol.
Das war actually cool.
Das ist eine weitgelabelte Telekom-Karte. Das sieht man dann daran, dass diese ganzen SIM-Karten-Menüs existieren von der Telekom. Und ich nehme an, dass die so einen internen Krieg haben werden. Dass die Telekom die intern total bekämpft. Weil die können einem nicht mal sagen, wie viel Traffic man schon verbraucht hat. Also nicht nur, dass es... Um das Guthaben auf der Karte abzurufen, da gibt es wenigstens so eine Telefonnummer, die man anrufen kann, wo dann so eine Flash-SMS oder was auch immer das ist, das so auf dem Display anzeigt. Aber wie viele Daten man verbraucht hat, das können die einem nicht sagen. Das kriegt man nicht auf der Rechnung, das kriegt man nicht an einer Hotline, das kriegt man nirgendwo. Das haben die nämlich gar nicht, das hat nur die Telekom. Und die Telekom sagt mir das einfach nicht, wie viele Daten du schon verbraucht hast. Du bist dann einfach irgendwann mal gedrosselt. Und ich hatte da noch Probleme, also wenn man sich so eine Kongstar-Karte holt, was bei denen eigentlich ganz cool ist, die haben sowohl prepaid als auch postpaid zu quasi identischen Tarifen. Also du zahlst, also auch als postpaid kannst du sagen, ok, du zahlst eine einmalige Anmeldegebühr von 25 Euro und dann hast du keinen Vertrag. Also du kannst auch einen Vertrag so über zwei Jahre machen wie bei den anderen. Aber bei denen ist das dann halt so, du kannst auch monatlich deine Datenflatrate kündigen und sowas alles, das geht alles. Man wird auf der Webseite aber nicht so richtig schlau daraus, dass das eine prepaid ist und das andere postpaid, weil das eine heißt prepaid und das andere heißt Tarife. Also hab ich mir eine prepaid-SIM-Karte bestellt, obwohl ich eigentlich eine TarifesIM-Karte hätte haben wollen. Dann hab ich diese Karte gekriegt mit 10 Euro Startguthaben. Ich wollte da erst mal 500 Megabyte drauf buchen, das ging aber nicht, weil ich nur 10 Euro Guthaben hatte. Dann hab ich da lange mit dem Support verbracht, dann hab ich dann 200 Megabyte gekauft, dann hatte ich kein Guthaben mehr. Jedes Mal, wenn ich telefoniert habe, hat er mir vorher angekündigt, dass ich jetzt erst mal doch dringend wieder aufladen sollte, was ich zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon lange hatte. Aber irgendwie braucht diese Abbuchung vom Konto ewig, also ich hab das initiiert. Dann hat es irgendwie fünf Tage gedauert, bis das ganze Geld von meinem Konto abgebucht war. Und dann noch mal drei, vier Tage, bis es bei denen auch wieder drauf gebucht war. Also keine Ahnung, was die da so rumtreibt. Diese Prepaid-Sim-Karte, die kann man so, wenn man einen Datentarif drauf buchen will, erstmal nicht nutzen, sondern muss erst mal vorher aufladen. Das ist relativ bekloppt. Jetzt hab ich das umgestellt, auf dieses Tarifguthaben. Bin mal gespannt, ob das irgendwann auch mal klappt. Also dass ich quasi einen ganz klassischen Postpaid-Vertrag habe. Aber ich hoffe mal, dass die Leitungskualität gut ist. Aber der Service ist wirklich eine Katastrophe. Was gut ist, Tethering und dieses ganze Zeug, das geht alles. Du hast leider keine Multisim-Karten, aber Tessern geht. Tessern, was soll man dann noch so? Also das funktioniert alles absolut problemlos.
Da fällt mir ein, heute hab ich SMS bekommen von der Telekom. Hast du die eigentlich auch bekommen, weil du vorhin so wissend reagiert hast, als ich meinte, dass die Telekom mir eine SMS geschrieben hat, dass ich jetzt mein neues Smartphone reservieren könnte?
Ich hab davon gehört, dass solche Einladungen rumgehen, nicht spezifisch als SMS.
Ich hatte ja irgendwann erzählt, dass ich diesen Vertrag verlängert hab und alles ganz gut und schön ist. Und mein Vertrag ist jetzt tatsächlich auch billiger geworden. Und dass ich ja dann sofort benachrichtigt werden würde, wenn es da dieses neue Smartphone gäbe. The New Smartphone, okay. Und dann hab ich ja nie was Schriftliches bekommen, wo immer diese Dame da am Telefon, ja, also...
Das Blaue vom Himmel.
Genau, also ich kriege ja auf jeden Fall alles noch mal schriftlich und so. Bis heute nichts gekommen, außer dass ich weniger bezahlen muss. Das hab ich schriftlich bekommen. Und heute kamen die SMS, aber ich musste jetzt so eine komische Nummer anrufen und mit dem Telekom-Support telefonieren und dann mal gucken. Ja, mal sehen, wie sich das hier...
In welcher Farbe hättest du denn gern dein Smartphone?
Wo will man dann wissen, in welcher Farbe du kommst?
In MAPS-H-Farbe hätte ich gerne das iPhone.
In welcher von den Haarfarben?
Das ganze Spektrum.
Uh, das neue Rainbow-iPhone.
Vollspektrum.
Ein paar mehr Farben könnte ich schon mal anbieten, oder?
Welche denn?
Na, wie beim iPod.
Braun?
Pink?
Braun war nicht der iPod.
Also, wenn du das ran findest, würde ich glatt nehmen.
Was würdest du nehmen? Orange. Orange und das iPhone?
Beim iPod gab es auch viele bunte iPods.
Also wenn du das Fünfer rauskommst und ich hol mir wieder so einen Bumper, weil ich fand das von Apple eigentlich ganz cool, dann will ich den Bumper in Orange.
Vielleicht alle Farben, collect all five.
Genau, gotta catch them all.
Bin ich zu reich, oder was?
Naja, hast du fünffache Bandbreite.
Du bist da jetzt hier Bitcoin-Millionär, dachte ich.
Ach, Tarife geht schon wieder runter. Letzte Woche ging es irgendwie bergab wieder.
Der hat mal so einen Peak und dann ging es erst mal wieder auf normal Level weiter.
Also wenn wir schon mal bei Bitcoin sind, ich hab ja letzte Woche erzählt, vorletzte Woche, über dieses FPGA-Teil, was ich mir da geschoppt hab, kommt auch, läuft das alles super, alles schick. Da haben jetzt tatsächlich, also, ich hätte vorher mit dem Typen einen Werbevertrag machen sollen, da haben jetzt mehrere Leute gleich da, die sich auch genau das gleiche Ding geordert und mine jetzt auch Bitcoins mit FPGAs.
In deinem Pool wenigstens?
In deinem Pool?
Ja.
Also vielleicht auch in anderen Pools, aber dann, jetzt, da kommen die Jungs, kommen alle zu mir.
Ich hab gehört, dass es so bei Amazon solche Trial-Zeiten geben, in denen man so den...
Das kann sein. Also da, wo Geld drin steckt, da machen die alles. Das ist andauernd auch wieder, die machen auch welche Lottospiele, wo sie sagen, du musst nur 0,3 Bitcoins zahlen, dann hast du die Chance, dass du irgendwie Folgendes bekommst und so. Also, die versuchen alles Mögliche, was es an Geld-Trix-Reise gibt, gibt es auch bei Bitcoins. Also, alles ein Abzocker.
Aber das machen wir alle jetzt nicht nach Tricks, oder?
Nee, ich wollte sagen, da gibt es wohl irgendwie so eine Probezeit, in der man so eine GPU-Probe fahren kann.
Naja, wir alle testen das und gehen da wieder weg und sagen Danke. Richtig? Und machen da Bitcoins.
Aber als Hörer ist das bei mir immer die Stelle bei Mobile Max, wo ich mir denke, Zeitreise, es gibt ja noch Bitcoin und es gibt ja noch Mac-ZFS.
Da kommen wir auch noch drauf.
Da kommen wir auch noch drauf, warte mal mein Freund. Wie Zeitreise.
Aber es gab auch eine Meldung, dass es angeblich Bitcoin Credit Cards geben soll demnächst.
BitInstant oder was der Spiegel da berichtet hat. Es gibt alles mögliche, ich guck mir das alles gar nicht an.
Wenn es da ist, wirst du schon davon.
Nee, es wird schon irgendwie kommen oder auch nicht, aber ich meine mit echtem Geld gucke ich mir auch nicht an, was es alles für Kreditkarten und all den ganzen Scheiß gibt. Aber du bist im Business.
Du bist Notenbank.
Nee, nee, nee.
Ah, du arbeitest dran, verstehe.
Ja, ich meine, der hat da so eine Idee und man könnte ja und irgendwie und überhaupt. Kriege ich auch noch irgendwie einen Ohrsaft? Hab ich schon.
Es ist nämlich heiß.
Na ja, wir weisen uns halt an so Themen fest, wenn wir mal haben.
Wir sind hartnäckig, da kann man die vier Jahre nicht loslassen.
Wenn man sich die beiden mal anguckt, sieht die eine nicht gut aus, oder?
Wir lassen nicht locker.
Timme, ich glaub, die hier, ich will die nicht. Wo wir warten, wenn ich die schütte?
Aber 13, also ist noch nicht abgelaufen.
Es geht gerade um Ohrsaft.
Ohrsaftfarben.
Er sieht eher nach naturtrüben Abelsaft aus.
So, dann will ich aber noch was erzählen, wenn Leute denken, sie können jetzt mit FPGA irgendwie fett Bitcoins verdienen. Überlegt es euch nochmal, weil da soll angeblich, man glaubt es ja nicht so, aber angeblich im Oktober soll ein ASICS kommen. ASICS ist das gleiche eigentlich wie ein FPGA. Ein FPGA kann man programmieren und der ist relativ generisch. Du kannst da deinen Code reinpumpen, wie du willst. Also FPGAs sind nochmal stromsparend als Grafikkarten. Also gerade das neue Ding, also neu auch nicht mehr, aber das, was gerade angesagt ist. So und ASICS ist das gleiche nochmal, nur dass du sie nicht mehr dynamisch programmieren kannst, sondern die werden einmal wie CPUs. Du machst deinen Code da direkt rein, dann wird der Chip so gebrannt und dann ist er fertig. Die kannst du für wenige Dollars herstellen lassen und die erzeugen dann viele Bitcoins für wenig Dollar, für wenig Stromkosten auch. Und die sollen irgendwann im Oktober kommen und wenn das passiert, dann sind die FPGAs alle am Arsch. Aber ob die im Oktober kommen, ist unklar. Ich bin dann auch am Arsch. Ob die im Oktober kommen, ist unklar, aber irgendwann kommen die auf jeden Fall. Deswegen dieses FPGA-Bitcoin-Business ist schon auch sehr riskant.
Du kannst immer noch Krypto knacken mit deinen FPGAs.
Ach, ist das keine sichere Zukunftsanlage, dieses FPGA-Bitcoin? Wer hätte das gedacht?
Aber mit den ASICs dann schon, weil ASICs kann man dann nicht mehr toppen so schnell. Damit werben die auch das. Also die CPUs wurden von Grafikkarten verdrängt, die Grafikkarten wurden von den FPGAs verdrängt und die FPGAs werden demnächst irgendwann mal von diesen ASICs verdrängt und danach gibt es aber keinen nächsten Schritt mehr.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, also Grafikkarten wurden jetzt noch nicht so richtig vollständig von FPGAs verdrängt, vielleicht bei Bitcoins, aber...
Nee, klar, FPGAs hast du ja nicht als Grafikkarte, aber um Bitcoins zu berechnen wurden die Grafikkarten verdrängt.
Also sie werben mit Bitcoin-Mining, oder wie ist das jetzt zu verstehen?
Nein, was? Früher hat man erst mit CPUs gemeint, dann mit Grafikkarten, weil es schneller war.
Weil du hast es gerade so erzählt, als wäre...
Alles im Bitcoin-Kontext.
Das gibt einfach kein anderes Thema.
Wir waren gerade dabei, ich hab nicht mal da was angefangen.
Ruhig, Brauner, ruhig, Brauner, das läuft, das läuft.
Ich wollte ja nur die Leute warnen, dass sie jetzt nicht irgendwie ihr Erbe sozusagen in FPGAs versenken, sondern...
Ihr Bitcoin-Anlageberater, Dennis Haarens, im Gespräch.
Schönen guten Tag, wir wollten Sie nochmal auf das...
Halten Sie auf das nächste Mal wieder ein.
Schön, was war das andere Thema? Da haben wir doch noch was.
Warte kurz mal voran, bist du auch so ein ZFS-Hasser, so wie Max?
Nein, ich hatte viele Hoffnungen und dann hab ich festgestellt...
Und dann hat's plopp gemacht und dann waren die alle weg.
Ich kenne ja diese Menschen so ein bisschen wieder.
Der Osaf ist ein bisschen schimmlig, der sieht so grünlich aus.
Der war offen, alles klar. Ich bringe dir einen neuen.
Du bringst dir einen neuen?
Also ich kenne Menschen, die saßen gleich im Büro, wie die Menschen, die bei Apple ZFS integriert haben und hatte dann erst viel Hoffnung und hatte dann ganz wenig Hoffnung nur noch.
Schon bevor es offiziell war?
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Sag mal überhaupt, hast du gute Insider-Informationen? Nicht welche, nur ob überhaupt?
Man hat so ein bisschen, man kennt so ein paar Leute.
Wenn du in dem gleichen Büro sitzt, dann hast du es auch schon so ein bisschen früher gewusst, oder?
Ich hab nicht, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht mehr genau. Kann sein.
Ich verstehe, wir reden dann nach der Sendung nochmal über Apple.
Aber für mich hat sich das Thema halt erledigt. Ja, ist schon schade. Aber es ist ja auch schön, wenn da immer noch dran gearbeitet wird von englischen Interessanten. Es besteht noch Hoffnung, weil, nachdem sich ja jetzt diese Tense-Complement-Leute selbst desintegriert haben und die Green Bites-Leute, die sie gekauft haben, irgendwie auch nicht so richtig mit offenen Karten spielen, hat dieses alte Mac-ZFS-Projekt, wo irgendwelche Wahnsinnigen der Meinung sind, sie müssten diesen ganz alten Code von Apple zu 10-5 Zeiten, gab's den mal auf MacForge, die basteln an dem rum und sind da aber immer noch auf Pool Version 8 oder so.
Kannst du doch voll vergessen.
Und jetzt hat ein Wahnsinniger, der irgendwie in dieser Hackintosh-Szene, der ex-new Hacker ist, der auch mit Bootloadern und so weiter, weiß ich nicht, rummacht, mehr oder weniger so ein Konzept-Paper geschrieben. Ja, Booten von ZFS, das kriegen wir hin, das machen wir jetzt. Man darf gespannt sein. Also, sie sind jetzt irgendwie bei diesem, also die Mac-ZFS-Leute, die zählen irgendwie nach Open Indiana oder so, Releases? Es gab ja mal von Solaris, gab es ja mal eine Open Source Variante und die hatten so komische interne Nummern, nach denen sie gezählt haben. Und der Branch, den Apple irgendwann mal gemacht hat, C10-5-Zeiten.
Diese Open Solaris-Nummern meinst du?
Genau. Der war zu Open Indiana oder Nevada oder wie das Ding hieß, 72 und sie wollen jetzt dann demnächst den Mac-ZFS-Port von Nevada 77 schaffen, der dann, ich glaube, auch eine Pool-Version oder zwei Pool-Versionen weiter ist.
Warum denn nicht einfach das, was Freeway es nicht so macht?
Ich weiß es nicht. Also es ist aber auf jeden Fall sehr nett anzukurvieren.
Solange die nicht mindestens das schaffen, was Tenz Compliment schon hat, nämlich die Version 28, können die das doch voller einer Pfeife rauchen. Also ich meine, die Versionen gibt es ja. Vielleicht wird jetzt gerade aktiv nicht verkauft, aber ich glaube, Pirate Bay oder irgendwo, du wirst es schon runterladen können und dann hast du ZFS Version 28.
Ja, das Problem ist halt der Mac OS X Virtual File System Layer und das, was ZFS auch unter entweder Open Solaris war oder unter FreeBSD ist, das sind halt so zwei Dinge, die man nur sehr schwer zusammenkriegt. Und deswegen operieren die halt an Code, der funktioniert, auch wenn das nicht so richtig toll tut.
Ich glaube, wir können es einfach mal vergessen.
Aber ich wollte auch gerade sagen, die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben, das erinnert mich an Homer Simpson, als Lisa ihm mal das BBQ-Schwein versaut hat und er dem hinterher... Das kann man doch essen, das ist nur ein bisschen nass geworden. So diese Form von Hoffnung scheint mir das zu sein. Es ist noch nicht vorbei, da sind noch irgendwelche Typen hier.
Aber wenn du noch nicht... Wenn du Insider-Informationen hattest, hast du dann immer noch Informationen. Du kannst das, wir können das so machen. Wenn ich lüge, sagst du einfach nein, ja? Apple entwickelt an einem modernen neuen Fallsystem.
Das sind so viele Attektive in diesem Satz.
Passt doch nicht.
Okay, nochmal.
Du machst das wie Deep Throat by all the presidents men. Wenn Hucke sagt was und wenn es stimmt, dann sagst du einfach nix.
Genau.
Genau. Und wenn ich lüge, sagst du einfach nein. Dann ist ja alles gut. Also Apple entwickelt ein neues Fallsystem. Okay, Apple entwickelt ein modernes Fallsystem.
Da könnte man darüber streiten.
Apple entwickelt an einem Fallsystem, das HFS++ heißt.
Nein.
Sehr schön.
Wahrscheinlich heißt es Objective HFS.
HFS Cloud.
Ich möchte mal kurz mit die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt hier noch mal ein bisschen dran anknüpfen, weil wir haben ja letztes Mal schon ein bisschen darüber geredet und es gab in den Kommentaren zur letzten Sendung einen sehr wertvollen Link, den ich allen mal ans Herz legen möchte. Und zwar ist mir sozusagen da überhaupt ein Fortschritt gewahr geworden. Ihr habt es kurz angesprochen, vielleicht wisst ihr auch schon alles darüber, aber da müssen wir nochmal drüber reden. Und zwar diese Situation mit Solaris und Open Solaris und speziell halt dem Ende von Sun und Oracle. Oracle hat ja Sun gekauft und ehrlich gesagt, ich hab überhaupt nicht verfolgt, was seitdem eigentlich passiert ist. Dieser Link geht auf einen Vortrag von Brian M. Canchel. Hast du den gesehen?
Ich hab mir den angeguckt, ja.
Also diesen Vortrag sich anzuschauen ist allein schon deshalb so interessant, weil ich einfach gerade diese BSD, bzw. SunOS, Solaris und allgemein aber auch Unix History Lessons, die der irgendwie da eine halbe Stunde in der ersten abfeiert. Das ist schon mal so geiles Basiswissen zu dem Thema, was ist eigentlich geschehen in den letzten Jahren. Also er hat im Prinzip diese gesamte Entwicklungsgeschichte von SunOS bis hin zu Solaris und Open Solaris im Speziellen aufgefächert, sodass man mal nachvollziehend. Und dann kam halt irgendwie Oracle. Und dann wird der irgendwie so giftig und gullig. Es ist wirklich zu schreien. Der hat so einen Hals, ja. Also so richtig so erzählt so die ganze Geschichte, wie Oracle übernommen hat und schnell irgendwie so Open Source-Redices von Open Solaris eingestellt hat, intern andere Sachen gesagt hat, als sie dann gemacht haben.
Am schönsten fand ich den Satz, you must not anthropophasize, oder wie das Wort heißt, Larry Ellison. Und von dem Zeitpunkt an meint er nur noch The Lawn Mower. The lawn mower doesn't care if you hold your hand into it.
Wo ist der Link?
Der Link kommt jetzt in den Chat.
Nicht umsonst fragen Steve und Larry gute Freunde.
Ja, wo bei mir ist Larry Ellison, ist für mich immer noch ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln und Steve Jobs irgendwie nur mit sechs.
Nur mit sechs? Und Apple entwickelt an einem File-System, das Cloud-basiert ist.
Wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Das Wort Cloud will ich hier nicht mehr hören.
Cloud-Verbot.
Ja, also dieser Vortrag ist super interessant und vor allem, was sich überhaupt daraus entwickelt hat, weil mittlerweile ist es wohl so, dass alle nennenswerten Founding Developers, die sozusagen an den relevanten, coolen Technologien von Solaris gearbeitet haben, einschließlich ZFS, einschließlich D-Trace, also ich glaube, der ist für D-Trace selber...
Das waren D-Trace-Entwickler.
Genau, und jetzt kriegst du sie nicht alle zusammen. Ich hab immer die Solaris-Technologie nicht alle so ganz auswendig drauf, aber das ist ja wirklich... Das stellt er auch nochmal heraus und ich glaube, das kann man auch mal anerkennend sagen.
Schreibst du mal jemanden bitte den Link kurz rein.
Also er hat ja behauptet, und ich würde fast das so unterschreiben, auch wenn ich jetzt eigentlich zu wenig Einblick habe und das machen, aber es ist für mich immer schon so ein Eindruck gewesen, dass...
3-4-3 macht.
Sun, also speziell das Solaris Team, quasi so das Xerox der Unix-Zeit seit den 90er Jahren war. Also die großen Fortschritte in Unix, die wirklich großen Steps, wo wirklich signifikant Dinge umgestellt wurden und wo Sachen komplett neu strukturiert wurden, sind im Solaris Bereich. Da ist ZFS sozusagen nur ein Ding davon. Und Detray ist ein weiteres. Und wie heißt noch gleich diese Virtualisierung? Zones in Solaris etc. Da weiß ich jetzt nicht so viel drüber, aber ich weiß, dass das auch ein sehr umfangreiches, starkes Modell ist. Und er bringt da ja auch ein paar interessante Beispiele. Also den Talk kann ich echt nur jedem empfehlen. Worauf ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus wollte ist, alle diese Developer, die bei Solaris sozusagen wegweisend waren, sind weg. Oracle hat sie irgendwie alle verscheucht. Und alle sammeln sich jetzt in einem neuen Projekt, diesem Illumus, was ein Scheißname ist.
Aber alle nicht.
Illumus.
Ja, aber Illumus ist nur der Karnel, glaube ich.
Ja? Naja, macht ja nichts.
Also die Zetaphys-Leute sind alle bei dieser Delphix-Firma.
Genau, und viele sind in wenigen Firmen organisiert und alle treffen sich sozusagen in diesem Illumus-Projekt, wo sie den Karnel voranbringen. Und ich meine, da wird auch auch Userland dann auch noch irgendwie dazugehören, oder nicht? Oder ist das jetzt nur der Karnel? Auf jeden Fall setzen sie auch auf Linux-artigen Approach mit, es kann nicht genug Distributionen von uns geben. Also sind es nicht so in diesem Single-Distribution-Modell drin. Das kann man so sehen, das kann man auch anders sehen. Er hat da auch ein paar Punkte. Wie auch immer, also mir war auf jeden Fall nicht klar, dass es mittlerweile außerhalb von Oracle, dass dieses Team da sozusagen immer noch beisammen ist und jetzt auf Open Source-Basis das weiterentwickelt. Weil das könnte einfach mal auch ein ganz interessantes Projekt sein, was man sich mal näher anschauen sollte.
Ich hab das schon erzählt. Das ist jetzt nicht so lange her, als ich gesagt hab, dass die alle bei Delfix rumhängen.
Ich kann das aber nachvollziehen, weil bei mir ist es auch so, irgendwann hör ich nur noch weißes Rauschen, wenn es um ZFS geht.
Nach drei Sekunden oder nach fünf?
Fünf.
Du bist schon mal drei.
Ich bin wieder bei drei.
Du hast einfach noch nicht die Sonne gesehen.
Wie hat Heuge so schön gesagt in der letzten NSFV-Sendung? Wiederholen heißt lernen.
Wiederholen heißt lernen.
Ich wiederhol's jetzt nicht.
Aber wiederholen heißt lernen.
Wer Rekursion verstehen will, muss erst Rekursion verstanden haben.
Moving on. Illumos.
Und wer Redundanz verstanden hat, hat auch Redundanz verstanden.
So, wollen wir auf ein weiteres Lieblingsthema kommen?
Kalender!
5 gegen 1, du hast keine Chance.
Natürlich reden wir über Syncing.
Moment mal.
Wir reden natürlich über Syncing. Nämlich, und auch das ist sozusagen eine Gelegenheit, die wir uns nicht entgehen lassen sollten. Der Mapp ist ja da.
Jetzt wieder aufwachen.
Ich kann wieder hören.
Wir haben schon mal im Restaurant darüber gesprochen, das ist schon eine Weile her. Wir haben schon einmal drüber gesprochen. Wir haben einmal länger als eine Viertelstunde darüber gesprochen.
Okay, wenn das deine Definition von einmal drüber sprechen ist, dann schon.
Klar, ich muss ja auch erstmal ein bisschen ausholen. Ich würde mir ja ganz gerne nochmal auch für unsere Hörer so einen Detail erläutern lassen, nämlich Sub-Ether-Edit ist ja der Editor, der sich von den anderen Editoren dadurch unterscheidet, dass er eben dieses Real-Time-Editing im Netzwerk kann, zwar nur im LAN. Entschuldigung, Blödsinn, also war das Internet-Feature von Anfang an auch mit drin?
Ja, das war ein bisschen schwierig, weil Partnerping noch nicht eingebaut war, aber mittlerweile ist es auch noch Partnerping.
Wie auch immer, mehrere Instanzen von Sub-Ether-Edit können serverlos, leider nur serverlos, wie ich finde, miteinander gemeinsam an einem Dokument arbeiten und das Coole ist, das ist halt so richtig Realtime. Während es eben viele Lösungen gibt, wo man so tippt und schreibt und irgendwann beschließt der Client dann so, jetzt müsste ich mal wieder sinken mit irgendeinem Server und dann baut er das ab. Bei Google Docs und Wave und so weiter, Etherpad etc. ist ja Ähnliches drin. Du hast ja die Sachen auch ein bisschen genauer angeschaut. Ihr habt ja seinerzeit diese Technik auf Basis eines Protokolls oder was war das Datenmodell?
Wie nennt man das? Also ein Verfahren hätte ich jetzt gesagt.
Ein Verfahren.
Richtig schön Deutsch. Das Ganze heißt Operational Transforms. Und kommt wie alles Gute in der Welt von Cirrus Park. Und wir haben uns da dieses Cirrus Park Paper angeguckt und haben uns gewundert, warum das noch niemand so umgesetzt hat eigentlich. Also es gab da irgendwie so ein paar Forschungselitoren, die halt, ja, wie halt so Forschungsprojekte sind und die Software dazu. Sprich, man musste sie selber kompilieren. Und das ging ja auch nur so mit diesem einen Setup, das damals der Entwickler hatte, von diesem Forschungsprojekt. Und dann musste man irgendwie IP-Nummern eingeben und es stürzte irgendwie alle drei Sätze ab. So, aber das war so Stand, das verteilten Editians, als wir uns das angeguckt haben. Und wir haben uns das Paper angeguckt von Cirrus Park und dachten, ne, das ist ja cool. Und das ist eigentlich auch ganz einfach.
Was war der Zweck dieser Transforms? Ging es da schon um dieses kollaborative Editieren?
Da geht es um kollaboratives Editieren und nicht um Editieren. Also Cirrus hat sich damals richtig ausgedacht, wir haben das kollaborative Umfeld, Office, whatever. Das ist das Jupiter Project. Und Jupiter Protocol hieß das auch damals.
Der Name eigentlich.
Ja, ja, eigentlich schon. Das hätte auch bei einer IO geheißen. Ist jetzt aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht markenrechtlich besser als Hydra.
Da erwähne ich iOS.
Die hatten halt nicht nur Text im Sinn, sondern auch Spreadsheets und Grafiken.
IO wäre aber auch ein geiler Name.
Ich habe mich damals nicht so gesetzt damit.
Schlecht zu googeln. Und auch noch zwei Buchstaben, die direkt nebeneinander sind.
Hätte ich sogar in einer richtigen Reihenfolge nebeneinander.
Auf jeder Tastatur. Die wollten halt wirklich alles miteinander kollaborativ vernetzt haben. Tim krieg ich ein. Das war der Gedanke hinter dem Paper. Und die Technik funktioniert im Prinzip auch für alles. Weil was du halt machst ist, du legst jeweils fest, wie zwei Konflikte, also wenn du einen Konflikt hast, in den Sachen, die passieren, also editieren beide an der gleichen Stelle. Also zu für uns unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten, aber die Übertragung kreuzt dann quasi unsere Zeitlinien. Und da müssen wir entscheiden, wer jetzt Recht hat von uns beiden. Und für diese Fälle gibt es eben so Transformationen, die du anwendest auf diese Einzeleditier-Events, die das alles in eine richtige Reihenfolge bringen, damit auf beiden Seiten der gleiche Text entsteht und bleibt. Oder nicht nur Text, sondern auch was anderes. Also das ist eben für allgemein aber auch...
Wie heißt dieses Paper genau?
Link ist auf dem Paper.
Ach Gott, ich weiß doch den Link zu dem Paper nicht aus. Wenn ich irgendwas mit Jupiter Protocol...
Oh, ich sehe schon arme Menschen, die Pritzync implementieren müssen.
Ja, also ich suche das nachher raus.
Das macht der Chat bestimmt für uns gleich.
Oder der Chat macht das. Ich hab das irgendwie auch schon mal irgendwo verlinkt gehabt. Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr altes Paper aus den 70er Jahren.
Da behauptet gerade jemand, das gebe einen Podcast mit euch.
Bestimmt gibt es einen Podcast mit euch.
Achso, du weißt es selber nicht?
Aber ich bin ganz schön fortgeschrieben dazu.
Diese Monate an... Ja, das ist aber nicht das original Paper, aber das ist im Prinzip das, was... Genau, diese lustigen Diagramme auf dem Zeitstrahl, die sind so.
Darf ich mal ein Chat?
Und wir haben uns damals gedacht, wir machen dieses Protokoll halt mal und Protokoll ist an der Stelle immer verwirrend zu sagen, weil dann denken die Leute, so hier, du musst dieses Netzwerkprotokoll einfach veröffentlichen und dann ist die Sache gegessen. Aber das Netzwerkprotokoll hat halt mit diesem Protokoll nichts zu tun, weil diese Transformation findet in deiner Applikation statt und das ist halt extrem wichtig, dass die Transformationen erstens in sich schlüssig sind. Also wenn du Transformationen hast, die sich widersprechen, mathematisch, dann führt das halt dazu, dass du irgendwann trotzdem aus dem Sync läufst. Sprich, da muss auch dieses Transformationsset gut abgehangen sein, damit das funktioniert. Und dann müssen alle Apps, die da mitmachen, halt auch noch genau das exakt gleiche Transformationsset verwenden, sonst hast du halt auch verloren. Und deswegen ist es an sich so ein relativ fragiles System. Also gerade wenn du es auf mehrere Apps machen willst und irgendwie standardisieren, dann hast du da unter Umständen schnell Probleme. Das sieht nach dem Paper aus, das ich gelesen habe.
Ist das hier von diesem Cheng-Seng-Sun?
Nein, nein, stimmt das ist es nicht. Der arbeitet auf Basis von dem auch. Der hat dafür verwirrt, ein Plugin geschrieben, das das macht, das so leitlich gut funktioniert.
Ich guck weiter, ich find's noch.
Ach ja, in den Elementarfragen haben wir da auch drüber geredet. Richtig.
Elementarfragen 7, meinst du, Jett?
So, und das heißt, einfach mit einer Library ist nicht getan. Es ist auch wichtig, was die Programme in sich darin tun.
Das Hauptproblem an dem Ding ist halt, das muss ganz unten rein. Also beim Texteditor muss es halt wirklich unten rein ins Textsystem. Jedes Mal, wenn du eine Taste drückst, muss das einmal komplett durch diesen Transformationsstack durchlaufen, bevor es dann irgendwie hochkommt.
Selbst wenn man niemanden anderen irgendwie...
Selbst wenn du niemanden anders genau... Und selbst wenn du nur irgendwie was Copy-Paste oder so, das läuft alles erstmal einmal ganz unten durch nach oben hin. Und deswegen ist es halt nichts, was du hinterher draufschrauben kannst. Wir machen jetzt auch noch Syncing. Das kannst du halt voll verreiben. Das geht nicht.
Wenn der Editor bisher so mit String-Insert funktioniert hat und so. Aber im Prinzip ist das so allgemein, dass man das auf beliebige Strukturen nicht nur jetzt auf Fließtext machen könnte. Also jetzt auch hier meine Alter tauchen.
Kannst du mit auch einen Outliner machen, ja.
Ich wollte es gerade sagen. Ohne, dass das jetzt nochmal, man denkt ja, dass das nochmal so ein spezifisches Problem darstellt, dass man jetzt solche Strukturen hat, die jetzt über den Text hinausgehen.
Es stellt halt dahingehend ein spezifisches Problem dar, weil wie du gesagt, du musst halt eine Transformationszeit definieren und du musst das mathematisch korrekt definieren. Sprich, das darfst du dich selbst nicht widersprechen. Und das ist was, das dauert ein, zwei Monate Praxistest, bis es dann rund läuft. Also das kann man bestimmt auch komplett mathematisch irgendwie mit Beweisern machen, aber da habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Und hast du den Eindruck, dass jetzt hier so Google Docs, Etherpad etc. diese Prinzipien auch verinnerlicht haben? Oder machen die was anderes und das funktioniert nur zufällig?
Also gerade bei Etherpad und bei Google Wave kann ich es dir so aus der Hand sagen, weil ich kenne die Leute, die das gemacht haben. Die standen auch mit in E-Mail Kontakt mit mir, bevor sie es gemacht haben. Die basieren im Prinzip alle auf dem Jupiter-Paper. Gerade Wave hat halt, meines Erachtens, den Fehler gemacht, dass sie gesagt haben, wir machen Rich Text und Grafiken, aber eigentlich ist alles unten drunter XML und dieses XML transformieren wir. Deswegen fühlt sich Wave so ein bisschen wabbelig an, wenn du tippst, weil es entsteht immer XML und dieses XML wird zu irgendwelchen Zeitpunkten dann miteinander gesynkt und deswegen fühlt es sich nicht so live an, wie es sich eigentlich live anfühlen sollte.
Das zieht ja so hinten um den Zahn, wenn man das hört.
Wie hättest du das eigentlich machen sollen?
Naja, so für Rich Text eben Transformation definieren und die dann synken.
Du hättest sie gerne Liedezenzer kauft.
Für Rich Text hätte ich mir auch eine überlegen müssen. Also da hätte man ja auch nichts im Schrank. Weil da hast du halt so Operationen, dass du nicht nur einfügen und löschen und irgendwie so Text verschieben und was nicht alles. Sondern auch, mach das jetzt fett und mach das jetzt kursiv und mach da ein Bildchen rein. Und auch dafür musst du dann jeweils, wenn es da Konflikte gibt, also der eine macht ein Bildchen rein, der andere löscht gerade das gleiche Bildchen. Was passiert dann? Da musst du dir dann auch jedes Mal so alle Konfliktfälle überlegen und da sinnvoll handeln.
Ich wollte nur kurz, also das heißt, wenn man jetzt einen Outliner da drauf, also wenn man jetzt sagen würde, was gibt's denn da zu lachen?
Nichts, nichts, mach mal.
Das ist ein essenzielles Problem.
Und der Outliner könnte auch eine Kalenderfunktion haben.
Ich sag's euch, wartet ab. Die Zukunft wird mich bestätigen. Outliner spielen eine große Rolle bei der Revolution.
Na dann ist es noch eine Weihrengesser-Revolution.
Ja, eben, weil jetzt das Problem nicht gelöst wird.
Wir kaufen uns schon mal eine Bahnsteigkarte.
Wie soll man sich denn korrekt abstimmen, wenn man irgendwie noch nicht mal Outlines mit anreißen kann? Aber wenn ich jetzt als Software-Entwickler rangehen will, müsste ich eigentlich erst mal dieses Prinzip verstehen. Dann müsste ich mir für meinen speziellen Fall Gedanken machen, was für Operationen überhaupt stattfinden können.
Das ist soweit richtig, ja.
Okay.
Das würde nicht schaden, wenn du damit schon Erfahrung hättest, sonst dauert das wie bei uns damals erst mal drei Monate, bis es stabil ist.
Naja, drei Monate.
Also drei Monate mit im Büro schlafen.
Mit so einem Zelt vielleicht von O2. Für die Privatsphäre.
Man macht einen Alien-Pod.
Wie macht das, Etherpad? Machen die auch XML-Transformation?
Nee, Etherpad macht das richtig.
Deswegen funktioniert das auch so gut. Tja, also wirklich.
Und Google Docs basiert ja auf Etherpad, also die haben ja die Jungs damals gekauft oder Jungs und Mädels, weiß ich gar nicht. Und haben dann Etherpad geopensourced und die Entwickler von Etherpad haben an Google Docs dann dieses Syncing eingebaut. Weil da war ja vorher schlechtes Syncing drin.
Genau, und dann ging's auf einmal.
Dann ging's auf einmal und das war eben der Zeitpunkt, wo sie da die Operational Transforms eingebaut haben.
Na, das war ein guter Kauf. Und Valve war eher so, hm.
Ja, schade, ja, also ich hätte Valve. Valve hat halt glaube ich auch in der Positionierung als Produkt einfach komplett versagt. Aber jetzt haben sie halt so als Next Generation E-Mail verkaufen wollen.
Als Eier legende Wollmilch da.
Das war viel zu viel.
Jetzt krieg ich weißes Rauschen, Valve.
Aber sie haben halt Kommunikation mit Kollaborationen irgendwie verwechselt und das funktioniert halt nicht.
Der Chat weist darauf hin, dass unsere Show Notes ja auch im Etherpad erstellt werden. Das ist richtig, deswegen sind sie auch so gut.
Ich dachte, weil sie von guten Leuten gemacht werden.
Ja, das spielt gar keine Rolle.
Es ist zufällig so, dass es auch gute Leute sind, aber es hätte nicht umhergehen müssen.
Das ist doch eine schöne Tagline für Etherpad. Etherpad, da kann ja jeder kommen. Gut, schön, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben. Vielleicht kriegen wir irgendwie diesen Link von diesem Paper noch raus. Weil ich dachte, als Fortbildung ist das ganz gut.
Ich suche den noch raus.
Dann kann ich gleich nochmal mein aktuelles Klagelied nochmal abstimmen. Weil da es ja sozusagen richtige Lösungen noch nicht gibt, die das irgendwie mal übers Internet und so weiter machen, muss man sich mit dem rumschlagen, was es gibt. Ich bin irgendwie immer noch auf Simple Note fest, weil das sozusagen das einzige ist, wo es native Apps für Mac und für iOS gibt und was irgendwie über den Server singt, wo es meistens so irgendwie geht. Aber da stellt sich halt auch, und das ist wahrscheinlich genau das, was du auch gesagt hast, sind so Probleme. Bei Just Note zum Beispiel, was ich an sich super sleek finde, also in seiner ganzen Art. Es hat nur so bekloppte Minibugs, so kannst du das Fenster nicht beliebig weit aufziehen und so. Aber dann hast du auch so diesen Fall, ich starte das Programm, ich sehe sofort, weil das eben auch so schnell startet und alles da ist, ich sehe, wo ich was reinschreiben will, schreibe sofort los. Im Hintergrund fängt er dann an, oh, mal SYNKEN! Ich schreibe, ich schreibe, ich schreibe und dann SYNKT er. Und alles, was ich schreibe bis zum ersten SYNK, ist dann irgendwie vergessen. Dann kommt da die neue Information, oh, in diesem Zustand hätte das Dokument eigentlich sein müssen, als ich geöffnet habe. Da hat jemand was reingeschrieben, das sehe ich jetzt mal nicht. Und schwupps ist das irgendwie weg.
Ich meine, da hast du halt noch mal zusätzlich das Problem, dass da nicht mit Operationen gearbeitet wird, sondern dass halt einfach so ein normaler DIV gemacht wird, zum Beispiel in zwei Sachen, so wie man es irgendwie von Git oder ne Kuriele, was auch immer, kennt, dass man irgendwie so zwei Dateien miteinander vergleicht und guckt, wie kann ich die sinnvoll zusammenführen.
Aber es sind auch so absurde Race-Conditions, die an der Stelle irgendwie kommen. Na ja, die Editorinnen haben es generell schwer hier. Können wir ja mal mit Text-Mate weitermachen. Da gab es ja auch wieder Neuigkeiten. Ich glaube, Text-Mate hat jetzt endgültig den...
Jetzt wird alles gut.
Wie heißt...
Das Handtuch geworfen.
Na ja, nee, er macht ja noch weiter, aber es ist schon...
Er hat die GitHub-Exit-Strategie gewählt.
Das ist die schlechteste, aber ist auch irgendwie die... Ja, man weiß jetzt...
Also, die Text-Mate ist jetzt open source auf GitHub. Drei. Drei.
Also, ich denke mir, GPL gut und schön, es gibt ja schon Fälle, wo das ganz okay ist. Aber wenn er selber schon keinen Bock mehr hat, und jetzt irgendwie da den Source rausschiebt, dann macht er einfach irgendeine Lizenz, damit die Leute machen können, was sie wollen. Dass er jetzt dann noch darauf besteht, dass alle dann auch noch brav sind.
Er sagt ja, das ist ja nur, um den Bundle-Developants irgendwie leichter zu machen. Was auch immer das da leichter machen soll.
Aber die Bundle sind ja alle BSD oder MIT-Lizenz.
Ja, nicht leichter im Sinne der Lizenz, sondern dass sie mal die andere Seite sehen können, wo sie sich hinein bundeln.
War seine erste Aussage nicht, wir probieren jetzt mal die GPL3, aber ich bin ja eigentlich voll für Openness und Hacking und vielleicht wird das auch mal anders.
Ja, er hat nicht ausgeschlossen, andere Lizenzen zu nehmen und hat GPL3 halt erstmal genommen, weil die halt nicht so frei ist. Auch wenn es Leute gibt, die das anders sehen.
Was gibt's da?
Ja, doch, doch. Das Paper, das ich meinte.
High latency, low bandwidth, windowing in the Jupiter collaboration system. Niklas-Kurtis-Dixon-Lamping.
Und habt ihr es erst selber probiert und gemerkt, oh, scheiße, ist ja doch ganz schön komplex oder?
Nee, an sich ist das, also zu implementieren ist das gar nicht so komplex.
Nee, ich meine, habt ihr das Syncing mit Sub-Ease-Edit oder Hydra damals, habt ihr erst mal selber losgelegt und gemerkt, oh, scheiße, wir kriegen das nicht so hin. Und dann habt ihr euch mal umgeguckt, was es so gibt.
Nee, wir haben das so richtig, weil wir waren ja an der Uni damals noch und wir haben so an diesen akademischen Ansatz geglaubt. Und dann haben wir wirklich erst mal ein Paper gesucht. Und das hübscheste Paper rausgesucht. Das war eben dann von Xerox, wie das halt meistens so ist. Und das ist dann gelesen. Und da waren begeistert von der Eleganz das Algorithmus. Und haben das dann gemacht. Also wir haben da nicht mit geflusht erst mal.
Ist das meine Mate?
Ja, also das ist meine Mate hier.
Also dieses kommerzielle Twitter, das könnte auch mal noch so ein besseres Syncing...
Da kommen wir gleich drauf.
Fällt mir da gerade so auf, wo ich hier das so durchsyncing sehe.
Das Thema Text-Mate haben wir eigentlich durch, oder?
Ich will zu sagen, aber ist das wirklich... Ich weiß auch nicht, was das heißt.
Der war so vorne mit dabei und dann...
Aber ich benutze das immer noch gerne, es ist immer noch mein Default-Editor. Ich hab mich zu keinem dieser anderen Vorschläge, die du mir gesagt hast, durchregen können. Ich hab das alles mal angetestet und alle irgendwie so failten irgendwann.
Aber Chocolate ist doch echt so der bessere Text-Mate.
Chocolate ist jetzt alles Comic Sans.
So, weil du nicht gekauft hast.
Chocolate konnte Dinge nicht. Und zwar kann Chocolate etwas nicht, was ich jeden Tag permanent die ganze Zeit benutze, nämlich Recent Files ins System korrekt einbinden, sodass ich über Launch Bar auf die Recent Files zugreifen kann.
Dann schickst du ihnen mal ein Bugreport und dann ist das in wenigen Sekunden gefixt. Weil die sind noch klein und fit und schnell und zackig.
Okay, das lass ich gerne mal drauf ankommen. Ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob du das machst. Aber ihr wisst, wovon ich rede überhaupt?
Ich hab Bugreports bei denen innerhalb, also in unter 24 Stunden gefixt bekommen.
Was heißt Bug? Ich vermute halt hier irgendwie so einen generellen Fail, weil ich meine...
Oder halt dieses Handboxing.
Du kannst auch sicherlich sagen, was man da falsch macht, dass das nicht so ist. Weil sonst hab ich das nämlich, aus der Chocolate hab ich das nur bei diesen ganzen Systemfeinden. Hier so Adobe und...
Was denn? Was denn eigentlich?
Recent Files hat doch gesagt.
Recent Files.
Was ist mit Recent Files?
Das geht halt im System auch.
Ich geh hier in meinen Launchbar, sag irgendwie Textmate, mach Cursor rechts, und dann hab ich einfach die letzten Files, die Textmate aufgemacht hat.
Also hier weißt du, im Appelmenü gibts Recent Items und da tauchen dann die Dokumente quasi nicht auf.
Genau. Alles was da auftaucht in Recent Items, weiß ich richtig.
Das ist bestimmt ein Sandbox-Problem.
Nee, bestimmt nicht, aber...
Ja, aber gut, aber versuch's mal mit dem Chocolate. Also ich benutze ja Textmate 1.
So beta-edit macht das richtig.
Natürlich. Ich benutze Textmate.
Ich benutze Textmate 1 als mein neues Text-Edit eigentlich. Das ist so mein Default Text-Edit-Ersatz. Also Textmate Version 1, weil ich das ja auch mal gekauft hab. Ich hab's auch immer noch drauf. Das ist so mein Default Text-Edit-Ersatz quasi.
Genau, bei mir auch.
Weil ich brauch nie Rich Text eigentlich in so einem Quick and Dirty hier mal kurz was reinpasten und rumwursteln. Und da ich Chocolate noch nicht gekauft hab und mit Comic Sounds auch mich nur schwer anfreunden kann.
Halt, ich hab Chocolate gekauft.
Ja, ich noch nicht, aber ich werd's schon auch noch tun. Weißt du, jetzt wo ich 50 Euro Dollar für dieses komische Elitennetzwerk ausgegeben hab, kann ich eigentlich auch mal 40 Euro für so einen Editor ausgeben.
Also, ich weiß nicht, dieses Text-Mate, mir ist es ja einfach viel zu langsam.
Ja, das ist halt das Problem, ja.
Das schnarcht da so vor sich hin, ein Text, also ein Editor ist was, was einfach nicht langsam sein darf. Es gibt genug Editor, die sind einfach schnell genug. Und Text-Mate ist so...
Ja, aber für Quick and Dirty mal was machen geht schon, aber heute muss ich 20.000 Rows aus dem MySQL rausselekten und dann nochmal kurz was dran rumwursteln und dann bin ich auf die wahnsinnige Idee gekommen, so aus Reflex halt das ins Text mit reinzupasten und dann...
BABAAAAAAA Welch Meditorgene ist gut?
Sublime ist zum Beispiel so schnell, den Jogdha hat ja auch nicht Wim ist schnell genug für sowas, also... Sublime ist halt extrem schnell, das finde ich an dem so schick.
SubEtherEdit hab ich schon so lange nicht mehr angemacht. Der ist aber auch schnell.
Sublime hat aber auch keine Reasons why's. Er ist schnell genug, um nicht langsam zu wirken. Ja, also ich würde damit keine riesen Sequel-Dumps editieren wollen, weil da ist einfach auch... Das ist dann auch immer eine Abwägung. Willst du ein möglichst korrektes und nestbares Syntax-Highlighting oder willst du ein möglichst schnelles Syntax-Highlighting? Und wir haben uns da entschieden, dass du irgendwie in HTML PRP packen kannst und in dem PRP kannst du wieder JavaScript packen und das highlightert trotzdem alles richtig. Ja, und das ist dann aber so... Das ist ja nicht unbedingt... Nee, aber ich hab damit also relativ große XML-Files, äh, tadellos bearbeitet. Er sagt einem dann so, ja, das ist ein bisschen lang. Ich mach mal das Syntax-Highlighting aus, weil das könnte jetzt langsam sein, aber...
Es ruckelt.
Irgendwie komm ich hier nicht zum Brausen mehr gepflegt beim Podcasten.
Ich auch nicht.
It's gone! Sorry, ich mein nicht heulen.
Dann hol noch mal so ein Joker-Thema raus, währenddessen die Bugs gefixt werden können.
Wollen wir das jetzt, wollt ich jetzt schon machen? Ich dachte, wir reden jetzt erstmal über Mountain. Wir bleiben beim Mac und reden Mountain-Line.
Mountain-Line.
Was gibt's da noch zu reden?
Weiß ich nicht. Maul-Line.
Dennis meint, Goldader gefunden zu haben.
Ach so, kann ich das Thema starten und die übernimmt dann mit den wichtigen Sachen. Die haben doch hier berichtet, dass Mountain-Line soll irgendwie die Batterie leer fressen, wo ich in der letzten Sendung gesagt hab, was kann gar nicht sein, bei mir hier dieses Tool, was auf die Grafikkarte auf die schnellere und mehr Stromkosten umschaltet, wird jetzt seltener benutzt. Zum Beispiel bei Twitter nicht mehr, was vorher der Fall war. Also eigentlich eine Optimierung. Aber jetzt hab ich das Problem auch, Batterie schnell leer. Und zwar ist mir aufgefallen, dass früher mein Activity-Monitor, wenn ich nichts gemacht hab, dann war einfach schwarz. Keine Aktivität. Und jetzt ist da immer unten so eine rote Linie. Obwohl ich überhaupt gar nichts mache. Du kannst auch lauter Zeug schließen. Da bleibt immer so ein bisschen da. Hab ich mal geguckt, was es ist. Und das gibt da einen Prozess, da heißt Activity-Monitor D. Genau, da läuft er. Der läuft jetzt gerade mit 10%, was ich auch schon verdammt viel finde. Und teilweise ist er halt bei 30 und es ist nichts los. Und das ist ja nur ein Activity-Monitor D. Also der hat einfach mal die Schnauze zu halten.
Aber den gibt's schon immer. Und der verbraucht schon immer sehr viel Rechner.
So viel verbraucht er nicht. Aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass es jetzt für diese Batterieprobleme nicht ist.
Aber ich finde 30% schon verdammt viel.
Aber wenn nichts läuft, dass der ganz oben ist, das kenne ich schon seit ihr haben.
Aber nicht ganz oben, aber 10% von der CPU. Ich meine, der soll doch nur mitschneiden, wie viel CPU belegt.
Also bei mir verbraucht er 0,8.
Ja, siehst du das schon besser an.
Also du kannst mal gucken, vielleicht kannst du deine Log-Database mal irgendwie so resetten und dass du da irgendwie 8 unglaublich viel Zeug in deiner Log-Database drin hast, was du irgendwie ausmisten könntest. Aber es gibt diese Batterieprobleme, glaube ich, geräteabhängig und das ist glaube ich auch erknallt mittlerweile von Apple als Pack. Also da ist irgendwie schon so ein 10.8.1 erschienen, so eine Beta. Und die soll das für einige Geräte auch fixen. Genau.
Also ich hab mir sagen lassen, ich hatte ja massenhaft Kernel-Panics mit 10.8.0 und 10.8.1 hat plötzlich keine Probleme mehr, hab ich mir sagen lassen.
Kann ich mal kurz gucken hier?
Dennis, hast du Bittauen?
Es wacht vor allen Dingen, so Auffachprobleme sind plötzlich weg. Also ich hatte Kernel, also es gab da...
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Packet loss.
Ja, ich wurde ja auch rausgeschmissen und bin überall wieder rein und so.
16% Packet loss.
Aber dann möchte ich mal kurz was erzählen. Nämlich mein Kollege Stiggy hat eine tolle Software namens Mountain Growl geschrieben. Das ist nichts weiter als ein Growl-View.
Hals-Growl!
Das ist so ein Growl-Plugin, das nichts weiter macht als diese Sachen dann im Notification Center anzuzeigen. Also das ist der einfache Weg, um Growl mit dem Notification Center zu verbinden. Da gab es ja schon diese nicht ganz hässliche Software namens HISS, die was sehr ähnliches gemacht hat. Was allerdings an HISS nicht so toll ist, dass nämlich, die zeigt einfach alle Notifications an. Man hat keine Möglichkeit, das zu kontrollieren. Wohingegen Mountain Growl, weil es ja ein direktes, ein richtiges Growl-Plugin ist, hält sich auch brav an die Regeln. Also man kann einstellen, wann es das anzeigt und wann nicht. Nutze ich jetzt seit, ich weiß nicht, seit, stimmt, ich hätte es gerne zur letzten Sendung schon gepluggt, da war es aber noch nicht public. Also nutze ich jetzt seit zwei Wochen. Funktioniert ganz hervorragend. Und man braucht sich keine Sorgen mehr, um Growl zu machen.
Wobei es so ein bisschen vergebene Liebesmüh ist an der Stelle, weil Chris Forthouse, glaube ich, schon angekündigt hat, dass es in der nächsten Growl-Version so ein Verstand, wie es sich drin ist.
Jaja, das ist, naja, ich meine, er hat jetzt glaube ich nicht lange daran gesessen. Und bis es soweit ist, ist es, mal gucken, wie die App Store-Review-Zeiten sind ja zurzeit auch relativ lang. Und wer weiß, ob es überhaupt schon drin ist oder noch ein Waldchen dauert. Bis dahin kann man das benutzen.
Ich hab ja noch Ärger mit Safari. Das ist jetzt unabhängig von Mountain Lion. Das hab ich sowohl unter Mountain Lion als auch unter Lion. Mit dem Safari 6.
Was hast du denn für Ärger?
Dass das Ding so am laufenden Meter dann irgendwann mal aufhört. Zu funktionieren, entweder man lädt eine ORL und es kommt nur weiße Seite. Oder man kann dann auf einmal auf Buttons nicht mehr klicken, muss das Ding neu starten, beenden und neu starten und dann geht's wieder.
Das hab ich schon unter Lion. Die Rendering Engine von der Display Engine getrennt.
Sodass überhaupt keine Daten auch mehr durchkommen, weil das ist dann auch viel zu unsicher.
Ja, genau. Also die laufen jetzt bei unseren unterschiedlichen Threads und deswegen gibt es momentan diese Probleme. Ich hab die auch gerne, oder ich hatte die gerne, ich hab in letzter Zeit viel mehr CSS-Animationen und Dünse gemacht. Und das triggert das sehr leicht und dann muss der Fahrer wieder neu starten, weil irgendwie die zwei S-Threads nicht mehr ordentlich miteinander kommunizieren und dann noch weiße Seiten kommen.
Das funktioniert alles noch nicht. Mein Vertrauen in OSTen ist noch nicht wieder hergestellt seit 10.7.0.
Das muss man dir erstmal geben.
Das klingt so überheblich, aber es ist einfach die Wahrheit. Seit Lion geht's einfach nur backab.
Ich hab noch einen netten Bug unter Lion gefunden. Und zwar, wenn man dieses Air-Display hat, womit man irgendwie ein weiteres Display auf dem iPad oder ein iPhone machen kann. Dann kann es unter Lion passieren, dass man plötzlich nicht mehr Drag & Drop machen kann. Das ist verdammt... Also unter Mountain Lion hab ich's noch nicht beobachten können.
Unter Mountain Lion soll es dann passieren, dass man dann gerne mal einen Kernel-Panic hat. Oh. Also ich hab den Tipp bekommen, Mountain Lion, äh, Quatsch, Air-Display zu deinstallieren. Und das hat schon mal sehr viele Kernel-Panics verhindert.
Also dieses komische Drag & Drop-Verhalten wird also schon unter Snow Leopard berichtet?
Das kenn ich schon von ganz früher.
Und was hilft lustigerweise, ist den Rechner einmal in Schlafen zu legen und wieder aufzuwachen, dann geht's wieder.
Super.
Den war kenn ich aber. Den kenn ich aber auch schon vor Air-Display. Den gab's schon.
Aber ich hab ja, also ich installier ja, ich hab glaub ich nix mehr installiert, was so sich so irgendwie ins System rein klingt. Sowas wie Perian oder Menyumeters oder diesen ganzen Kernel hab ich alles nicht mehr. Und bei mir ist tatsächlich relativ Ruhe. Also ich hatte, letztens ist er einmal eingefroren. Also nicht mal Kernel-Panics, sondern einfach komplett stehen geblieben. Aber ansonsten ist es jetzt nicht total dramatisch.
Also ich muss auch sagen, persönlich hab ich mit dem Norton Line ganz wenig Probleme.
Also der ist auch alle chick. Bis auf FTD-Treiber, so OSB-Schnickschnack, kackt immer ab und so, aber da sind ja die schuld.
Ja, neulich meine Kernel-Panic, aber da stand dann Virtual Box Netzwerktreiber irgendwie im Panic-Log. Also es war dann irgendwie eindeutig.
Ja, wir haben jetzt zwei Internet-Trennungen gehabt mittlerweile während der Sendung.
Wir haben jetzt unser Treffikkontigent aufgebraucht.
Ich würde sagen drei, kann das sein? Weil da sind doch dreimal Internetverbindungen getrennt.
Das ist richtig.
Hört uns denn noch jemand?
Ja, wieder, aber das ist jetzt irgendwie im Stundentakt. Im Stundentakt? Naja, 21.30 Uhr, 21.42 Uhr, wenn das jetzt so weitergeht, alle sechs Minuten.
Stimmt.
Da scheint gerade ein Telekom-Problem vorzuliegen, was ich leider nicht beeinflussen kann. Tja, was soll ich machen?
Du hast kein Kennwort gesetzt? Ich frag ja nur.
Das ist ja hier nur ein Trust-Versi-Netz, nicht in diesem WLAN, in dem man da so wissen.
Thema.
Das vaporisiert Geld.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Also unter anderem Wolkenberg.
Wir kommen da noch zu. Wo wir noch bei Betriebssystemen sind. Ich hab in einem Artikel von Grober hier als zu Mars Curiosity gingen und die Feststellung, dass dieser Curiosity Rover ja so technisch gesehen jetzt so etwa auf dem iPhone 3GS Power durch die Gegend fährt. Genau.
Was ich aber relativ viel finde für so ein Gerät.
Ja und das Ding läuft ja unter VXWorks. Das war mir jetzt nicht neu.
Die haben doch da die interviewt und da meintest du, das ist ja mal vor acht Jahren angefangen und da war das halt das Beste, was du kriegen konntest. Und das soll halt laufen, die wechseln halt nicht mittendrin, machen was Neues.
Ja vor allem auch alle anderen Mars-Systeme laufen damit. Das ist schon seit langer, langer Zeit ist das so in der Raumfahrt so eins der Testsysteme. Luftfahrt ist einfach abgehangene Software, die irgendwie funktioniert. Das war ja auch ein Grund, warum QNX sich so lange gehalten hat, bis sie dann von Rimmen gekauft wurden, was jetzt aus ihnen wird. So und dann gab es aber in diesem zitierten Artikel, wird auch behauptet, dass auch die Apple Airport Extreme mit VXWorks läuft.
Auf dem Mars? Hier, scheiß Aliens, wir machen euch erstmal wehladen.
Scheiß Aliens?
Dann hast du noch so Notutower daneben abgeworfen.
Das ist Speciest heißt das.
Kommt drauf an, wie Däniken gebissen.
Ist doch noch nicht mal 10 Leute.
6,0 auf der Dänikenskala.
Internet-Disconnects sind nicht gut für euren Assets.
Guck dir die mal an, die Jungs. Die sind schon voll Hacke.
Du darfst kein gutes Bier kaufen. Auf der Campus-Party wär das nicht passiert.
Da werden wir jetzt schon alle eingeschlafen. Ihr mögt das Bier, ja?
Meinst du, wir würden das sonst trinken?
Es fällt nichts anderes dar.
Ich trink was im Kühlschrank ist.
Genau, an dieser Stelle Shameless Plug für Roddy. Roddy hat ja einen Blog namens winkenschürfel.de oder wie war das? Ja. winkenschürfel.de Und Roddy hat, so wie ich und wie Tim, auch schon diesen fränkischen Bier-Mischkasten quasi zu sich bekommen. Und ich hab auch kürzlich dieses Bayreuter Hell in diesem Mischkasten vorgefunden. Und das gleich als eines meiner Lieblingsbierer aus diesem Kasten. Und dann hab ich Roddy davon kürzlich erzählt. Und dann hat er das gleich aus seinem Kasten gezogen, hat gleich auf winkenschürfel.de also einen passenden Review verfasst. Und jetzt gibt's das hier bei Getränke Hoffmann in der Spezialitätenecke.
Die haben Roddys Blog gelesen oder was?
Ja, natürlich, ja!
Also weil es ist eigentlich voll das Nischenbier. Das ist halt irgendwie so ein...
Ja, ich kann ja auch sagen, wie das zu Getränke Hoffmann zumindest in diese Filiale kam.
Also es gibt auch einen Kreuzberg in so einem kleinen Getränk.
Ja, kann sein. Augustina ist das, was sie normalerweise führen. Und die haben in letzter Zeit die Preise extrem erhöht. Und irgendwann gab's auch mal einen Lieferengpass oder so. Und dann haben sie mal dieses Bayreuther reingenommen, was dann halt auch günstiger war. Und das haben dann irgendwie alle gekauft und danach gefragt und seitdem führen sie beides. Wie das so ist. Ja, kann man trinken. Also ich finde das jetzt hier auch sehr angemessen. Ja, irgendwie.
Ja, das hat so ein bisschen weniger Säure als das Augustiner. Ist ein bisschen geschmeidiger am Gaumen.
Also ich weiß nicht.
Mit einer leichten Haselnuss im Abgang. Ich weiß nicht.
Dieses Augustiner.
Also dieses Augustiner war ja so ein bisschen das Bier meiner Jugend. Und ich finde das hat irgendwie nachgelassen. Vielleicht erinnere ich mich da auch rückwirkend falsch dran, aber dieses Bayreuther Hell, so wie es heute ist, finde ich hat viel mehr von dem, wie dieses Augustiner halt noch vor 30 Jahren hatte. Na ja, 30 nicht, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine. Vielleicht schmeckt nach deiner Jugend. Aber eigentlich wollte es uns berichten, was dein Kinderstund in Sachen Airport Extreme war.
Du bist hier unsere referenzielle Integrität.
Diese Sendung hat schon immer einen Moderator gebraucht.
Also ich meine, allen mit Autorität.
Noch sind wir nicht beim Thema.
Also nochmal, die Behauptung steht im Raum, dass die Apple Airport extrem mit VXWorks läuft. Ich bezweifle das, weil meiner Meinung nach bisher nicht BSD zum Einsatz geht.
Das hat doch auch gehört. Ich habe allerdings auch gehört, dass sich was verändert hat innerhalb der letzten X Monate slash Jahre. Insofern kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass es mittlerweile VXWorks ist. Ich würde das zumindest nicht ausschließen.
Aber wozu?
Wozu? Wir wissen doch, wie das bei Apple ist. Irgendjemand, der an dieser Airport Extreme arbeitet, denkt sich, oh, NetBSD ist eine tolle Idee. Dieser jemand arbeitet zwei Jahre für Apple, geht dann, um einen Start-up zu gründen. Keiner kann mehr was mit diesem NetBSD anfangen. Der nächste, der an der Airport Extreme arbeitet, denkt sich, oh, VXWorks ist ein tolles System, machen wir doch lieber VXWorks.
Mit einem noch längeren Bart.
Also das wäre für mich so ein Ablauf der Dinge, der für mich Sinn ergibt innerhalb der Organisation, die Apple ist.
Na gut, aber dann muss natürlich dieses OS auch auf den Casus Knactus hier auch vorbereitet sein. Ich meine, gut Realtime... Ja, Datentransfer ja, im Prinzip ja, aber...
Mir scheint das nicht so ein guter Fit.
Das ist nicht so offensichtlich. Also es stört jetzt nicht unbedingt, aber so die Abgehangenheit eines BSDs, gerade wenn es so um Networking und Chip-Support von irgendwelchen WLAN-Steinchen und so weiter geht.
Aber für Stabilität weiß die Xtreme auch nie bekannt.
Das stimmt, vor allem die alten Expresse, die haben sich dann einfach irgendwann mal weggehangen.
Genau.
Vielleicht haben sie es einfach nie in den Griff bekommen.
Aber auch nur, wenn man Krypto gemacht hat, mit Webzeugs und so, wenn man es ohne gemacht hat, dann lief das eigentlich immer durch.
Ja, es gab da auch Bugs, wenn du zu viel UDP-Traffic machst, dann kippt es auch um und so. Also es war schon ein bisschen...
Oder Multicast. Multicast draufschießen und so. Also hast du irgendeine Ahnung, wann sich da was geändert hat? Ab welcher Generation? Vielleicht wär's ja mal wieder Zeit für ein Upgrade.
Diese oder vor zwei, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie so. Also das ist jetzt aber auch mehr Bauchgefühle als alles andere.
Haben wir das auch besprochen.
Besprochen. Ich könnte zur VX Works noch sagen, dass irgendwie das damals bei Cargolifter auch ganz hoch im Kurs war. Also das ist wirklich so...
Für die, also für Messensteuern, Regeln, ist natürlich Realtime absolut unerlässlich.
Ja, wie gesagt, es war nur hoch im Kurs. Also ich hab's nie benutzt, es wurde nur ständig davon geredet.
In einer Hochenergiefysik? In einer Hochenergiefysik wird das auch sehr gerne eingesetzt.
Super.
Der Trobot hat auch VX Works.
Auch für Stabilität bekannt.
Steht wo?
Auf der Wikipedia-Seite von VX Works. Ein Trobot zum Mars-Schießen ist auch eine gute Idee.
Ich hätte da noch einen. Die Apple-Airport-Extreme ist hier explizit auch gelingt. Interessant. Steht nicht ab wann. Da steht es bei...
Seit Hation Needed.
Ach man, ey, das ist hier alles ein...
Tatsache.
Ist vielleicht doch ganz gut.
Vielleicht.
So, kommen wir zum Internet. Neuigkeiten gibt es im Bereich von Backup und Archivierung. Stimmt. Bei Amazon. Amazon hat einen neuen Dienst eingeführt diese Woche, den ich sehr interessant fand. Das ist ja ein Thema für dich, Huckel.
Ja, Daten rein günstig, Daten raus nicht so günstig. Ist das Fazit.
Und nicht so schnell. Und nicht so einfach.
Mehrere Stunden oder so hieß es.
Also erst mal erzählen, worum es geht.
Es geht um Amazon Gletscher.
Na ja, sagt ja schon alles.
Die Daten kommen so raus, so langsam wie bei einem Gletscher.
Genau, ich frage mich, ob die auch abtauen.
Du kannst schraufschneien.
Also ob das jetzt so das beste Bild für Datenarchivierung ist in diesen Zeiten des Klimawandels.
Na ja, Fossilien sind ja auch, also ja gut.
Da sind die Liner schon eine Weile.
Nach 100 Jahren kommt doch mal so ein toter Bergsteiger wieder zum Vorschein.
Na gut, wenn man eine Backup-Flange hat wegen Gletscher, dann bin ich ja schon ganz zufrieden. Also das Ganze ist sozusagen eine neue Alternative. Kostet so ein Zehntel von dem, was so S3 aufruft, oder weniger sogar noch. Ich weiß nicht, was ist denn der normale Preis derzeit bei S3? 15 Cent? 17 Cent? Auf jeden Fall für Glacier zahlt man für weggeschriebene Daten 1,1 Cent pro Gigabyte. Also 1, genau in Europa etwas, also 10 Prozent mehr. Wenn man diesen Irland-Server nimmt, und dann kann man da halt seinen Scheiß wegschreiben. Aber man kann da nicht so jederzeit drauf zugreifen, sondern wenn man das Backup wieder hervorholen möchte, dann muss man das so an-triggern, und dann wird das eben aus so einem, ich weiß nicht, wo die das abspeichern, aber es ist zumindest nicht in diesen unmittelbar sofort verfügbaren Netzwerken, sondern eben keine Ahnung.
Die Steintafeln werden aus dem Salzbergwerk gerührt.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ob dann irgendwie einer mit so einem Rolli irgendwie so ein Festplattenpaket irgendwie aus dem Keller holt oder was das bedeutet. Auf jeden Fall haben sie da eine günstigere Methode der Datensicherung, die aber dazu führt, dass sie nicht so ohne Weiteres die Daten bereitstellen können und sie lassen sich so 3-4 Stunden einräumen, bis sie dann die Verfügbarkeit garantieren. Und dann darfst du auch nur maximal 24 Stunden darauf zugreifen. Wenn du in 24 Stunden deine Daten sozusagen nicht wieder runtergekratzt bekommen hast, dann musst du das irgendwie nochmal anstoßen. Und du darfst auch nur einen Teil deiner Daten überhaupt abgreifen. Also du darfst ja nicht alles rausholen, sondern nur, warte mal, jetzt muss ich nochmal nach.
Du darfst schon alles rausholen, aber das ist dann einfach scheiße teuer. Also es ist bis zu, wie war es pro Monat? Darfst du bis zu 5% deiner Daten haben?
3 Cent pro Gigabyte, ne, ne, Entschuldigung, ist was anderes. Ja, erzähl weiter.
Das war so eine sehr merkwürdige, also irgendwie kann man pro Monat, ich glaube 5% seiner gesamten gebackupten Daten. Und das wird dann aber auf eine Tagesperiode runtergerechnet. Also sie haben dann irgendwie so, wenn man, sie haben als Beispiel so, wenn man 12 Terabyte hat, dann darf man pro Tag bis zu 20 Gigabyte Daten wieder zurückholen. Das ist dann quasi im Preis inklusive. Und darüber hinaus geht das dann aber nicht pro Gigabyte, sondern es wird dann irgendwie ganz merkwürdig auf so ein, wir gucken uns den Peak an, den du hast, und das rechnen wir dann von einer Stunde auf einen Monat hoch. Und dann bist du bei so und so viel.
Peak hourly retrieval rate in any given hour multiplied by the number of hours in the month multiplied by 1 Cent. Das versteht jeder.
Ich würde gerne mal ein Beispiel sehen dafür.
Das ist wirklich unklar.
Hört sich nach Tape-Roboter an, oder?
Genau, außerdem, wenn du Daten löscht, die noch nicht drei Monate alt sind, kostet das auch noch mal 3 Cent. Das habe ich auch nicht so ganz verstanden. Also wenn deine Daten, die du schon geschrieben hast, wenn du die wieder löschen willst, aber die liegen nicht schon drei Monate rum, dann kostet es extra. Also mit anderen Worten...
Dann kostet es 3 Cent, klar. Weil die 3 Cent hättest du ja für die 3 Monate bezahlt.
Stimmt, das ist sozusagen so eine Mindestspeicherzeit, Vorratsdaten.
Das sind die 24 Monate von Amazon.
Okay, also sie wollen, dass du es sozusagen mindestens drei Monate lang ablegst, beziehungsweise sie forcieren in gewisser Hinsicht eben diese Idee, dass es eben wirklich so... Du schreibst das weg und dann bleibt es liegen. Und du willst da nicht sofort drauf zugreifen, auch nicht löschen. Darfst du es aber löschen? Ja, löschen ist erlaubt, aber kostet.
Wie gesagt, hört sich nach einem Tape-Roboter an, die haben da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so ein Ding, wo irgendwie, sagen wir mal jetzt, also die haben das natürlich, alles sind groß, aber da passen 50 Tapes rein, aber sie haben einen Lager für 10.000 Tapes und halt, die wollen, dass du da selten zugreifst, weil die schieben die halt zur Seite und sie brauchen nur noch Tapes nachkaufen und die Lesegeräte, da haben sie halt nicht so viele von. Und dann rennt da so ein Bot hin und her, du meldest dich an, wann du dein Tape da eingelegt haben möchtest, das ist halt für 24 Stunden drin oder wird halt dann auf schnelle Platte kopiert, was auch immer die dazwischen cashen und deswegen haben die da so eine Beschränkung, nehme ich mal an.
Wahrscheinlich wollen die auch nicht, dass man irgendwie mit anfängt, also mit den mindestens drei Monaten, dass man nicht so ein tägliches Backup draufschiebt und dann erst mal sagt, okay, jetzt löscht das mal für mich, nach 24 Stunden, sagen wir mal, die ganzen Backups wieder löschen, weil dann würde man denen ständig Treffikröcher schieben oder irgendwie sowas.
Meine Vermutung bei solchen Geschäftsmodellen von Amazon ist ja immer, dass sie eigentlich nur den Markt für Blogposts vorantreiben wollen, in dem verglichen wird, ab wann sich dieser Service im Vergleich zu irgendeinem anderen Service lohnt.
Und Podcasts.
Also bei S3 bezahlt man für das erste Terabyte im Monat 0,125 Cent pro Gigabyte. In anderen Worten, wenn man einen...
Also 12 Cent pro Gigabyte. Was? Du hast nicht 0,125 Cent, sondern 12 Cent.
Aber bei 100 Gigabyte würdest du 12,50 Euro zahlen?
Ich glaub schon, ja.
Und ich hab ja da auch mein Backup, aber wie gesagt ja nicht die ganzen Mediendaten, sondern nur so den textbasierten Kleinscheiß und so meine Library und so ein paar andere Sachen. Und ich bezahle im Monat 3,69 Euro oder irgendwie sowas. Also bin glaub ich immer noch weit unter 50 Gigabyte bei dem, was ich da bei ARK so hochschiebe. Und dafür ist SS3 irgendwie voll super.
Wenn du nur dein Textzeugs machst, warum machst du denn nicht zu Hause einen Netatalk hin mit einer Platte dran und machst das übers Netzwerk?
Ich mach ja lokal auch noch einen...
Das kannst du ja auch noch machen.
Ich hab keinen Rechner zu Hause, noch einen Server oder sowas will ich auch gerade eigentlich nicht. Achso, du kannst bei SS3 noch den Reduced Redundancy Storage nehmen und da kostet es dann ein... Was nehmen? Wie? Da würden dann 100 Gigabyte...
9,30 Dollar.
9,30 Dollar kosten, genau.
Weil das ist nämlich der Preis, das ist nämlich das, was ich gerade angelegt habe.
Genau, das heißt, da kopieren sie dann die Daten nicht zweimal irgendwie rum und wenn Zweck ist, ist es weg.
Das ist halt bei Glacier eben explizit so, dass sie da eine sehr hohe Ablage-Sicherheit garantieren. Also im Prinzip, das ist eben wirklich für Archive. Also was weiß ich, du hast halt irgendwie deine Bücherbibliothek gescannt und willst einfach dafür einen Backup haben, damit du diese Scheiße bestimmt auf gar keinen Fall wieder machen musst, dann wäre das so ein Ort, wo man mal die Daten reinwerfen kann, um einfach für den Fall, dass einem die eigene Infrastruktur komplett in die Ohren fliegt, irgendwie was hat so. Aber da geht man eigentlich davon aus, ja, das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen so ein Write-Only-Filesystem. Also man schreibt es vielleicht nur einmal da rein und greift nie wieder darauf zu.
Aber ein Backup, das du nicht zurückholen kannst, ist ja kein Backup.
Du kannst es zurückholen, du tust es bloß wahrscheinlich.
Aber das ist ja bei einem Backup generell der Fall.
Ja, nicht wenn es so ein Backup ist, wo du drauf rumdiffst, wo du auch noch wieder ausliest und irgendwie Diffs bildest und so weiter.
Ich nutze mein Backup, probiere es eher so zu nutzen, dass ich nach Möglichkeiten draufzugreife.
Wie macht das eigentlich arg? Also muss der immer wieder auf die alten Archive zugreifen, um die Changes zu machen, weil er kann ja keine Snapshots machen. Also dann müsste er im Prinzip so wie Time Machine da...
Vielleicht hat er einen lokalen Index oder so.
Der kann auch mal Delta V machen eigentlich.
Was machen?
Delta V immer. Es gibt ja da so Algorithmen für...
Delta?
Delta V ist da ein Algorithmus, der solche Sachen... Der hasht ja auch so Blöcke und so. Und dann, weiß nicht, vielleicht...
Aber irgendwo müssten diese Daten ja dann liegen.
Ich kann es dir nicht genau sagen, das ist die kurze Antwort.
Also bei mir, ich hab das jetzt ja mal angefangen zu nutzen, auch auf Huckels Rad hin, und ich hatte ja das Problem, dass mein Rechner wegen 1080 relativ häufig mal neu gestartet hat. Und dann hat er nämlich immer wieder von... Also er hat nicht von vorne angefangen zu übertragen, das sah nur so aus, sondern er hat dann die Daten offensichtlich neu gehashed und hat geguckt, was hab ich schon? Und hat sich dafür irgendeinen Index oben runtergeholt von Amazon.
Ja, es sieht bei ARK immer so aus, als würde er von vorne anfangen und dann siehst du aber, dass er dann irgendwie relativ schnell so ganze Blöcke vorwärts geht und dann wirklich nur noch am Ende 100 Megabyte oder so.
Dann macht er so wie, wie, wie heißt das, wie Ersing?
Scheiß Fruchtflüge, ich raste aus.
Ist ne Mücke, oder? Wie Ersing macht er halt einen Hash über irgendwie so einen Blockbereich, schickt den hoch, der Server sagt irgendwie, ja hab ich schon, hab ich schon, hab ich schon und dann rockt das so durch. Also bei Ersing ist das ja so. Und so will man das auch haben, eigentlich dann flutscht das nämlich. Und dann noch Compression rein und dann geht's ab.
Also ich pack da jetzt so, also jetzt läuft das erst mal. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wie es ist dann nachher drauf zuzugreifen, wenn man wirklich mal drauf zugreifen muss. Ich hab's noch mal ausprobiert, das funktioniert alles soweit relativ okay. Ich speichere ohne Redundanz aber dafür auch Fotos, weil ich beschlossen habe, dass Fotos doch langsam wichtig genug sind, dass man die auch durchaus als Offside-Backup haben möchte. Ich hab's dann auch mal auf einer Festplatte zusätzlich, aber ja, das ist schon schön.
Aber Festplatte macht man halt einfach viel zu unregelmäßig und das läuft halt jeden Tag. Also ich mach's bei mir. Wir haben ja im Office jetzt mittlerweile zweimal 100mbit synchron. Ich mach's halt immer so kurz vor der Mittagspause geht's automatisch an. Also ich hab sozusagen das so auf periodisch immer am Tag um 12.30 gestellt und dann komm ich vom Mittag zurück, ist mein Backup fertig, super.
Also hier der hat ja dank Powernap und das funktioniert, hab ich mir sagen lassen, funktioniert mit 10.8.1 auch und damit macht dann ARK tatsächlich auch wohl angeblich innerhalb der Powernaps-Backups, was total Geiles wäre, wenn's ginge.
Nicht schlecht.
Echt, ARK macht Powernap.
Hab ich.
Schlagt wer jetzt?
Na ja, man kann ja im Zweifelsfall sehen, wann das Backup gemacht worden ist.
Bei mir funktioniert Powernap übrigens nicht mit Time Machine. Ich hab das zwar angeschaltet, aber ich hab das Ding mal zugeklappt und hat keinen Backup durchgeführt.
Aber ist das vielleicht, also Max meinte doch auch gerade, dass es irgendwie erst seit 10.8.1 funktioniert. Was?
Powernap.
Ja, aber das ist dann jetzt eine API-Gebirge, wo die sich auch dran hängen und dann werden wir neu.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt eine API ist oder ob die einfach aufwachen und dann ARK in Zweifelsfall ist. Oh, hier ist es und ich soll ja jede Stunde einen Backup machen und dass es dann halt seinen Backup macht.
Also auf der ARK-Webseite sieht ihr jetzt, ich guck mal in die Release Note.
Ich meine, das normale Time Machine. Also hat irgendjemand einen Powernap-fähigen Rechner? Du, Orastin, kannst du bestätigen, dass die Time Machine bei dir im zugeklappten Zustand läuft?
Also das Sinken funktioniert von Kontakten und Notes. Das hier ist ja keiner. Der andere ist ja zu Hause zugeklappt im Powernap, der Powernap-fähige Rechner. Die Time Machine funktioniert glaube ich auch, aber das habe ich jetzt noch nie wirklich überprüft, ob das so ist.
Aber es funktioniert angeblich nur, wenn es am Strom ist?
Nee, wenn die Batterie über 50 Prozent ist.
Ich dachte Powernap geht nur, wenn Strom angeschlossen ist.
Nee, mir war so, der hatte in dieser Keynote gesagt, die machen das solange die Batterie über 50 Prozent ist, darunter nur noch mit Strom.
Ja, aber die Time Machine hatte da eine Ausnahmeregelung.
Ich bilde mir ein, das ist natürlich jetzt schönes Rumgerate, aber bei der Time Machine gibt es ja ein Setting, ob er überhaupt aktiv werden soll im Batteriemodus. Vielleicht kommt das auch noch zum Tragen.
Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher.
Es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass du als Party-App keine API hast für Power-Nap und auch nicht laufen kannst.
Okay, also ich hab hier merkwürdige Update-Zeiten einfach zu denen. In der Rechner von dem...
Also in diesem riesen Mountain-Line. Keine Ahnung. Da gibt es doch von diesem wahnsinnigen auf Ars Technica gibt es doch immer dieses... Syracusa, da gibt es doch immer dieses riesen Review, wo er immer alles auseinandernimmt für die neue Mac OS Version. Und da beschreibt er dieses Power-Nap auch irgendwie als Kernel-Zustand, der irgendwie Dark Wake genannt wird. Was ich einen coolen Namen finde übrigens. Und in diesem Dark-Wake-Zustand können also irgendwie auch diverse andere Prozesse laufen. Also das ist nicht so, dass das jetzt wirklich nur gewissen Sachen vorbeithalten wäre. Also hat er es zumindest dargestellt. Ich habe da keine eigenen Erkenntnisse zu. Ich habe nur gerade auf Stack Overflow geguckt und da ist halt die einstimmige Ansage, ne, kannst du nicht laufen und Power-Nap.
Also es gab das auch schon vor Mountain Lion, aber jetzt erst in Mountain Lion nutzen sie es auch für so Sachen, die eben wirklich auch Netzwerk aktivieren etc. Und es ist sicherlich vorstellbar, dass irgendeine zukünftige Katzenart ist dir dann auch erlaubt, da dran teilzunehmen, wenn du irgendwie Upstore-Rules befolgst und freiwillig iCloud benutzt und so.
Wenn du überhaupt im App Store bist. So wie iCloud, was du ja nur verwenden kannst, wenn du im App Store bist.
Soift, soift, soift, soift, soift. Ach ja. Internet. Naja, was haben wir denn noch Neues im Internet?
Ein Eliten-Social-Network.
Bei Flatter gibt es Neuigkeiten. Von denen man nicht so genau weiß.
Das ist ja auch so ein Eliten-Netzwerk, Flatter.
Ja, ist es. Die haben jetzt die Subscriptions geändert.
Und?
Das heißt, dass es ja vorher so war, dass wenn du einen Flatter-Knopf subscribst, also du kannst ihn ja klicken, und wenn du nochmal klickst, kriegst du so einen Dialog, wo drauf stand, wir flattern diesen Button für dich, automatisch für, und dann darfst du auswählen, 3, 6, 12 Monate. Und das haben sie jetzt geändert. Und jetzt ist es so, also für die Subscriptions, die du jetzt noch hast, laufen die auch so wie ursprünglich gesagt aus. Aber wenn du eine neue Subscription machst, gibt es jetzt sozusagen nur noch eine Art von Subscription, das ist sozusagen eine richtige Subscription ohne Ende. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt nur noch Dauersubscriptions.
Dafür kann man aber jederzeit kündigen.
Was? Du kannst jederzeit Subscriptions beenden. Das ist jetzt auch sehr viel übersichtlicher aufgelistet da im Dashboard. Und du kannst auch vor allem alte leichter wieder reaktivieren. Du siehst auch alle, die du schon mal gehabt hattest und kannst sie jederzeit wieder anstellen. Und angeblich soll es dann halt auch jeden Monat eine Mail geben, wo alle deine Subscriptions nochmal zusammengefasst sind, damit du die dann immer siehst. Also ich weiß, dass viele Leute diese Subscription-Geschichte benutzt haben, um so einen Click-Weight zu geben. Also wenn man sozusagen besonders flettern will, dass man dann sagt, drei Monate. Ich hab das häufiger, also wenn ich irgendwie mal wieder so ein Ahoy-Polloy-Comic habe, der mich irgendwie komplett auf den Boden geworfen hat, rollend, lachend, so, dann gibt's dann auch gleich mal drei oder sechs auf die Mütze, so, weil das muss dann einfach belohnt werden. Und da gibt's wohl viele Leute, die das auch so gemacht haben.
Also du hast hier benutzt, um sozusagen deine Flatter zu boosten, aber du wolltest ja keine Subscriptions, so wie eine Subscription zu verstehen ist, sondern du hast einfach sozusagen das Dreifache gespendet, indem du eine drei Monate Subscription genommen hast.
Genau. Genau, also ich hab auch gar nichts dagegen, dass sie jetzt auch unbegrenzte Subscriptions einführen, fand aber gerade diese Begrenzten ganz gut. Na ja, es gibt ja so eine Augurenliste, wo einige Leute drauf sind, die sozusagen da so die Flatter-Fans sind.
Zum Beispiel du?
Zum Beispiel ich, aber auch viele andere und das wird da auch genau in der Breite diskutiert. Sie überlegen sich mal, wie sie sozusagen diesem Bedürfnis der besonderen Würdigung da irgendwie entgegenkommen. Aber sie wollen halt die Subscriptions tendenziell auch in die API überführen, wo sie derzeit noch nicht ist. Dazu mussten sie das einfach vereinfachen, weil das ist dann einfach nicht abbildbar in solche automatisierbaren Sachen.
Gut.
Ja, Twitter? Wer ist denn hier alles so verified von euch?
Aber das sind ja die uncoolen Leute. Das will ich gar nicht.
Was muss man machen, um verified zu sein?
Ich darf jetzt nicht mehr bei den coolen Kids rumhängen, sondern ich wurde irgendwie verifiziert.
Ach du wurdest verifiziert?
Ich wurde verifiziert.
Du hast da gar nichts für gemacht?
Nein, ich hab da gar nichts für gemacht.
Hast du eine Mail bekommen, du bist jetzt verifiziert?
Man kriegt eine Mail und ein Tweet von verified. Also der Twitter-Account verified sagt, hallo wir möchten dich gerne verifizieren. Ich dann erst mal so, was ist das für eine URL? Irgendwie ist da irgendwie UTF-8 drin.
Wie soll das so?
Gleich so alle Alarmsignale an. Was ist denn das jetzt hier für ein Scam und so? Aber das erste Mal seit langer Zeit mal wieder so ein Zertifikat durchgelesen. Ich hab mir so echt vorsichtig gedacht, was soll denn das jetzt? Naja und dann kriegst du da so einen Link vor die Nase, den sollst du dann halt anklicken, um den Verification-Prozess abzuschließen. Jetzt kann ich schon mal mein Datasheet rausholen, weil jetzt wollen sie ja wahrscheinlich von Unterhosengröße bis irgendwie Kurzort irgendwie alles abfragen. Weit gefehlt. Also ich hab überhaupt keine Ahnung, warum sie mich da jetzt ausgewählt haben, auf welcher Basis, was mir völlig schleierhaft. Ich hab auch keinen Kontakt irgendwie mit Twitter und ich hab denen auch nie eine Mail geschrieben, dass hier verifiziert werden möchte. Zumindest nicht, dass ich mich daran erinnern würde. So und dann kriegst du da irgendwie so einen Form, so einen Webform, wo sie dir so drei Steps irgendwie präsentieren, wobei du jetzt erstmal nur den ersten so siehst. Und der erste Step ist, dass sie dir so zwei Tweets zeigen und fragen, welcher von diesen Tweets, das weiß ich nicht mehr genau, welcher jetzt irgendwie besser oder effektiver wäre oder wäre, welcher von den Tweets mehr Follower erzeugt. Das hab ich auch gesagt.
Hast du Screenshots gemacht?
Ich hab einen Screenshot gemacht, aber ich hab den gerade auf dem anderen Rechner. Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob... Wollen wir noch über iCloud... Siehst du mal, das wusste ich doch. Ich kenne euch doch.
Kinder, seid ihr noch alle da?
Das eine war so, ja ich bin... Zweimal kam diese Frage. Zwei Tweet-Paare wurden einem vorgehalten. Das eine war, was erzeugt mehr Follower und das andere war, was schafft mehr Engagement oder irgendeinen Scheiß.
Also ich dachte sowas...
Dann hast du den angenommen, diesen Derry Fighting?
Der eine Tweet war so, ich war gestern bei der Oscar-Nacht und der andere Tweet war Ich bin jetzt bei den Lattenzaun Oscars! Und dann hast du richtig geklickt. Genau.
Die wollen nur Leute verreifern, die auch so Twitter-Ahnung haben.
Ja, beziehungsweise, ich kann mir wirklich bekloppt vor, warum ist das jetzt so eine Art Kurs irgendwie? Ich brauch nicht mehr Follower erklärt zu bekommen oder ich bin seit Dezember 2007 bei euch. Erzählt mir nicht, wie euer Scheißdienst funktioniert. Da kann ich euch mehr darüber erzählen als ihr mir.
Welcher Dienste schmeckt mehr nach Pepsi?
Völlig unklar. So, und der dritte Schritt war, gib uns deine Telefonnummer. Damit wir irgendwie dich verifizieren können. Und übrigens, solltest du deine URL ändern, dann bist du automatisch nicht mehr verifiziert, solange bis du wieder verifiziert bist. Dann müsste das irgendwie gecheckt werden oder so. Also da erscheint schon irgendwie so ein manueller Prozess dahinter zu sein.
Hier, da gibt's im Chat einen Link, in den Screenshot wohl von diesem Verification-Prozess.
Ja dann, sag mal, schieb mal rüber auf den Bildschirm.
Watching the Oscars right now and I'm loving the fashion on the red carpet.
Ah ja, genau, hier ist es. Das ist das, genau.
Also du kriegst von denen eine DM, ohne ihnen zu folgen.
Watching the Oscars right now and I'm loving the fashion on the red carpet. Genau, which tweet will help you, will help double your rate of new followers for the day. Und das Zweite ist, which tweet will more of your followers engage with? Klickt immer den linken.
Aber da ist noch bei beiden hier Haschmark, Oscar, also warum soll denn der eine jetzt cooler sein als der andere?
Ja, der ist dabei und bringt noch extra Information.
Ach so, der andere ist nur was gestern, weil die Zeug haben was Aktuelles.
Ja, und dann hier irgendwie Which tweet will get more clicks, favorites and retweets from your followers?
Aber fehlt mir noch, dass sie da wirklich auch so ein Avatar-Bild daneben packen, wo eine so ein fröhliches Gesicht und das andere so ein dickes, trauriges Gesicht ist.
Auf Melissa hat immer recht und David nicht.
Ja, und ich würde es auch viel besser, dass sie dir noch vorschlagen, Rihanna, Ellen, Degeneres und ESPN zu folgen, um deine Fast-Virtues-Nest zu increase.
Genau, und dann gibt es noch deine Telefonnummer und dann war es das. Und dann bist du verified.
Ach, sobald du die Telefonnummer enterst, hast du alles gemacht.
Ach, und du wirst nicht anrufen, vielleicht?
Äh, doch, warte mal. Schämen wir ihn. Warte mal, verwechsel ich das jetzt gerade mit irgendwas anderem oder haben sie mir tatsächlich noch irgendeinen Anruf und eine Nummer?
Hallo, hier ist das automatische Twitter-Verifizierungssystem.
Oder eine SMS vielleicht?
Wenn sie Tim Brittlaff sind, drücken sie die ein.
Wenn sie nicht Tim Brittlaff sind, drücken sie die zwei.
Ich muss gerade mal überlegen, ob das im Rahmen von Twitter... Ich glaube, sie schicken dir dann noch so ein... Genau, du wirst angerufen und dann kommt so ein automatisches Telefonsystem und da musst du dann so eine vierstellige Nummer, die halt auf dem Bildschirm steht, eingeben und dann ist alles gut.
Ja, aber an welcher Stelle genau haben sie jetzt überprüft, ob du Tim Brittlaff bist?
Ja, an keiner. Das ist ja das Absurde an dieser ganzen Geschichte, ne? War das was anderes? War das jetzt wirklich... Bei Twitter steht hier irgendwas davon, dass sie irgendwie einen anrufen?
Also angerufen wird man auf jeden Fall bei Ebay, aber da wiederum spielen sie einem die Nummer vor, die du dann im Web eingeben musst.
Oh Gott, das ist so furchtbar!
Hier steht, we will not distribute your personal information or use it for any other reason than contact you in a case of security breach.
Ja doch, ja stimmt. Also mich hat hier so eine USA-Nummer angerufen, genau, dann war das bei Twitter. Und dann hab ich so eine vierstellige Nummer per DTMF eingegeben. Ich hätte sie auch sagen können.
Bitte werfen sie eine Münze ein.
Meinten sie eins, neun. Auf jeden Fall danach kam ich mir so ein bisschen verarscht vor. Irgendwie, und jetzt bin ich verified. Na ja, dann hab ich festgestellt, dass dieser verified Account mir folgt. Was mich so ein bisschen glaubt. Paranoid gemacht halt. Block in der Spam. Das macht so den Eindruck, dass er mir nur deshalb folgt, weil ich verified bin.
Meinst du, das ist der Automatismus, mit dem sie intern rauskriegen?
Das haben sie nicht gesagt. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das stimmt. Sollte jemand jemanden kennen, der verified ist, dem aber nicht von verified gefolgt wird, dann bricht das diese Theorie.
Block doch einfach mal.
Auf jeden Fall hab ich mal geguckt, wie viele Leute verified folgt. Und der folgt 33.000 Leuten.
34.000 mittlerweile.
Oder 34.000. Das nimmt auch zu. Da dachte ich, jetzt bin ich in so einem schönen elitären Club. Und jetzt war ich das auch.
Aber der andere Club, in dem du beigetreten hast, ist ja noch viel elitärer. Der ist sogar doppelt so elitär.
Und teurer.
Und teurer. Na, bei Twitter bezahlst du immer deine Telefonnummer.
Und mit meinem guten Namen. Ja, genau. Das ganze Twitter-Debakel. Dann gab es halt diesen merkwürdigen Blog-Post von Twitter, wo sie ihre neuen Rules vorgestellt haben für ihre neue API Version 1.1.
Aber wo ich mich ja gefragt habe, 1.1, wann sind die auf... Also ich meine, solange ich Twitter kenne, haben die ständig ihre API geändert. Die waren bis jetzt bei 1.0?
Ja, 1.0.
Oder ist das jetzt so reines Marketing-Gewäsch, dass sie jetzt gesagt haben, jetzt ist 1.1?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, sie haben zusammen mit dem Stream...
.da 1.0 draufgeschrieben.
Ah, okay, also gab es da vorher schon eine Versionierung?
Ich glaube, es gab vorher keine Visionierung.
Achso, sie haben irgendwann mal 1.0 draufgeschrieben.
Ich glaube, vorher keine Vision, ja, das auch.
Ja, und es ist etwas schwierig herauszufinden, was sie da eigentlich meinen. So, ein paar Sachen sind, glaube ich, ganz gut nachvollziehbar, dass sie da so Limits-Usage abhängig machen. Also, dass sie sozusagen nicht ein generelles API-Limit haben, sondern ein API-Limit, was quasi davon abhängt, was du dafür Anfragen machst, weil halt manche Anfragen irgendwie auf ihrer Seite wahrscheinlich auch more costly sind als andere. Ja, dann führen sie so merkwürdige Standards ein, mit man soll jetzt irgendwie, wenn man denn ein Tweet präsentiert, das so und so machen. Hat das hier nicht für eure Auswirkungen hier?
Mal gucken. Also man darf jetzt zum Beispiel nicht mehr so Sachen machen.
Wie heißt die App noch mal?
Jetzt kaufen.
Jetzt die Nummer unseres Rennenslager an.
Screenfeeler. Gibt es auch Screenfeeler? Wo man irgendwie möglichst viel drauf rumtouchen muss, immer so zehn Kontakte gleichzeitig.
Erst wenn der iPad Nano da ist.
Massage ab, Screenfeeler. Dann musst du das iPad massieren und dann läuft's schneller, wenn du den richtigen Griff hast. Was denkt ihr, was ihr da jetzt tun müsst?
Wir warten jetzt, was passiert. Wir verstoßen ziemlich offensichtlich gegen die Regeln, weil man darf ja nicht die Tweets mit einem anderen Timeline mischen. Also man darf ja nicht so Sachen wie Instagram und Twitter Timeline miteinander mischen. Genau das machen wir. Man muss jederzeit...
Ihr zeigt ja keine Timeline an, sondern ihr zeigt ja ein Ding nach dem anderen an.
Ja, okay, kann man vielleicht noch argumentieren. Man muss auch, wenn man einen Tweet nur einzeln anzeigt, muss man jederzeit die Reply-Buttons, Retweet-Buttons und Favorite-Buttons anzeigen. Was wir auch nicht tun, sondern wir zeigen die erst on tap. Und ich würde sagen, wir warten jetzt einfach, also wir warten jetzt erstmal, was passiert. Und ich glaube, dass die bei Twitter, also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die bei Twitter andere Probleme haben als jetzt irgendeine App, die sich ein paar hundert Mal verkauft hat. Oder ein paar tausend Mal, ich weiß nicht wie oft. Aber wir sind jetzt nicht an dieser hunderttausender Grenze dran. Nicht mal nah, insofern glaube ich nicht, dass da viel passieren wird.
Also ihr seid restlos begeistert.
Schauen wir mal, das sehen wir schon.
Ja, also diese Begrenzung der User, das finde ich ja irgendwie krass. Also sie haben jetzt gesagt, wenn ihr so eine Art Client seid, der hm macht und was sie meinen, ist so ein richtiger Twitter Client, sowas wie Tweetbot, was sozusagen die volle Funktionalität abbildet, wie der normale Twitter Client, dann, ja dann ist alles ganz schwierig, weil wenn ihr, was waren jetzt nochmal die Limits, wenn ihr irgendwie eine Million User habt.
Hunderttausend.
Nee, wenn ihr eine Million User habt, dann müsst ihr sofort anrufen. Dann müssen wir reden. Das ist so die erste Aussage. Dann irgendwie, wenn ihr noch nicht hunderttausend User habt, dann ist bei hunderttausend User einfach Schluss. Und dann müssen wir vielleicht auch nochmal reden oder so, keine Ahnung, aber irgendwie.
Auf jeden Fall wollen sie viel telefonieren.
Dann ist irgendwas, genau. Und wenn ihr jetzt schon mehr als hunderttausend habt, aber vielleicht noch nicht eine Million, dann ist bei zweihunderttausend Schluss.
Nee, dann dürft ihr verdoppeln noch ab jetzt.
Genau, dann dürft ihr noch doppelt so viele, wie ihr jetzt habt, haben. Mit anderen Worten, wenn du heute darüber nachdenkst, einen neuen Tweet-Client rauszubringen, dann weißt du, dass du nicht mehr als hunderttausend User irgendwie kriegen kannst, im Prinzip, wenn ich nichts falsch verstanden habe, oder? Ja, wobei unklar ist, was dann ist.
Die machen dir dann ein Angebot, das du nicht ablehnen kannst.
Ja, da frage ich mich, warum sie nicht gleich die Bedingungen auf dem Tisch legen.
Ja, was könnte das sein? Nach dem Motto, wir kriegen so und so viel Prozent ab?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo das hinführen soll. Und überhaupt diese traditional Twitter-Clients, wie sie mittlerweile heißen, in diesem Press-Sprech, die scheinen ja sowieso nicht mehr fokussiert zu sein. Die haben ja dieses lustige Diagramm mit den zwei Achsen, die irgendwie, also wo du dir denkst so, dass es rauskopiert aus Worst Business Bullshit Ever Compilation 2012. Also die eine Achse geht von Business zu Consumer und die andere geht von Analytics to Engagement. Sie hätten gerne Wachstum in den drei, die eben nicht traditionell Twitter-Klient sind. Die sind rechts oben bei Consumer und Engagement.
Ach, da wollen sie überhaupt nicht hin.
Da wollen sie nicht mehr hin.
Die sind so Twitter, die sind voll nervig.
Oder da sind sie schon genug halt.
Also sie wollen jetzt entweder Business und Consumer analysieren oder sie wollen Business engagement. Aber so Consumer Engagement ist irgendwie, haben wir schon genug, brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Ja, und das Ganze führt ja im Prinzip so ein bisschen so einen Gesamteindruck fort, den Twitter seit einiger Zeit schon hinterlässt, dass es nämlich irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig um die User geht, nachdem man genug hat.
Na die bringen ja auch kein Geld.
Nee, die kosten Geld, die kosten sicherlich auch nicht wenig Geld. Und ich glaube, Twitter hat nicht geringe Summen Geld, die sie da jeden Monat auf einen massiven Server parkt. Developer Team, People Post, Support, keine Ahnung, was nicht alles, internationale Expansion, Büros und Sportboote und so weiter werfen müssen. Und das ganze Geld, was sie da ausgeben, gehört irgendwelchen anderen Leuten, die jetzt so mit einem Baseballschläger hinter ihnen stehen und denen sie irgendwie so in der Hand tatscheln. So, ja, Jungs und Mädels, macht euch doch mal hier ein bisschen Gedanken.
Naja, manche verkaufen ihren Laden zu früh und machen kein Geld. Manche machen es richtig und manche verkaufen zu spät. Und bei Twitter kann man sich ja langsam überlegen, was die machen.
Naja, aber die, die den Laden gegründet haben, die sind ja mittlerweile eh nicht mehr bei Twitter.
Erzähl doch mal kurz die Story, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die da so...
Dann können wir auch gleich noch drüber reden.
Ich weiß nur, dass das Quartier mittlerweile gegangen worden oder gegangen ist. Weiß ich nicht genau. Und Jack Doyle ist ja auch schon ewig nicht mehr, irgendwie seit einem Jahr oder so. Also die, die ursprünglich da irgendwie mal mit Twitter-ID 1 bis 100 oder so angefangen haben, die sind glaube ich alle nicht mehr dabei.
Verstehe und haben auch ordentlich abgesandt, aber...
Bisschen Investor-Kohle mitgetragen, mit rausgetragen, ja.
Ja, die geht es jetzt bestimmt nicht so schlecht.
Nö, der eine, der... Ich sehe nicht bis irgendwas. Der hat doch irgendwie fleißig neue Start-ups auch gepusht.
Über eins können wir auch gleich noch reden. Aber jetzt kommt ja sozusagen ein neuer Player ins Feld. Das ist ein Thema, was wir letztes Mal hätten schon aufgreifen können. Was ich vielleicht aufgegriffen hätte, hätte ich mich zu dem Zeitpunkt schon ausreichend damit beschäftigt gehabt. Ich hab zwar dieses Video gesehen von diesem Deuten, der so ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht...
Kommt so ein bisschen merkwürdig rüber, ne?
Ist mir aber auch irgendwie, fand ich diese kantige Art dann auch wieder geiler, als irgendein geschmeidiger Schwätzer, der mir da so ein Elevator Pitch um die Nase schmiert. Also das war eher so...
Es trägt nicht der Elevator Pitch schlechthin?
Ja, aber nicht so... Der nicht so käsig halt, ja. So wie man das sonst so kennt, finde ich.
Dieser Blick so, dieses...
Es war nicht so awesome und amazing.
Er hat es nicht gut gemacht, ne, ne. Also so richtige Schleimer, die kriegen das noch deutlich geschmeidiger über den Kanal. Und da war er fast noch ein bisschen... Da kam noch ein bisschen der Nerd durchgeblitzt und er nicht so richtig weiß, was er da jetzt in diesem Video soll oder so.
Und ich glaub, wie vielen ging es mir so, dass ich eigentlich nicht so ganz verstanden habe, worauf er hinaus wollte. Und ich hab dann eigentlich erst durch andere Blogposts im Nachgang so ein bisschen eine Ahnung gewonnen, die jetzt sozusagen gerade meine Ahnung ist. Können wir ja mal hier abgleichen, was ihr so meint. Hat dann letztlich aber bei mir dazu geführt, dass ich da auch Geld in den Topf geworfen habe. Sogar gleich zweimal.
Für Meterebene und für Temperatur.
Genau. Hab ich jetzt auch beides. Das war mir... Und so, was ist das jetzt? Ich glaube, viele reden davon, das ist jetzt das neue Twitter. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt erstmal eine sehr simple, plumpe Wahrnehmung dessen. app.net ist ein Projekt, was eine Plattform für Social Media Anwendungen sein möchte. Und anders als diese Diaspora-Entwickler sind es ja auch alles Leute, die sowas auch schon mal gebaut haben. Ich weiß nicht, wie dieser Dienst hieß, den er da vorher gemacht hat. Er hatte da irgendwie so einen...
Hieß das nicht auch app.net? Also es lief vorher schon mal so unter app.net?
Nee, der hat irgendwie einen Bildersdienst gehabt mit ein paar Millionen User. Ja, genau. Pick Place heißt es dann wahrscheinlich. Achso, ich dachte, Place. Pick Please, Pick Place, keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich war das auch der Grund, warum er jetzt was anderes macht. Auf jeden Fall sind das alles gestandene Developer, die sich da in diesem Bereich schon ein bisschen umtreiben. Und seine Argumentation ist im Kern die, eine Plattform, die nicht für die User arbeitet, sondern für die Werbung, kann irgendwie langfristig einfach nicht tomen.
Kann immer sterben gehen.
Und er möchte jetzt gerne was bauen, was eben diese Plattform ist, sozusagen. Und dann eben auch wirklich eine Plattform ist. Das heißt, es ist nicht ein Dienst, den man dann benutzt, sondern es ist eine Plattform, die man als User benutzen kann oder als Developer benutzen kann. Wenn man als Developer einsteigen will, muss man auch gleich 100 Euro auf den Tisch legen. Wobei, das bezieht sich jetzt erst mal nur auf den Anfang. Also es hat gesagt, ihr könnt uns jetzt finanzieren, dass wir das machen. Und wenn ihr alle da seid, dann wissen wir auch, dass das gewollt wird. Und wenn ihr Geld bezahlt, dann ist quasi das, was ihr dafür bekommt, ist ein Jahr schon mal Usage von diesem Dienst, deren Bezahlwert wir eben derzeit jetzt mal auf 50 Dollar pro Nase oder eben das Doppelte für Developer Services bereitstellen. Und dann gab es dann irgendwie noch so ein Platinum Developer Account, wo du mit den Schmusis auch gleich essen gehen kannst und so. Das kostet irgendwie 1000 Dollar. Keine Ahnung, wie viele Leute das gemacht haben. Ein paar Irre gab es bestimmt. Naja, sie wollten 500.000 Dollar haben und haben am Ende, glaube ich, so 700.000 irgendwas abgerockt. Also wie das bei Crowdfunding in den letzten Metern.
Genau, weil ich halt auch glaube, dass nachdem, dass du erreicht hast, dass dann bei vielen halt noch so, okay, gut, das wird jetzt was, dann mach ich jetzt mal auch mal mit. Genau. Ich würde auch wetten, dass ich dann am Ende bestimmt noch mal deutlich mehr bekomme als ihre 500.000 oder 700.000.
Das Timing war auch gut mit diesem komischen API-Ankündigung 1.1 von Twitter. Das kommt ja noch dazu.
Extrem in die Hände gespielt.
Das kann man nach, oder?
Das hat sich so ein bisschen überschnitten und ich hatte das Gefühl, dass viele Leute haben sich diesen Twitter-Kram angeguckt und gesagt, nee, jetzt erst recht.
Genau, ich glaube, das war, da haben sie sich... Also es hätte wahrscheinlich trotzdem funktioniert, aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass es noch mal in die Hände gespielt hat. So, was kriegt man jetzt dafür? Erstmal gar nichts. Das Einzige, was es gibt, ist eine Alpha-Mini-Billo-Version von Twitter, die auch erst mal nur unter dem Namen Alpha bekannt ist und die dann eben entsprechend unter alpha.app.net läuft. Da kann man sich halt jetzt einen Account klicken, weil man, gehörte man zu diesen First Investors, dann könnte man auch gleich so einen Twitter-Nick direkt so über, ich hab diesen Twitter-Nick, den will ich wieder haben, so mit OOs und Tra-La-La sichern. Und wenn man danach gemacht hat, konnte man einfach sagen, welchen Account man gerne hätte. Und dann kriegt man den oder nicht. Und ja, und dann muss man noch mal battlen, dass man in diese Alpha auch reingelassen wird. Also man kriegt das nicht automatisch, sondern sie fügen halt jetzt, je nach wie sie das für Zumut behalten für das System neue User hinzu. Keine Ahnung, wie viel sie sich da jetzt irgendwie rumtummeln.
Ich hab das ja am Anfang überhaupt nicht verstanden. Ich hab dieses Ding gemacht, wollte mich dann anmelden und dann ging es nicht so hell.
Also angeblich haben sie, wo habe ich das von gesehen? 75.000 User? Ich weiß nicht, ob irgendwo die User stehen. Unique Users Today ist 2.606. Auf jeden Fall. Es gibt eine Seite. Geh mal hier auf diese Webseite, die ich in den Chat poste. Der Chat darf erst in 5 Minuten klicken, sonst ist die Seite gleich bestimmt down. Du guckst jetzt auf deinen Chat, ich paste eine URL und du klickst sofort drauf. Und da gibt es angeblich, also das wurde jetzt schon sehr viel repostet auf ab.net. Und deswegen ist die Seite wahrscheinlich jetzt auch derartig unresponsiv geworden, dass da der Graph gerade wieder steil nach unten zeigt.
11.800 Posts today und wo steht die User-Zahl?
Unique Users today steht da so in der Mitte und das war jetzt gerade mal 2600.
Okay, aber da steht jetzt nicht...
Also daran könnte man jetzt vielleicht ablesen, wie viel sie jetzt schon reingelassen haben sozusagen. Aber eigentlich kann das nicht sein, weil wenn sie 500.000 haben wollten und 50 Dollar war sozusagen der Minimumeinsatz, dann müssten sie ja mindestens 10.000...
Sie haben irgendwie auf einem Video von 10.000 Usern als kritischer Masse gesprochen.
Aber gut, jetzt ist wahrscheinlich, fängt der Tag gerade in Amerika an, vielleicht geht es dann auch gleich nochmal los.
Ja und wenn man ehrlich ist, so viel ist ja da im Moment auch nicht los und ich gucke auch alle zwei Tage noch rein.
Wer von uns hat denn da jetzt alles in der Crown? Du, Mapp? Du, Huckel? Und da Roddy nehme ich mal an, ne?
Wie folgt man denn da Leuten? Das habe ich auch noch gehört.
Einfach alpha abnetz slash Roddy und dann auf den Follow-Button klicken.
Ja, es ist mir auch gerade auch eingefallen, nachdem ich irgendwie hier jetzt ein paar Minuten rumgeklickt habe, wie ich denn hier mal irgendwie. Aber es ist tatsächlich einfach.
Genau. Und es ist eigentlich auch vollkommen unklar, ob dieser Alpha-Dienst jetzt als solcher so überleben wird. Das ist jetzt erstmal um was zu haben, wo man eben miteinander kommunizieren kann und so was twitterartiges, also ich sag mal ganz salopp, Microblogging braucht man halt heutzutage, wenn man einen Social-Media-Dienst hat. Aber, und jetzt ist jetzt sozusagen die Frage auch in die Runde, was ihr euch so vorstellen könnt, was sich dort so entwickeln könnte. Offensichtlich gibt es ja großes Developer-Interesse, viele hacken da an irgendwelchen Ups rum, so und das ist jetzt so der Pool, wo Developer Spaß haben und so ein bisschen Social-Media-Klimb im machen. Und man hat jetzt so ein Twittersystem mit 256 Zeichen, was ich auch mal eine ordentliche Ansage finde.
Ja, und mit schon jede Menge Third-Party-Clients, also die sind zwar alle unfertig und haben Krude Bugs, aber immerhin, es gibt schon diverse iPhone-Apps, Android-Apps, Desktop-Apps, sogar Web-Apps. Also da ist sozusagen innerhalb weniger Tage bereits schon eine große Appvielfalt da dringend rum entstanden.
Ja, was benutzt du?
Ja gerade so bin ich bei diesem Appetizer hängen geblieben auf dem Desktop. Ja, dieses Icon, das geht überhaupt gar nicht klar.
Der Elefant ist super.
Aber Moab sieht ein bisschen schicker aus, ja das mag sein, aber irgendwie, ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher. Ich betrachte die kleinen Software auch erstmal alpha und da wird sich sicherlich in den nächsten Wochen, Tagen wie auch immer noch was herauskristallisieren, was dann vielleicht mal irgendwie Sinn macht. Also ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht, was da noch so kommt, außer dieser Twitter-Funktionalität. Ich wäre jetzt nicht böse, wenn es nur Twitter in irgendwie mal, ja noch ein bisschen enhancer gäbe. Aber, ob sie das jetzt halt so weit aufbauen, so à la Facebook, Social, Graph, Open Graph wie auch immer, worüber ja auch schon echt viel geht, für App-Developer, ob sie da so die volle Breitseite da fahren wollen, das, tja.
Aber warum gibt es denn eigentlich diese ganze Euphorie da rum? Da kommt jemand an und sagt, hey guck mal, gib mir 500.000 Dollar und dann entwickle ich euch einen Twitter-Klon.
Nein, das ist ja nicht das, worum es geht.
Natürlich, im Endeffekt ist es, also ist doch genau das.
Nein, es ist eine Plattform für Social Media. Man kann auch genau so was Facebook-artiges bauen und irgendwas anderes bauen, also es soll sozusagen.
Aber die API gibt das nicht her. Also die API, so wie sie jetzt beschrieben ist, gibt im Wesentlichen nur her, dass man sowas wie Twitter entwickelt.
Die von Alfa?
Ja, gibt es da mehr Spezifikationen?
Keine Ahnung, ich hab da keinen Überblick, aber es ist ja nicht beschränkt auf Twitter funktioniert.
Aber das haben erstmal viele so wahrgenommen, glaube ich schon.
Sie sagen halt, wir wollen hier irgendwie den Real-Time-Stream bauen. Und klar, kannst du damit am einfachsten jetzt erst mal Twitter machen, was du damit in Zukunft machen kannst, keine Ahnung, kann ich auch nicht abschätzen. Ich glaube, wo diese Euphorie herkommt, ist halt, wir kennen alle jemanden oder wir haben vielleicht alle selber schon gesagt, ich würde gerne für Twitter zahlen, damit ich dann irgendwie hier meine Limits nicht mehr habe oder hier meine Werbung nicht mehr habe oder was auch immer. Und jetzt probiert das halt mal jemand. Und ich glaube, da kommt diese Euphorie her. So hier jetzt probiert mal jemand wirklich einen Dienst zu machen, wo die Leute zahlen. Und ja, das ist das Problem, das ich sehe, wenn du wirklich so eine grundlegende, wir sehen jetzt, realtime Stream für alles machst und dann eben da die Zugangshürde so hoch setzt, dass du eben 50 Dollar im Jahr zahlen musst, dass es erzeugt einfach zu viele Ausschlüsse, als das irgendwie nützlich werden kann als Soziotop.
Also das halte ich nicht. Nicht für das Problem. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein kleiner Dienst mit einer relativ elitären, in Anführungsstrichen, ich meine, so wahnsinnig viel Geld ist es jetzt ja auch nicht, User-Gruppe.
Ich werde schon extrem drauf an, wer du bist.
Also klar, aber ich meine, das ist, also, also, gegen jeden...
Na, wenn jeder Account, wenn jeder Twitter, in Anführungsstrichen, Account hier 50 Dollar kostet, dann wird's teuer für mich.
Ja, das ist vielleicht weniger, aber das ist vielleicht auch...
Ja, aber für jedes Projekt, die sich jetzt sagen, esse ich oder habe ich ein Up.net-Account. Und die lese ich auf Twitter gerne und die würde ich auch auf up.net gerne lesen, aber die sind da halt nicht, weil sie können sich halt einfach nicht leisten.
Aber das ist ja nicht auszuschließen, dass sie jetzt im Laufe ihrer Entwicklungszeit auch auf irgendwelche Free-Tier-Modelle kommen oder halt irgendwie 10 Tweets pro Tag oder weißt schon so die klassischen Flickermodelle irgendwie. Du hast so und so viele Tweets pro oder Posts pro...
Oder halt irgendwelche mit 10 Modelle, dass du irgendwie User-Sponsoren kannst.
Read only is free oder was auch immer. Da gibt es ja tausende Varianten, wie du auch irgendwie gratis Leute da irgendwie reinlassen kannst. Und sie anfixen.
Ich fand halt an diesem, wie ich es wirklich sehr fand, Werbevideo, was er da am Anfang war, wo er so diese Story erzählt, dass das Problem wäre mit werbegetriebenen Netzwerken, dass die nicht für den User arbeiten, sondern sie arbeiten nur für die Werbeindustrie. Und wenn du nicht für deinen Dienst bezahlst, dann bist du nur das Produkt. Das haben wir jetzt hinreichend oft gehört. Das mag ja auch stimmen. Aber er weckt...
Nee, also das Produkt bist du nicht, aber egal.
Aber er weckt den Eindruck, sozusagen, wenn man bezahlt, dann ist man automatisch immer der Kunde. Und der Kunde ist immer König. Und als König hat man automatisch gewonnen. Das ist so ein bisschen den Eindruck und die Hoffnung, die er, glaube ich, weckt. Und ich weiß nicht, ich kenne zu viele Branchen, wo ich für mein Produkt vollständig bezahle und das nicht über Werbung finanziert. Und trotzdem, die Gesamte, alle auf mich scheißen. Also wenn ich mir die Telekommunikationsbranche angucke, die machen sich nicht im geringsten die Mühe, mir Produkte zu entwickeln, die mir irgendwie in den Kram passen.
Die haben aber auch ein Oligopol.
Na Moment mal, wenn du hier so ein app.net hast und wenn das erstmal 200.000 User hat, Das konkurriert mit allem, was auf dem Internet ist. Die haben genau den gleichen Log-in-Effekt, wie Facebook auch hat. Krieg da mal deine Daten raus und zwar so.
Aber trotzdem kannst du auch beliebig Konkurrenz aufmachen.
Das ist ja ein Selbstversprechen.
Du kannst aber nicht jederzeit einen neuen Mobilfunkprovider aufmachen, der genauso aufgestellt ist.
Du kannst auch nicht jederzeit ein neues Social Network aufmachen.
Natürlich kannst du das tun. Das machen sie ja hier auch.
Du brauchst keine Lizenz vom Staat dafür zum Beispiel.
Also es gibt hinreichend viele.
Banken, Verlage.
Such dir einen anderen Vergleich, der greift nicht.
Banken kannst du auch nur mit Lizenz aufmachen. Verlage.
Ich glaube, die Lizenz ist vor allen Dingen das Grundkapital, was du haben musst, was irgendwie eine Million ist oder noch mehr. Also das ist...
Ja, so. Aber wenn die, diese Theorie, dass sie immer im Sinne des Kunden entwickeln, ist einfach Schwachsinn. Es gibt, wie gesagt, diverse Beispiele, wo das nicht der Fall ist. Wie zum Beispiel die Filmindustrie. Und jeder kann theoretisch ein Filmstudio gründen, die lieber ihre Kunden verklagen als Enibre Brugte auf einem Weg anzubieten, was sie okay finden.
Naja, aber nach dieser Maxime dürftest du nichts mehr kaufen. Im Endeffekt kann dich ja jeder irgendwie übers Ohr hauen und immer an deine Interessen vorbeientwickeln.
Natürlich kann er es.
Klar ist es naiv zu glauben, dass der Kapitalismus und der Markt die Lösung aller Probleme sind. Nämlich, dass du mit deinem Geld da irgendwie abstimmst und wenn es scheiße ist, dann kaufen die Leute keine Accounts mehr und deswegen wäre das dann in sich Motivation genug, dass es eben nicht scheiße ist. Das ist natürlich alles naiv. Der Punkt ist aber, man kann es ja mal ausprobieren. Und das ist noch nicht ausprobiert worden. Und das ist glaube ich da, wo dieser Disconnect da ist. Es ist einfach so...
Aber warum liefert er nicht erst mal?
Von was denn?
Ich meine, die haben während ihrer Crowdfunding-Phase, während die noch nicht abgeschlossen war, ist da schon was entstanden. Na, programmier mal einen.
2000 Usern? Der Punkt ist nämlich genau der, den du gerade machst. Also, liefer doch erst mal. Das ist ja die Mentalität so. Hol dir mal irgendwie Venture-Kapital, kauf mal irgendwelche Leute ein, hol dir mal irgendwo Geld.
Wie viele Firmen hat der jetzt? Also ich meine, er hat ja eine Firma, der diese app.net...
Das ist mir doch egal. Soll der doch preisereich werden? Das ist mir ja so wurscht.
Nee, ist ja auch...
Also der Punkt ist ja so, hier ist ein Typ, der versucht, mit einem Business-Modell einen Webservice zu machen und nicht mit einem Webservice, einem Business-Modell.
Na erstmal hat er noch kein Business-Modell.
Wieso hat er kein Business-Modell?
Die zahlen 50 Dollar im Jahr.
Es gibt ein paar Leute, die haben jetzt 50 Dollar im Jahr gezahlt, aber ihr habt die ganze Zeit darüber geredet, vielleicht wird es ja auch Free-Accounts geben, vielleicht wird es das und das geben. Also ein richtiges Business-Modell hat er noch nicht.
Das Business-Modell ist klar, die User zahlen 50 Dollar. Was darüber hinaus dann passiert, ob sich das weiterentwickelt, kann passieren. Darüber haben wir spekuliert. Aber erstmal ist das wesentlich mehr Business-Modell als alles andere, was im Internet so mal einen Dienst macht.
Und das ist wert genug zu sagen, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob da jemals was für rauskommt, ich schmeiß da jetzt 50 Dollar in den Pool und wenn der jetzt damit durchbrennt, dann ist das für mich okay.
Allein schon um Twitter den Finger zu zeigen und zu zeigen, wir reden nicht nur, dass wir bezahlen würden, sondern wir zahlen auch. Aber leider kriegt ihr jetzt gerade das Geld nicht, weil ihr wolltet es ja nicht haben. Und das war bei mir die primäre Motivation.
Das war, glaube ich, bei mir auch so.
Einfach so, hier Stinkefinger und so weiter und wir machen das jetzt einfach. Und du könnt mir tausendmal erzählen, das kann nicht funktionieren, wenn es nicht frei und kostenlos und blalala ist. Ja, natürlich, Dinge können nicht funktionieren, wenn man sie anders macht, wie man sie immer gemacht hat. Das kann gehen. Es kann auch schief gehen, aber ich hab schon ganz andere Sachen schief gehen sehen. Im Netz. Und hat mich am Schluss 100 Dollar gekostet. Also das ist mir der Versuch wert.
Aber wärs da nicht sinnvoller, tatsächlich das Geld zum Beispiel in Identica zu stecken? Die gibt's immerhin schon.
Die haben kein Businessmodell.
Ja und? Ich mein, ihr nutzt ja alle BSD, das hat auch kein Businessmodell, trotzdem nutzt ihr's.
Nicht alles, was hängt, ist ein Vergleich.
Aber da schmeißt man auch kein Geld rein. Identica hat ein Businessmodell.
Wem soll man's denn da geben?
Identica hat ein Businessmodell.
Welches Status net, incorporated, verkauft, Businessinstallation und Support dafür? Offensichtlich nicht gut genug, sonst können sie sich mehr Zeit leisten, um Arbeit in ihre Software reinzustecken.
Das heißt nicht alles PHP?
Ja.
Also auch der Core?
Der Core? Wie soll denn das funktionieren?
Richtig. Aber ich stelle mir gerade vor, weil du das vorhin sagtest, irgendwie du gibst der Bank Geld und sie tut trotzdem nicht, was du willst. Wie denn das wäre, wenn ich mein Geld bei einer werbefinanzierten Bank hätte?
Es funktioniert auch, wenn du zahlst, in vielen Fällen einfach nicht. Das ist doch genau das Versprechen, was er gesagt hat. Das ist das Einzige, warum das passiert.
Du musst ja nicht von deinen Negativbeispielen auf die gesamte Welt schließen. Das ist ja der maximal pessimistische Ansatz. Aber gut, bist du grundsätzlich pessimistisch gestimmt, dann ist das so. Aber man muss ja nicht von dem einen auf das andere schließen.
Meine Argumentation wäre, dass Userzahlen für den Dienst getriebene Dienste vielleicht einfach besser funktionieren als die werbekunden finanzierten Dienste. Also für mich als Kunden zumindest. Natürlich kann ein Dienst immer noch schlecht sein, obwohl ich dafür bezahle. Aber wenn nicht mal ich derjenige bin, der dafür bezahlt, dann ist der Dienst garantiert schlecht, weil es dann wirklich nicht mehr um mich geht, sondern nur noch um den, der bezahlt. Und das ist halt dann der Werbetreibende.
Ja, aber es geht auch...
Das ist Ihr Fernsehen.
Es geht auch nur... Also ich meine, wenn er einmal drinne ist, dann braucht er die Qualität dieses Dienstes gerade mal so hoch zu halten, damit du nicht rausgehst. Um Zweifelsfall muss halt irgendwelche... Also ich meine...
Das ist vielleicht am Ende immer noch viel besser als Twitter.
Ich meine, wenn zum Beispiel, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass du einfach...
Aber Twitter hat doch genau das Gleiche. Die müssen auch nur gut genug sein, dass die Werbekunden nicht abhauen.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel bei app.net könnte es dir durchaus passieren, dass du schriftlich kündigen... Also jetzt nur mal so als böses Beispiel, ich sag nicht, dass sie das machen, da mögen ja auch Idealisten sein und das gut funktionieren lassen, dass du schriftlich kündigen musst. Und da ein Fax und weißer Teufel und per Einschreiben und so. Ich meine, wie sollst du alle diese Tricks anwenden, um dich da in irgendwelche Verträgen zu entzünden?
Es könnte ja auch sein, dass Apple jetzt anfängt, dir Abos für dein MacBook zu verkaufen und du sie schriftlich kündigen musst.
Ja, machen sie aber nicht.
Aber Apple hat sogar Produkte. Das ist nämlich der Unterschied.
Und sogar Produkte, die du kaufst und gerne benutzt.
Ja, im Gegensatz zu Appletnet, die nix haben. Die einfach nur sagen, gib mir 50 Dollar.
Also, die haben schon ein Produkt. Ich sehe da so Posts in meiner Timeline. Ja, es funktioniert.
Max ist skeptisch.
Zu Recht.
Skeptisch kann man ja hier auch sein. Ich bin hier auch skeptisch. Aber ich bin hier auch grundsätzlich. Ich meine, ich kenne zumindest jetzt keinen überzeugenderen Ansatz, wo auch eine kritische Masse von Entwicklern mitspielt. Das ist für mich überhaupt das Reizvolle, dass das etwas ist, wo viele Developer ein Interesse daran haben. Also dass das wirklich ein System ist, wo sie sich alle zusammenführen und sagen, okay, lass uns mal hier wirklich gemeinsam ein System finanzieren, was für uns eine gute Plattform ist und darauf können sich dann die neuen Anwendungen entwickeln. Ich meine, derzeit hast du halt so Twitter, der große Chor, und dann gibt's so viele lustige kleine Ideen, die da so drum herum rangeklatscht sind, aber irgendwie nichts wird so richtig Teil vom Ganzen. So lange bis Twitter dann nach drei Jahren endlich mal einsicht, dass das ja vielleicht eine tolle Idee war, dann übernehmen sie das und schieben dann auch sofort alle beiseite. Die irgendwie Image-Url-Shortener und machen die eigentlich URL-Shortening?
Ich finde, dass für den Twitterdienst Oh, Dennis ist auch noch da. Müsste das passieren, was bei den Instant-Messaging-Systems passiert ist. Nämlich vorher gab es ja nur hier AIM und Ease, ICQ und MSN und so. Central Server Intelligence oder wie heißt die? Ich weiß schon. Und dann kam irgendwie Java und alles ist irgendwie verteilt.
Also du meinst, es müsste jemand identica.ccc.de aufsetzen und da sollten dann alle drauf und dann wäre gut.
Aber ganz viele von irgendwas...
Nein, also mein Punkt ist, Federation funktioniert nicht, weil die Leute trotzdem immer auf allen Server rennen.
Aber sind ja nicht auf AIM.
Wie viele Leute in deinem Java-Roster sind nicht auf javaberlin.ccc.de?
Klar, die Leute, die ich kenne, schon. Macht ja auch Sinn. Oder weiß nicht, ob das Sinn macht, aber das erklärt sich ja. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die ganze Welt auf dem ccc-Server ist. Die sind schon noch ein bisschen woanders.
Aber wenn javaberlin.ccc.de down ist, dann kannst du nicht chatten. Oder JavaBerlin, was auch immer.
Wie die Leute es dann benutzen, ist mir erst mal egal, aber es besteht die Möglichkeit.
Aber ist für dich dieses Argument der Dezentralisierung halt komplett nichtig, weil du komplett zentralisiert chattest. Auch mit Java.
Das ist da aber nicht das Argument.
Das ist das einzige, was wirklich dezentralisiert funktioniert, ist doch BitTorrent, oder?
Mehl.
Funktioniert dezentral.
Also klar, auch mit den Mails, wenn alle deine Kumpels auf deinem gleichen Mailserver drauf sind, und da kennen wir auch einen, wo das so ist, das ist doch klar, aber trotzdem gibt es noch tausende Mailserver, tausende Java-Server und das finde ich einfach viel cooler als irgendwie...
Es gibt auch tausende Social Networks, also...
Sicher? Ja, aber die sprechen nicht miteinander. Ich finde, Twitter könnte man schon so machen, dass jeder irgendwie von seinem Hacker-Kumpel den Twitter-Ersatz irgendwie benutzt, und dann sind da mal so ein paar Hundert oder vor mir auch so ein paar tausend Leute drauf. Aber halt nicht irgendwie... Wie viele User hat Twitter? 500 Millionen, 100 Millionen, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe auch nichts dagegen, Föderation einzubauen in irgendwelche Dienste. Das Ding ist halt nur... Das passiert halt nicht. Also Identica war...
Ja, bei Java hat das funktioniert.
Bei Java hat das funktioniert, aber es basiert ja drauf. Aber Identica war letztes Sommer Google of Code, das Projekt, irgendwie mal DMs zu föderieren. Da ist nichts draus geworden, immer noch nicht. Da warten wir seit Jahren drauf, DMs.
Na gut, aber ich mein, wenn es in PHP geschrieben ist...
Ja, aber ich meine... Also ich würde auch keine 50 Dollar zahlen.
Ja, ist nicht...
Vor allem, was ich auch ein bisschen lame finde, also alle anderen Buden, die besorgen sich Venture Capital und besorgen sich dann eine Million, legen da irgendwie los. Und wenn es dann aber noch funktioniert, dann ist natürlich der Typ, der die Kohle gegeben hat, der will da natürlich seinen riesen Anteil haben. Und deswegen ist es nicht so einfach, so eine Million zu kriegen, außer das ist so ein voll geilen Plan. Bei diesen ganzen Kickstarter-Projekten, die besorgen sich auch ihre 700.000, so wie viel auch immer. Und wenn es aber nichts wird, ja, habt ihr alle Pech gehabt. Wenn es aber was wird, habt ihr auch alle Pech gehabt, dann kriegt ihr nicht mal wieder Investoren, irgendwie euren Anteil.
Das ist ja genau der Punkt, den ich irgendwie, das hatte ich ja glaube ich auch getwittert, ich würde ja, wenn ich so ein Kickstarter-Projekt mache und da so eine Firmengründung im Sinn habe, dann würde ich irgendwie so zehn Premium-Pakete raus tun, wo sie ja jeweils ein Prozent Options kriegen. Und das ist dann halt auch richtig teuer, aber das lohnt sich dann halt auch richtig, wenn es was wird.
Also ein Prozent ist ja ein bisschen viel, aber da kann man sagen, wenn man dann eine Million anpeilt, dann kriegst du halt den Anteil der Firma, wie du halt Anteil von dieser Million halt irgendwie gegeben hast.
Ja, irgendwie so Shares halt. Das hat bisher noch keiner gemacht, ne?
Doch, das gibt's. Also das gibt's nicht auf Kickstarter. Das gibt's wahrscheinlich sogar auf Kickstarter verboten, kann ich mir vorstellen. Das gibt's woanders. Ich hab ja leider vergessen, wie es heißt. Das war genau das Gleiche. So investiere ich ganz leicht in Firmen.
Damit hätte app.net vielleicht auch viel schneller die 500.000 zusammen gekriegt.
Ich bin ja bei diesen ganzen Kickstarter-Sachen. Ich hab das Gefühl, dass das ein ziemlich aufgeblasener Hype ist. Weil da gibt's mittlerweile auch einige Sachen, die ziemlich sicher nach hinten gehen werden. Und wenn da Leute, also ich erinnere nur an diese alberne Android-Spielkonsole, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die mitbekommen habt.
Jungs, ihr müsst eure Biere mal hier zumachen. Das mit den Fliegen hier, das ist irgendwie nicht cool.
Das glaube ich ist eher von dein Fruchtsaft oder der süße Mate.
Was komplett überfinanziert ist. Und wo wahrscheinlich, selbst wenn die Leute jemals irgendwie ein Stück hässlicher China-Plastik sehen, sie das nach drei Minuten in die Ecke schmeißen werden und hassen werden, weil es einfach nicht funktionieren wird. Und das Gefühl hab ich bei sehr, sehr vielen dieser Projekte, die da im Augenblick sehr euphorisch hochgetrieben werden. Und ich hab das Gefühl, dass app.net dazugehört.
Das ist schon eine grundpessimistische Sicht auf die Dinge.
80 Euro für eine Kiste Bier.
Ja, nee, das ist ja auch richtig, dass das natürlich große Chancen hat, auch nach hinten loszugehen. Aber es ist jetzt so eine kleine Epoche halt, wo die Leute irgendwie jetzt mal so die Dezentralität auch beim Finanzieren von Projekten mal ausprobieren und in wahrscheinlich ein, zwei, drei, vier Jahren werden wir dann alle schlauer sein und sehen, was da draus geworden ist. Aber ich will Cookies and Cream. Ich will Cookies and Cream.
Das ist deins, musst du mit ihm klar machen. Kann ich ihn mal nicht einfach wegnehmen.
Für die Zuhörer, die nix mitkriegen, wir haben hier gerade alles ausgeteilt bekommen.
Aber sag mal... Ich esse immer das große Schock.
Aber nicht für app.net bezahlen hier, ja? Also, ja, ich meine, ich hab bei Kickstarter, glaube ich, nicht ein einziges Projekt gesponsert und irgendwie app.net war auch so irgendwie ein bisschen trotz Reaktionen.
Ich hab letztens in Porsche geklickt.
Man sollte das, glaube ich, auch nicht tun, wenn man es sich nicht unbedingt leisten kann. Also wenn man sich hinterher ärgert, dass nichts draus geworden ist, dann ist es vielleicht auch sowieso eine schlechte Idee.
Na ja, ich meine, du wirst dich auch wahrscheinlich bei 50 Dollar schon ärgern, wenn nichts draus wird, oder? Egal, ob du das leisten kannst oder nicht.
Aber leider die Sache ist doch ganz einfach. Diese Kickstarter-Dinger, die können den Leuten auch nur so viel Geld aus der Tasche ziehen, wie die haben. Das heißt, irgendwann überlegst du dir, wo du dein Geld irgendwie in welches Kickstarter-Projekt investierst. Und wenn dann natürlich demnächst Projekte kommen, die sagen, ey, hier, yo, ich hab die geile neue Idee, ich brauch eine Mille. Und jeder, der da irgendwie ab 100 Dollar irgendwie mir hier irgendwie sponsort, der kriegt halt genau Anteil an dieser Mille von meiner Firma, wenn es denn mal was wird. Und natürlich investiere ich dann lieber mein Geld dahin, weil dann weiß ich, wenn es was wird, dann hab ich wenigstens was davon und nicht zu dem anderen Projekt, der sich dann mit irgendwie meinen 100 Dollar verpisst. Wenn es was geworden ist und dick abkastiert und ich hab's ihm bezahlt. Und so einfach wird sich das von alleine regeln, oder?
Du kaufst halt die Katze im Sack. Bisher hab ich nur Katzen bekommen, die ich halbwegs okay fand. Oder gut sogar. Aber es ist halt einfach so, du siehst irgendwie Monochrom will jetzt einen Film drehen, das ist die Rasooloo, und will halt da Kickstarter-Geld dafür. Und du denkst dir so, hey Monochrom mag ich eigentlich total gern. Die haben in der Vergangenheit lustige Sachen gemacht. Dann geb ich denen halt mal einen Zehner. So auch aus, ich fand jetzt irgendwie das Zeug, was ihr vorher gemacht habt, gut. Und ich hoffe ihr könnt das neu auch machen. Und wenn das gut wird, noch umso besser. Es ist halt irgendwie so, es ist so ein bisschen wie Flatter auch. Du gibst halt irgendwie Geld an jemanden, wo du denkst, das könnte was werden. Und ob das jetzt irgendwie daraus motiviert ist, dass du das Video guckst und dir denkst, das macht jetzt einen okayen Eindruck. Oder ob du dir denkst, hey Monochrom, cool. Im Endeffekt kaufst du die Katze im Sack.
Man muss man ja nicht unbedingt.
Iron Sky hat es doch auch geklappt. Wer hat was für Iron Sky gespendet?
Das hätte ich auch bitter bereut, wenn ich das gemacht hätte.
Wieso? Ist doch ein cooler Film geworden.
Ich habe noch nicht gesehen.
Den Film fand ich auch okay, aber mir waren die insgesamt nicht... Also interessanter hätte ich es gefunden, wenn sie wirklich komplett auf Crowdfunding gegangen sind. Aber sie hatten ja immer noch diese ganzen Abhängigkeiten und so ein bisschen bekloppt sind die, glaube ich, auch. So richtig cool fand ich das Team jetzt nicht, was jetzt so ihre Einstellungen betrifft mit Kopierheiten. Die haben ja jetzt auch da ihre Anwälte, die irgendwie die Leute verfolgen dafür, dass sie den Film runtergeladen haben und so weiter. Das ist mir dann einfach nicht das richtige Versprechen an der Stelle. Sie haben halt zwar Geld bekommen, aber ich fand so, denn das was so zurück kam, was dafür versprochen wurde, war nicht die richtige Mischung. Gut, wir werden es sehen. Ich denke zwar, dass Max mit seiner Voraussage, dass Abnet nie 15.000 User haben wird, wahrscheinlich schon in der nächsten Sendung gestrandet sein wird.
Aber Timme, Multi-Accounts von dir zählen nicht, ne?
Na ja, dann kannst du einen abziehen, wenn man wahrscheinlich der einzige, der zwei Counts hat.
Der erste.
Aber ich wusste schon, Eis bringt jetzt ein bisschen Ruhe rein. In den ganzen Sport. Auf jeden Fall, wenn ihr da draußen, außerhalb dieses Studios, wenn ihr auch irgendwie ein Abnet 50 Euro zu viel habt, dann, na ja, wenn ihr schon dabei seid, macht euch bemerkbar. Also ich bin wie auf Twitter Tim Brittlaff. Roddy ist Roddy, Huckel ist Huckel.
Mapp ist Mapp.
Mapp ist Mapp. Und der Rest ist noch enthaltungs... Twittert mit Identika und Schert.
Ich bin da konservativ. Die sollen erstmal was bringen und dann gucken wir mal und überhaupt. Und dann steigen wir auch mal später ein.
Oder ich registriere mir 3-4-3-MAX.
Dann verifiziert immer, das will ich ja mal sehen.
Max Telefonnummer hat er auch. Nee, er kann ja seine eigene sogar eingeben.
Wo wir vorhin schon bei diesem Event tralala waren und den Twitter-Gründer, der ja vorher auch blogger.com gemacht hat und der übrigens auch vorher Odeo gemacht hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich irgendjemand von euch noch daran erinnert. Interessanterweise war das der Bett auf Podcasting. Die dachten damals, das wäre sozusagen the next big thing. Und haben dann so eine Plattform gestartet, die nannte sich odeo.com, wo man so auf der Webseite direkt mit Flash recorden und podcasten konnte. Ich denke, woran das gescheitert ist, ist schlicht nicht unbedingt... Ich wollte es jetzt nicht sagen. Nee, dass man so halt nicht podcastet. Also dieses Instant-Podcasting, das hat auch mit Telefon-Podcasting und so weiter nicht funktioniert. Weil die Qualität ist da einfach zu schlecht und man macht nicht mal eben so ein Podcast. Also auch dieses, wie heißt es noch gleich, dieses andere... Audiobu, weiß ich nicht, hebt für mich irgendwie auch nicht so richtig ab. Und daher ist das nicht so richtig was geworden. Und ich glaube, als iTunes dann irgendwie mit Podcasting kamen, haben sie dann auch schnell wieder die Serie gestrichen. Wobei ich es interessant gefunden hätte, wenn sie so gesagt hätten, wir machen jetzt hier mal so richtig Podcast-Hosting. Aber das ist halt nicht so der Massenmarkt gewesen. Nichtsdestotrotz haben sie jetzt wieder sich was Neues ausgedacht. Ich habe es mir noch nicht besonders gut angeschaut. Medium, eine Blogging-Plattform.
Davon haben wir noch nicht genug.
Das haben die auch gesagt. Weil es ja nicht so, dass es nicht gebloggt wird. Aber es ist so, dass es doch schon Probleme gibt mit der Einfachheit, der Optik, der Sicherheit, der Aggregation. Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist Medium eine Blogging-Plattform. Die sich vor allem darin unterscheidet, wie du deine Sachen veröffentlicht. Oder wohin du sie veröffentlicht. Wenn du in deinem Blog immer so dein eigenes Reich hast, und da schreibst du halt und vielleicht lässt du andere mitschreiben, kannst du in Medium quasi in so eine Gesamtsuppe hineinschreiben. Du kannst ja deinen Thema-Pool aussuchen und dann deine Nachricht da in ein oder mehrere Themen-Pools einstellen. Und alles, was dann innerhalb dieses Themen-Pools hochgewotet wird, weiß ich nicht, viel gelesen wird, da verließen sie ihn. Ich glaub, es ist auch chronologisch. Einfach nur chronologisch. Also es ist mehr so ein automatisches Magazin, was sich da aufbauen soll.
Sie nennt es ja irgendwie Collections. Und die gibt es halt irgendwie in offen und geschlossen. Also eine geschlossene Collection ist im Prinzip halt sowas wie ein Blog. Und so eine offene ist halt sowas wie eine Soup. Du hast gerade schon Suppe gesagt. Es geht schon sehr in Richtung Soup-Io dahingehend. Wenn du so irgendwie diese Gruppensoups zum Beispiel hast, wo du irgendwie reinposten kannst. Das geht schon, das sieht halt so aus, nur in hübsch und wahrscheinlich in weniger Serverumkipp.
Das ist ja hübsch.
Ja, ist vor allem wohl hübsch.
Genau.
Da steht nur Your Text Here.
Kannst auch gleich Medium followen.
Und Sign In.
Genau.
Naja, also ich finde das sehr interessant. Ich denke, dass da noch eine Menge zu machen ist, wenn man sich so diese...
Du willst Medium followen?
Ich will Medium auch followen.
Ich hab genau gesehen, dass du die Terms of Serbs nicht gelesen hast.
Doch, doch.
Vorbereitung zur Sendung.
Hab ich gestern schon gesehen.
Also du kannst dich da irgendwie einloggen, du kannst aber dann noch nichts machen, weil irgendwie Invitation Only und irgendwie wir machen das ganz privat hier noch. Es sieht interessant aus und es sind interessante Leute dahinter.
Was ich sagen wollte ist, heute hast du so die Wahl, entweder bist du bei so einem Blog-Hoster, so wie WordPress, da bist du irgendwie auch voll das Opfer. Oder du bist halt irgendwie in deinem eigenen Blog und dann bist du irgendwie Opfer der System-Administration. Eigentlich auch wieder von WordPress oder was auch immer sonst gerade.
Dieses Perl-basierte, was früher... Movable Type.
Das waren noch Zeiten.
Es sind immer noch Zeiten, das gibt es immer noch. Aber ist auch immer noch Perl.
Naja, also schlimmer als PHP ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Der Ring Fireball ist Movable Type zum Beispiel.
Movable Type ist ganz, ganz schlimm. Also sorry, das ist... Jetzt möcht ich gern mal sagen hier, also Movable Type soll schlimmer, also ist Dimension schlimmer als WordPress.
Aber auch da gibt es Fanboys, die sagen, es ist besser als alles andere auf dem Planeten.
Gibt es da ernsthaft jemanden, der das noch sagt?
Aber die Leute, die das sagen... Ich möchte euch jetzt nicht... Hangen auf Pöltschi, Schatz. Den möchte ich jetzt nicht auf den Schlips treten, aber die sind, also die, die ich kenne, also ich kenne zwei und die sind beide auch ein bisschen... Na ja, anders.
So, dann gibt es ja noch dieses andere Betriebssystem.
Windows.
Von dem man jetzt nicht so genau weiß, wie es eigentlich heißen soll. Aber wahrscheinlich heißt es jetzt Windows 8. Ist das jetzt eigentlich schon erschienen?
Ja, ich weiß doch.
Woher weißt du das?
Das habe ich in so einem Podcast gehört.
Windows 8 User Experience.
Also 200 Dollar, ja? 200 Dollar?
Nee. Das OS.
In the end. Und wenn du bis Januar zugreifst, dann 80 Dollar.
Das ist das übliche. Vorher ist es billiger und später wird es ein Dollar. Das ist noch nie passiert.
Aber das hat doch, irgendjemand hat doch getwittert, gepostet. So war es nicht dieser Coding Horror, Jeff Artwood, der dann irgendwie dann in seinem Fanboy Windows 8 Post irgendwie meinte, ja und jetzt ist es auch endlich billig geworden und kostet irgendwie auch unter 100 Dollar und so. Ich hab doch da irgendwas gelesen.
Vielleicht für diesen Early Bird Preis, keine Ahnung. Aber gibt es da nicht wieder so Pro Home Super Deluxe Edition und alles mögliche?
64-Bit Edition. Ok, was gibt es dazu zu sagen?
Ich dachte ihr hätt irgendwas interessantes gehört. Auf jeden Fall gibt es da eine totale Konfusion. Irgendwie ob man das jetzt ein Metro nennen darf oder nicht. Ich frage mich ja warum Microsoft nicht einfach zu Metro AG gesagt hat. Nee nicht fuck you, sondern hier.
Anderes Business und so, ist doch mal voll egal.
Ich meine die haben 13 Milliarden Dollar für Skype bezahlt oder waren sieben? Ich komme total durcheinander. Irgendwie eine vollkommen bekloppte sinnlose abstrakte Suche.
Hast du auch schon in der letzten Sendung, dass Metro eben nicht so klein und billig ist, dass sie sich da nicht abzocken lässt. Aber sie sind schon trotzdem immer noch kleiner als Microsoft.
Vor allem wenn ihr denen Geld bietet, dann kriegen sie was sie wollen. Ich meine es kann ihnen auch scheißegal sein, dass es ein Betriebssystem gibt, was so heißt wie sie.
Das könnte man auch ausstreiten eigentlich. Also ich habe da nicht, dass sie da irgendwie ein Business haben, was überschneidet.
Was ich ja nicht verstehe, ist, zumindest im europäischen Markenrecht gibt es ja schon die Nitzer Klassen. Und warum sollte da die Metro AG die Klassen für Software und...
Für ein OS-Belegung, genau.
Weil sie die einfach mitgeholt haben. Das macht man halt so.
Aber da hat man dann schon Aussichten auf Erfolg in einem Rechtsstreitpotenzial.
Das denke ich nämlich auch. Und vor allem, ich habe mich schon am Anfang gefragt, als sie irgendwie mit dem Namen kam.
Metro AG, 66 Milliarden Dollar Umsatz. Euro sogar und Microsoft, 69 Milliarden Dollar. Das heißt, die sind schon Umsatz.
Umsatz, aber jetzt guck mal bei Gewinn.
Kommt gleich als nächstes. Du redest erst mal weiter, aber als kleine Einordnung.
Die einen verkaufen Schweinehälften, ja.
Da musstest du kämpfen für den, aber hast du gut gemacht.
Okay, und das ist trotzdem, also ich meine, die hätten den auf jeden Fall...
Findest du den Namen Metro so schick?
Ja, ich find den Namen total todschick und ich hätt es mega cool gefunden, wenn sie gesagt hätten, Scheiß auf Fenster, weil wir wollen jetzt eh keine mehr haben. Und wir machen jetzt einfach so ein richtig schönes, neues, OS, ja Kacheln, was weiß ich, aber da sind, ich meine, sie hätten es ja auch Tiles nennen können.
Ich find den Namen Metro auch schick.
Der hätte sich ja auch noch zugetraut. Und dann fand er im Hetero nicht mehr schick.
Ich finde, Metro geht gut von der, ich meine, wie schnell sich das eingeprägt hat. Ich meine, die haben das angekündigt und gesagt, das heißt jetzt Metro. Und es war überall in der Welt. Keiner hatte was dagegen, klang gut, kurz, prägnant, hat sich jeder sofort, jeder denkt sofort bei Metro jetzt an Microsoft.
Und nicht mehr an die Metro AG genau.
Also in unserem Kulturspreis, sag ich jetzt mal.
Also ich hätte den aber auch gekauft.
Also wenn du jetzt da draußen irgendwie zum Lastwagenfahrer gehst und sagst irgendwie, alter wie sieht es aus mit Metro? Und er sagt, da hat es schon zu.
Und von der BVG lernen heißt siegen lernen, denn schließlich hat die BVG erst vor nicht allzu langer Zeit ja auch ihre, also einige der Linien in Metro Linien umgenannt. Und Metrobus, also wie gesagt, die BVG war da schon sehr visionär voraus schon unterwegs.
Microsoft hat den Recht schon mal.
Ich hätte einfach diesen Windows-Namen gedroppt, weil er ist sowieso bekloppt. Ich meine, sie wollen ja auch weg von Fenstern. Sie wollen hin zu den bekloppten Kacheln, die ich auch Quatsch finde, aber so soll es nun mal sein.
Ich glaube du unterstellst da ein bisschen zu viel.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass Microsoft auf Windows verzichtet. Das ist eine der stärksten Marken, die die haben.
Ja, aber nicht mehr lange.
Die wird noch eine ganze Weile langsam sehr stark sein.
What's wrong with trying something new? Ich meine, wenn sie jetzt angefangen hat...
Windows Phone 7? Auf Windows Phone 7 gibt es keine Fenster. Und trotzdem heißt es Windows Phone.
Ja, das sag ich ja.
Aber ich glaube der Punkt ist, was du da siehst, was da nach außen dringt, ist halt so dieser interne Microsoft-Twist. Also es gibt halt irgendwie schon die coolen Microsoftler in Anführungszeichen, die halt so Sachen machen und das dann Metro nennen und irgendwie mal neue Konzepte durchdenken.
Hatten die ja nicht auch so ein komisches Prototype-Device, was sie dann irgendwie nicht gemacht haben oder so?
Microsoft Research ist sowieso nochmal eine ganz andere Ecke und irgendwie meistens auch ziemlich cool. Aber irgendwann kommt das halt so in diesen Design-by-Committee-Prozess rein, der bei Microsoft halt da so maßgebend ist. Und dann kommen da halt so Sachen wie Windows 8 User Experience hinten raus. Also ich glaube, die sind jetzt auch nicht unglücklich damit. Also vor allem nicht der Teil der Firma, der halt so drauf guckt, dass Windows halt die Marke bleibt und der irgendwie so die Einordnung macht von das sind Produkte, die machen Geld. Und der RS ist halt Spielkram und interessiert uns nicht.
Also ich hab jetzt nochmal nachgeschaut, ja. Also der Operating Income von Microsoft ist 21 Billionen US-Dollar. Und der Operating Income von der Metro AG ist 2,2 Billionen. Aber Euro in dem Fall. Also warte, Moment, Stopp. Ja, Billionen. 21 Billionen US-Dollar. Und 2,2 Billionen Euro. Das ist so bei der Metro AG.
Ja, wenn sie dem da ein paar Millionen vor die Nudel gehalten hätten, dann hätten sie ja einfach sofort zugegriffen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das der Grund ist. Das ist nur vorgeschoben. Irgendwelchen Schlipsies hat das nicht gepasst und dann war's das.
Das war zu metrosexuell.
Wahrscheinlich.
Na ja, was kümmert uns das?
Aber ich finde Windows 8 ja eh eine unausgegorene Chimere, aber dazu habe ich mich ja schon länglich geäußert.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das schlägen wird und auch nicht dieses komische Brett-Oberfläche.
Das Surface, das jetzt kein Tisch mehr ist, sondern ein iPad-Verschnitt.
It's just a small table.
Die Table hat es jetzt irgendwie anders. Die haben sie irgendwie auch, also das, was vorher gesagt hat. Nein, nein, nein, die haben es jetzt irgendwie auch, ich hab's vergessen.
Keine Ahnung, das hat alles mit der Benennung, hat das bei Microsoft einfach kein Hand und kein Fuß. So, kommen wir zum illustren Teil des Abends. Wenn du möchtest.
Nein, wenn wir schon bei Windows waren, können wir kurz über Nokia reden. Nokia hat QT verkauft.
Das ist aber auch schon alte News.
Finde ich aber trotzdem irgendwie witzig, dass von Nokia irgendwie noch sinnlose Dinge kommen.
Noch mehr weitere sinnlose Dinge.
Ja, ich meine, ich hatte immer so das Gefühl, QT war so das letzte große Standbein, was sie noch hatten, wenn sie irgendwann mal was reißen wollen, was eine Oberfläche hat. Und jetzt haben sie es verhökert.
Das ist ja auch ein ziemliches Bindeglied in so viel Software, die man eigentlich hätte lieber ohne QT haben wollen, aber ja.
Sie haben das ja irgendwie zuerst in einer Tochterfirma so oft gespint, um mal ein ganz schlimmes Wort zu benutzen. Und dann hieß es so, als du zu dem Zeitpunkt gesagt hast, jetzt ist es tot, hieß es dann, nein, nein, da ist immer noch Nokia drüber. Das heißt jetzt nur so anders als Gruppe und so. Und jetzt haben sie es halt verkauft, wie es abzusehen war. Und ja, wahrscheinlich jetzt immer noch Leute, die sagen so, nein, nein, an Digia weiß jemand, wer das ist? Nee, mich auch nicht.
Digiage.
Unerisch.
Einfach ein Digia, so wie Wikia.
Oh, Inventive Solutions bring success for people and businesses in everyday life.
In welchem Quadranten von der Twitter-Malatrix ist das jetzt?
Oh, Bullshit-Bingo-Quad-Damage.
Wir müssen auch den Fokus innerhalb der Global Pearson auf das Thema Business Consulting setzen.
Der Wikipedia-Artikel zu Digia ist großartig, weil der erste Absatz enthält das Nasterkürzel, der zweite Absatz sagt, wie viele das Employees das sind und der dritte Absatz sagt, sie haben Kuté gekauft.
Das reicht ja auch für das erste. Also ich hab mir einen Vaporizer gekauft, ne? Und auch den Messo gar nicht so...
B-Anschluss und da gibt's Mac Software oder was?
Nee, aber auch...
Warte mal, wovon reden wir jetzt? Wir reden Vaporizer von...
Wenn du Pfeifentabak hast oder so frische Minzblätter, sagen wir mal, ja? Und du möchtest die......möglichste... Also so steht's in der Bedienungsanleitung.
Pflanzliche Stoffe.
Es geht in der Bedienungsanleitung um Pflanzen. Um Pfeifentabak. Und auf diese Linie beschränken wir uns jetzt erst mal für das Erste. Minzblätter. So. Und da geht es halt darum, dass du diese Pflanzen-Dinge da halt nur erhitzt und nicht verbrennst. Und dadurch halt nicht die karzinogenen Stoffe, die da durchs Verbrennen stehen, irgendwie einatmen, sondern nur die Dämpfe quasi. Das soll jetzt nicht heißen, dass es gesünder ist, wie gerne viele sagen, sondern vielleicht weniger schädlich.
So.
Und zum anderen kommt halt auch tatsächlich geschmacklich und wirkungstechnisch sehr viel mehr dabei herüber, als wenn man es einfach nur verbrennen würde. Also bei Minze zum Beispiel, da hat man also auch wirklich, da pustet man die Lungen einmal durch und dann...
Die ätherischen Öle kommen viel besser zu Geld.
Ja, also es gibt da auch andere Kombinationen. Du kannst auch Thymian da reintun, da schläfste besser und es gibt da verschiedene Varianten. Ich bin mir sicher, Hopfen könnte man da auch Prema reintun. Vaporizer, dieser... Also diese Art, um eben zu vaporisieren, die gibt's in verschiedenen Bauformen. Die gibt's auch schon sehr lange, diese Konzepte. Die gibt's auch in Selbstbaututorials und die gibt's in Groß- und in Klein- und eigentlich war mir das immer zu doof. Und jetzt hab ich letztens aber einen gesehen, der hatte so ein Gerät in der Hand. Das Gerät nennt sich IOLight mit L-I-T-E. Also iolight.com, da würde man dann auf die Seite des Herstellers kommen. Da gibt's auch sehr stylische, scenetypische Fotos. So, der Benutzergruppe. Das ist das neueste Modell, was man auf der Webseite sieht. Aber es gibt auch eins, wenn man da auf Products klickt, dann gibt's da den klassischen IO-Lite auf der rechten Seite. Das sieht aus wie so ein Baby-Phone. Könnte man sagen. Pass auf, ich paste das mal in den Chat hier.
Das wäre sehr hilfreich.
Da, bitte schön, einmal draufklicken. Der untere da. Also das ist der, den ich habe. Es gibt da noch ein Modell, das sieht aus wie so eine 70er-Jahre-Garnitur, keine Ahnung. Das ist aber auch sehr handlich. Kommt gleich. Sieht halt aus wie so ein Babyphone. Man nuckelt dann im Prinzip an der Antenne her. Der Clou an der Geschichte ist allerdings, dass das Gerät komplett mit Feuerzeuggas betrieben wird, also es ist keine Batterie nötig, keinen Strom. Das heißt, du machst wie beim so einem normalen Gasfeuerzeug, dein Feuerzeuggas rein. Dann gibt es unten an der Ecke so ein P-Zuzünder. Das heißt, du legst den Hebel um, dass das Gas strömt, zündest einmal mit dem Knopf und dann hält es sich selber durch ein internes Thermostat quasi auf Temperatur. Das heißt, immer wenn es unter dieser besagten 190 Grad sinkt, bei welcher, also das ist die Temperatur, bei denen Pflanzen besonders gut verdampfen, dann schaltet der automatisch sozusagen wieder an und zündet auch selbstständig. Also man muss wirklich tatsächlich nur einmal pro Ladung diesen P-Zuzünder betätigen und dann hält es sich da selber am Laufen. Und ja, den habe ich mir jetzt gekauft und das Schöne war, jetzt dachte ich so, wo kaufe ich den? Also es gibt so im Fachhandel, das wird langläufig, also der Fachhandel besteht auch aus zum Teil etwas dubiosen Geschäften, die bisweilen auch, wie heißen die manchmal, also Headshops ist das eine, was gibt es noch? Grow Shops, Coffee Shops, was auch immer. Aber wo ich das jetzt gekauft habe, war Amazon. Dieses Gerät gibt es bei Amazon zu kaufen. Und jetzt ist es so, bei Amazon, wenn man irgendwie auf so ein Produkt klickt, dann kriegt man ja auch Kunden, die das kauften, kauften auch. Da kriegt man jetzt so Artikel angeboten, die vielleicht vom Pfeifentabak und den Minzblättern schon sich ein bisschen entfernen, aber thematisch noch in der gleichen Kategorie spielen. Also man kann seine Minzblätter dann auf Amazon noch mit einem Alu-Uni-Buddy-Minzblatt-Grinder z.B. zerkleinern um sie in Seiben.
Man kann sie auch abwiegen mit einer Feinwaage.
Man kann sie auch mit einer Feinwaage abwiegen. Und im Prinzip der ganze Zubehörbedarf ist auch bei Amazon mittlerweile gedeckt. Also man muss sich da keine großen Gedanken machen. Man kann seinen Minzblatt-Vaporizer auch innerhalb kürzester Zeit bei Amazon stellen. Das hat glaube ich zwei Tage gedauert, bis er bei mir war. Und jetzt nach ausgiebigen... Genau, nach ausgiebigen...
50 Einwegfeuerfolge.
Nach ausgiebiger Testphase kann ich also berichten, dass diese...
Gib mal eine Seite zurück.
Eine Seite zurück. Es gibt bei Amazon ein mehrteiliges stylishes Kiffer-Set.
Können wir das bitte in die Affiliate-Links tun? Also Amazon ist einfach voll dabei.
Was die Kunden wünschen.
Also ich mein, das kommt... Ich mein, man muss dazu sagen, das kommt von Amazon Marketplace-Händlern. Aber du bestellst das alles über Amazon und das wird auch über Amazon im Wesentlichen abgewickelt, aber...
Verkauf und Versand durch All Oriente.
Ja, aber kann dir... Aber du kannst halt mit Amazon bezahlen, Amazon Interface, alles mögliche. Ich kann auch jetzt abschließend noch sagen, dass dieses Produkt doch sehr überzeugend ist. Also die Minzblätter werden sehr effektiv verdampft. Also man kann auch über längere Zeit ohne Beschwerden und mit großartigem Genussgefühl also an diesem Gerät Spaß haben, ja. Ja, oder wie gesagt, Thymian oder Pfeifentabak, wenn es ein bisschen herber sein soll. Ich bin mir sicher, eure kreativen Geister Hopfen genau, können da mithalten. Man sollte halt, also wenn man das einmal mit so Vollzeugbenzin auffüllt, der Gas, sorry, dann hält das so für ein, zwei, so eine Ladung. Das heißt, wenn man so länger unterwegs ist und so sollte man vielleicht noch so eine kleine Taschenfeuerzeuggas-Geschichte dabei haben, um das dann unterwegs nachfüllen zu können. Ja, wobei, also diese Babyphone-Optik, also ich dachte mir zumindest so auf Konzerten, weil die Luft auch immer ein bisschen stickig ist und so eine kleine Minzinhalation vielleicht ganz praktisch fairer, um noch die Sommerstoff-Zufuhr zu verleisten, wo ja auch Rauchverbot herrscht. Und sowieso das Rauchen von Minzblättern nicht so toll ist. Da könnte dieses Gerät auch doch sehr effektiv... Ich hab übrigens beim Camp, und das hab ich erst gesehen, als ich jetzt einen Freund getroffen hab, der dieses Gerät auch hatte, beim Camp hab ich halt in dem einen im Trockendock, da saß zwei Tage lang so ein Typ in so einer Hängematte oder so am Rand, hat die ganze Zeit auch sehr fröhlich reingeschaut und hat die ganze Zeit an so ein Babyphone an so... Und das hat mich zum Zeitpunkt des Camps doch sehr verwirrt, aber als sozusagen... Also dieses Gerät hat dann doch die Verbindung wieder hergestellt.
Und gibst du das auch in Kombination mit einem Babyphone?
Also ich kann das wie gesagt durchaus empfehlen, wer an sowas interessiert ist. Und ich hätte ja dann noch so ein Thema, ne? Soll ich das noch...
War mal ein Keyword.
Wassteln, Elektronik.
Wir können ja erstmal ein bisschen Ruhe gestatten. Ich wollte noch auf eine andere Geschichte... Ja, deswegen ja. Ich muss erstmal ein bisschen ausdampfen. Manchmal hat man den Eindruck, du hast wieder zu viel Minze genommen. Habt ihr vielleicht schon gesehen, fand ich aber jetzt ausreichend bemerkenswert, um das noch mal hier zum Thema zu machen. Und zwar dieser Font. War auch beim Grober, ich weiß, kennen wahrscheinlich schon wieder alle, aber das hat mich dann doch ein bisschen beeindruckt. Von Fontshop hier aus Berlin. Auch ein deutscher Designer gemacht, der OpenType-Fonts gemacht hat, die sozusagen in allem, was OpenType-kompatibel ist... Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, was alles so OpenType-kompatibel ist, aber ich vermute mal generell, OS X dürfte dazugehören. Die Demos, die er da gibt, sind innerhalb von InDesign und so, was natürlich den Vorteil hat, dass es ebenso auch spezifische User-Interfaces bereitstellt, um da in die Tiefe des Fonts hineinzutauchen. Kurz gesagt, du kannst halt sowas eingeben, wie hier 30 plus 40 plus 10 plus 15 plus 7 plus 8 plus 1. Und dann markierst du diesen Textring und im Font ff-chartwell, in der Variante Chart oder Line oder Bar oder Radar etc. oder Rings und dann wird daraus ein Chart.
Krass.
Also der Font rendert dann als Chart. Kein Flash, kein Java, kein JavaScript, kein Nichts. Es handelt sich schlicht um einfach genau das. Das wird realisiert mit sogenannten Stylistic Alternates. Also das ist etwas, was OpenType sozusagen vorhält. Du kannst eben irgendwie Text so haben und dann kannst du sagen, jetzt habe ich aber einen anderen Style. Da sieht es ganz anders aus und die Rendervorschriften, die sind eben so komplex, die da realisiert werden können, dass du eben wirklich richtig mega pfiffige, hübsch aussehende Charts dabei rauskriegst. Also diese typischen Line, Bar, Charts etc. Pies und so weiter. So, wenn du halt mal eben sowas brauchst. Und dann kannst du dann eben auch, je nachdem, was dir dein Editor eben erlaubt, entweder indem du zwischen diesen verschiedenen Styles hin und her schaltest, dann mal wieder den Text editieren, uns dann wieder in die andere Darstellung überführen. Oder aber eben, wenn du so einen Inspektor hast, der dir sagt, irgendwie hier, ich kann den Content irgendwie in diesem Style editieren, und in meinem Dokument erscheint er aber immer in dem anderen Style, dann ist es natürlich besonders einfach. Und du kannst dann eben die Farbe der einzelnen Elemente einfach durch die Zuweisung von Farbe auf die Zahl, die du da hinschreibst, realisieren. Und dann sagst du einfach nur noch, lass mal anders aussehen, und dann hast du auf einmal so einen Chart.
Das ist total abgefahren.
Völlig irre. Das war mir überhaupt noch nicht bewusst, dass man sowas überhaupt realisieren kann mit OpenType. Aber offensichtlich geht diese Spezifikation doch sehr weit. Mapnick nur, du wusstest das alles schon.
Ja, also OpenType ist verdammt mächtig. Also es ist ja ursprünglich mal so angedacht worden, um Ligaturen machen zu können und so Kram. Und es gab letztens ja auch diesen Font, wo du irgendwie so Ice-Cream tippst, und der macht dann da draus irgendwie so ein Ice-Cream-Icon. Also der ersetzt halt on the fly so, wenn du tippst, Wörter durch die Symbole dafür. Also so wie ein Ding mit Benahmt quasi. Und OpenType ist echt schon fast ein Betriebssystem.
Ist auch kein schlechter Name für ein Betriebssystem, so OpenType.
Geht was, aber dauert lange bis sowas wie...
Geht leichter über die Zunge als VXWorks auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber dann kommt Freetype und dann kommt NetType und dann...
Ja, das war mein Einwurf.
Sehr schön, auf jeden Fall. Also ist mir, ist schon an mir vorbei gescrollt, aber ich hab so gedacht, da hätte ich einen anderen Fund oder so. Irgendwie hab ich's ignoriert, aber das ist ja doch einigermaßen spektakulär. Ja, aber geil.
So, während unser Internet mal wieder abgetaucht ist, kannst du ja mal auf das Gitarrenthema kommen.
Ja, ich hab ja eine El Chico Ho Chi Minh Flower Power Enterprises Gitarre. Eine Replika oder ein Nachbau von einer Les Paul Gitarre von Gibson. Und ich hab auch einen billigen Verstärker. Und das hat insgesamt alles nicht so wahnsinnig Spaß gemacht. Das hat mich auch so ein bisschen die Motivation im Stich gelassen, da dieses Gitarrenspiel noch weiter zu verfolgen. Ich hab auch sehr spät angefangen. Alles keine guten Voraussetzungen, um da noch mal ein Rockstar, zumindest ein Punkstar vielleicht oder so, irgendwas zu produzieren, was Leute sich gerne anhören. Limitieren wir es mal auf dieses Scope. Und dann haben ja ganz viele Freunde, die aber Gitarre spielen und so gesagt, hol dir erstmal einen ordentlichen Verstärker, wo du so ein paar mehr Effekte hast, dann macht das auch gleich ein bisschen mehr Spaß, rumzuprobieren. Und irgendwie hatte ich jetzt kürzlich wieder Bock und hab so ein bisschen nachgelesen und dann dachte ich mir auch so, naja Moment, also diese Pickups, also diese Spulen quasi, die die Schwingung der Seiten aufnehmen, wenn ich da so eine billige Gitarre hab, vielleicht ist da ja auch das schon mal irgendwie nicht so optimal. Und wenn man jetzt also so einen richtigen, ordentlichen Gipsen-Pickup sich da reinschraubt, dann kriegt man vielleicht auch einen Sound, der schon dem Original ein bisschen eher entspricht. Wobei natürlich bei so einer Gitarre auch der Holz-Korpus natürlich auch einen signifikanten Teil ausmacht. Und jetzt hab ich halt irgendwie erstmal mir kürzlich einen neuen Verstärker gekauft. Falls du auch das verlinken willst, oder die Hörer gerne verlinkt wissen wollen, das ist ein Vox VT20 Plus, der sich seines Zeichens dadurch auszeichnet, dass er eine Röhre in der Power-Section drin hat. Also es ist ein sogenannter Modeling-Amp, wo man halt tausende Effekte kombinieren kann. Und man hat irgendwie halt von Overdrive und Wah-Wah und alles mögliche kann man da einstellen. Aber er hat halt eben was untypisch ist für diese Art von Gitarrenverstärker, eine Röhre in der Power-Section, was dann eben dafür sorgt, dass er dann doch auch tatsächlich eher nach einem Röhrenverstärker klingt, als so die billigen Transistor-Verstärker. Und er ist halt auch vergleichsweise günstig, deswegen... und laut ist er auch. Also in dieser Preisklasse ist er der lauteste. Also ich hab ihn jetzt gestern bekommen und gestern ausprobiert und es war schon nach 22 Uhr. Und ich hab ihn nicht mal auf Stufe 1 gedreht und es war schon...
Lärm.
Es war schon so, dass ich dachte, na, ob der Nachbar unter mir das jetzt noch so aufnimmt oder ob das gerade vielleicht da drunter ist.
Was machst du denn damit?
Gitarre anstecken und dann halt irgendwie Lieder spielen und üben und verschiedene Sounds für die unterschiedlichen Lieder. Weil klingt ja nicht alles gleich, ne?
So hieß es bei Pink Floyd damals.
Wie heißt das Lied, was immer verboten ist, in Gitarenlehnen zu spielen? Also es ist nicht Stairway to Heaven, sondern... Aber es gibt doch eins, was sie immer... Ja, Smoke on the water, genau. Das ist immer verboten zu spielen. Ja, aber das mach ich natürlich dann zu Hause privat mit so ein paar Stärke auf 20 Watt voll aufgedreht. 30. 30, ja, aber ja. So, das war das eine. Und dann hab ich mir halt bei Thomann ja auch, wo du gerade da hier klickst, zwei Gibson-Pickups bestellt, nachdem ich ausgiebig erst mal gelesen hab, welche Pickups denn da so empfehlenswert wären. Da gibt's auch unglaublich tolle YouTube-Videos, wo Leute halt ihre alten Pickups einbauen.
Jetzt mal sagen, was Pickup genau ist.
Na, das sind halt diese Magnet-Sch...
Magnet-Tonabnehmer.
Von pro Seite einer oder einer für alle sechs?
Einer für alle. Also es ist ein Magnet, der über die ganze Breite geht, mit Metallstiften drin und Kupferungen rumgewickelt quasi.
Also du hast eine Spule, in der Spule ist ein Magnet. Und dieser Magnet, also ein Festmagnet, der Festmagnet erzeugt ein Magnetfeld. Durch dieses Magnetfeld geht deine Seite durch, deine Metallseite, und ändert dieses Magnetfeld dadurch, dass die Seite durch dieses Magnetfeld durchgeht. Und diese Magnetfeldänderung wiederum wird von der Spule wieder aufgenommen als Schwingung.
Also das ist ein Picker pro Gitarre.
Die meisten haben mehr als einen.
Du hast hier zum Beispiel rechts bei Tormann in dem Bild, da gibt es so einen Single-Coil-Pick-Up. Das rechts unten da, genau das. Das heißt, das ist jetzt nur ein Magnet, eine Spule, und diese Stifte sind so nochmal Metallstifte durch den Magneten, um das Magnetfeld auf die Seite zu fokussieren.
Ja, für manche Seiten ein bisschen mehr, für manche ein bisschen weniger.
Das ist alles fu. Genau, und die Les Paul getan, diese Humbucker, die wir hier auch auf dem Bildschirm haben, diese fetten Metallkästen, da sind im Prinzip zwei von denen drin. Und die sind in Serie geschaltet und sind halt weniger noise-empfindlich.
Also der Trick am Humbucker ist, du hast zwei Spulen, die direkt nebeneinander sind, die aber gegeneinander verpolt sind. Gleichzeitig drehst du auch den Magnet um. Das heißt, der eine macht dir das Magnetfeld mit Norden oben und der andere macht das Magnetfeld mit Süden oben. Und die Schwingungen, die sie aufnehmen, nehmen sie in der gleichen Phase auf. Aber wenn du eine Magneteinstreuung hast von außen, dann hebt die sich dadurch, dass die Spulen gegeneinander verpolt sind, auf.
Das heißt, wenn du vor dem Röhrenfernseher sitzt...
Ganz intervangial sozusagen, so es detailliert das gleiche.
Genau, sehr geile Cross-Referenz.
So, und die hab ich mir jetzt gekauft und hab dann meine El Cheapo Chiming Flower Power Enterprises Gitarre aufgeschraubt, gestern Nacht noch, und die alten Pickups rausgeschraubt und dann so den Deckel hinten aufgemacht, dann erst mal die Hände über dem Kopf zusammengeschlagen, weil das ist da so reingedübelt und reingelötet, also das sieht aus wie ein Schlachtfeld. Da ist so der...
Das ist aber auch bei teuren Gitarren nicht viel anders.
Ja, genau, das hab ich mir schon gedacht. Aber der Elektronik-Bastelnerd in einem, der sagt gleich, das ruppe ich alles auseinander und mach's nochmal ordentlich. Ich hab's jetzt erstmal nicht gemacht. Was ich gemacht hab, ist das Kabel von den alten Pickups irgendwie so ein bisschen mittig abgeschnitten, sodass sozusagen das noch angelötet ist. Dann hab ich die neuen Pickups reingeschraubt und hab jetzt hinten aus der Gitarre kommen sozusagen die alt fest angelöteten Kabel raus und die Kabel von den neuen Pickups. Und morgen, weil bei heutigen Podcasten geht's nicht mehr heute, morgen werd ich dann mit Krokok klemmen sozusagen die neuen Pickups an die alten Kabel ranklemmen. Und dann erst mal ausprobieren, ob's denn auch ordentlich klingt, ob ich mir jetzt überhaupt die Lötarbeit machen sollte, oder ob die alten Pickups sozusagen eigentlich viel besser klingen. Mal gucken. Ja, also ich bin hier voll am Gitarre basteln gerade. Und das Geile ist bei Thomann, und das ist wirklich cool, also nicht nur, dass sie hier Soundbeispiele für alle Verstärker, also für die meisten, haben. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt sozusagen, sie haben immer so bestimmte Riffs, Blues, Rock, was auch immer. Du kannst ja sozusagen die Verstärker in Taps aufklicken und kannst sie erstmal anhören, wie das auf den einzelnen Verstärkern klingt, was echt geil ist für so einen Online-Store. Sie haben auch Ratgeber zum Verstärkerkauf und sie haben auch einen Ratgeber zum Pick-Up-Tauschen. Das ist echt ein Nischenthema. Also du findest zwar Blog-Poster drüber und so Voranbeiträge, aber es ist echt dünn gesät. Und bei Thomann gibt es halt gleich irgendwie 7, 8 Seiten, wo es dann auch darum geht, ja, wenn du jetzt einen Hamburger hast, dann kannst du den in Serie schalten und dann parallel kriegst du Schaltbilder dazu. Gib mir auch Tipps, wie du deine Gitarre noch einen zusätzlichen Schalter reinschraubst, um halt on the fly von seriell auf parallel Schaltungen zu wechseln und so der totale Elektronik-Nerd-Bastel-Wahnsinn, quasi, ja. Jetzt bin ich so ein bisschen angefixterer Gitarretuner. Also eigentlich hatte ich den Plan, mir noch mal eine richtige Gipsengitarre zu kaufen und dann mit meiner billigen Gitarre nochmal so richtig so alles aufzufleddern und irgendwie dann nochmal rum zu schrauben und zu basteln. Weil die Elektronik und die Schaltung da drin ist echt trivial. Also jeder, der mal einen LED-Cube gebaut hat, hat ja deutlich komplexere Sachen schon gemacht.
Mehrere sogar. Die Kunst ist, dass du es erstens brummfrei kriegst und zweitens mal dann auch so robust, dass es hinterher irgendwie ein Konzert auf der Bühne überlebt.
Davon bin ich sowieso noch sehr, sehr weit entfernt, möchte ich mal sagen.
Und ich sage jetzt nicht, Gitarre zerschlagen oder so, sondern einfach irgendwie, wenn da, ich weiß nicht, der Teufel drin ist, dann brummt es manchmal oder es brummt nicht oder es ist ein Wackelkontakt. Das ist alles sehr unschön.
Ja, ich meine also die Gitarre, die ich hab, die ist halt auch wirklich, also da ist alles so ein bisschen flimsy und, na mal gucken. Ich werde auf jeden Fall berichten, wie es dann gelaufen ist. Ich hab auch natürlich vorher die Gitarre in alter Konfiguration an meinen Rechner angeschlossen mit so einem, ich hab noch diesen alten Griff in USB-Audio-Schnuffi, da hab ich die Gitarre direkt rangelegt.
Dieser Puck?
Ja, irgendwie so, ja doch. Und dann mit Amplitube erst mal so ein paar Standard-Akkorde und so weiter aufgenommen. Und Amplitube speichert die auch als Eif, also quasi lossless, ja. Das heißt, wenn ich dann das umgebaut habe, dann mach ich das Gleiche dann nochmal mit Amplitube und dann kann man sozusagen auch das Spektrum und alles mal nebeneinander legen und mal sehen, ob dann die teuren Gibson-Hambucker auch wirklich einen geileren Sound machen. Und als nächstes Projekt, falls das so ist, dann kann ich die alten Pickups, dachte ich, auf so eine Holzlatte schrauben und dann irgendwie so richtig Freestyle nochmal versuchen, irgendwie so ein Seiteninstrument zu basteln.
Ich freu mich ja mal neuen Pickup für meine Luftgitarre.
Das ist easy, da kommt man ins Geschäft, sagen wir mal 30 Euro und dann...
Du solltest vielleicht lieber Dubstep machen.
Ja, ich dachte auch gerade, eher Dubstep.
Das, was du da machst, ist aber eigentlich ein Effektgerät, ne?
Naja, ich meine, da gehört das nicht dazu. Ich muss sagen, mein Zugang zu Gitarrenmusik ist beschränkt.
Ich weiß.
Ist schmalbandiger als irgendwie O2 im Ausland, nachdem dein Charret abgelaufen ist. Also ich will das gar nicht schlecht finden. Ich bin irgendwie nativ aufgewachsen mit der Überzeugung. Das hat bei mir einfach nicht verfang, Gitarrensound generell nicht. Und ich war immer so leer und habe irgendwie keine Musikeinschläge gemerkt. Bis ich dann mal auf Techno gestoßen bin, da dachte ich mir so, pah, endlich, Musik. Das war ein ganz natürlicher Vorgang bei mir. Da hat es bei mir irgendwie eingestanden. Mit Gitarrenmusik kannst du mich meistens jagen. Also zumindest so Bühnen-Gitarren-Geschrammel.
Denkst du jetzt ja so an die Glam-Rock-Zeiten? Also wie ein bester Moment.
Ja, es gibt auch Musik, wo das irgendwie tragend zum Einsatz kommt, die ich durchaus gut finde.
Wie?
Ja, keine gehört.
Na also, dass ich mich wirklich für Musik selbst so richtig begeistern konnte, also abgesehen von, dass ich mal was gut fand. Das ging eigentlich erst mit Techno los. Vorher war das irgendwie alles unecht.
Na, das war ja eigentlich Techno, ne?
Jean-Michel Jarre?
Jean-Michel Jarre fand ich zum Beispiel auch ganz großartig, ja.
Aber Sündi löten ist halt auch so ein kleiner Sport, ne?
Ich fand Jean-Michel Jarre eigentlich auch immer ganz großartig, aber das, was dann Techno war, fand ich war immer nur lauer Abglatsch.
So, die alten Männer sind zurück.
Haben wir noch Themen, ich hab hier noch eins.
Wollen wir mal die Tür wieder zumachen, sonst wird es langsam kalt an der Fest.
Aha, aha, der Herr, der Herr macht's mal, der Herr macht's. Eine Sache, die wir vielleicht hätten woanders unterbringen sollen, hab ich hier noch rumliegen, fällt mir gerade auf. Habt ihr mitbekommen, dass H265 announced wurde?
Ja, hatten wir auch schon vor zweiter Sendung, hab ich dir das sogar mitten in deinen Satz reingeklatscht. Hast du nicht verstanden und hast es übergangen.
Wirklich?
Aber du darfst jetzt, weil das hatten wir ja dann nicht so richtig.
Ja, Entschuldigung, ich bin zu wichtig, jetzt kannst du ja ruhig mal drauf bestehen auf so einem Thema.
Na, nee, ich wollte noch ein bisschen.
Weißt du denn was darüber?
Was jetzt bei diesem H264 ist? Dass er irgendwie 40% effektiver, also der Bitstream ist kleiner und kannst ja immer ausruhen, ob du deine Qualität besser machst bei gleichem Bitstreamgröße oder ob du den Bitstream einfach kleiner machst. Aber was dir da speziell irgendwie jetzt fummeln, da beleg ich ja eh schon nicht mehr durch bei diesen Grafikkompressoren.
Ja, ich frage mich, wodurch sie das eigentlich erzielen und vor allem, wie sich das, also zu welchem H264, das sozusagen so verhält, weil es gibt ja H264 und es gibt das in verschiedenen Prozielen.
Du meinst die 40% könnten zudem von vor zehn Jahren da irgendwie sein? Das könnte natürlich...
Naja, zu diesem Baseline-Profil oder so. Aber mittlerweile kann ja auch jedes iPhone advanced... das komm ich jetzt mal durcheinander. Was sind die drei wesentlichen Gruppen?
Naja, ich meine, wenn es genau so gut wäre wie das advanced-Profil, dann bräuchten sie keinen neuen Standard, oder?
Wahrscheinlich wird es wieder Profile geben und die Profile sind jeweils besser.
Ja, ich frage mich nur, inwieweit dieser high-efficiency-Video-Coding-Standard gegenüber, also wie sehr das durchschlagen wird.
Ich denke, es verhält sich ja der Wesentlichen so wie HE AAC zu AAC. Nur, dass es halt nicht rückwärtskompatibel ist.
Kann man den Vergleich so ziehen? Audio und Video?
Nicht wirklich.
Ich finde es insgesamt interessant, dass die immer noch einen neuen Standard aus dem Hut zaubern, der immer noch kleinere Dateien macht. Wobei die Bandbreite, die so üblicherweise zur Verfügung steht, immer größer wird.
Das macht schon Sinn, weil die Movies werden ja auch immer fetter. Und wir wollen ja auch mehr Bilder pro Sekunde und so. Also da geht schon noch was.
Nur, ich hatte es halt so getwittert und die Leute haben es halt wie blöd retweetet. Die Zeit arbeitet halt gegen die Content-Industrie, wenn die Files immer kleiner werden und die Bandbreite immer größer.
Das ist so der Durchschnitts-Movie, den euch so unterladen.
Und wenn du dir anguckst, wer dahinter steht, hinter diesem Codec, dann fragst du dich, schießen die sich selber gerade in den Fuß? Weil da waren, glaube ich, auch einige Movie-Studios dabei, die hinter diesem Codec standen.
Natürlich, weil das bedeutet ja potenziell, dass du auch über den Satelliten einfach mehr rübergestrahlt kommst.
Das bedeutet ja auch, dass du deine Movies, wenn du den Online-Store hättest oder sowas, oder ein Online-Rental-Modell, wenn du das hättest, dass du die auch einfacher an den Kunden bringen kannst.
Hauptsächlich bedeutet das, dass die Pifel bei den Downloads kleiner werden, wenn sie aber dabei noch besser aussehen.
Wobei, wenn die Filme dann 4K sind, dann werden die Downloads erstmal wieder größer, glaube ich.
Oder sie sind dann einfach gleich groß, obwohl sie auf 4K sind.
4320p. 4220p.
Das ist nach unten, ne? Das heißt, du brauchst dann schon einen 27 Zoll Retina iMac dafür.
7680 Pixel mal 4320.
Ich meine, ich war hier. Weißt du, wir haben doch eine Kino International Konferenz gemacht und die haben ja so eine 21 Meter Leinwand oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Also schon ziemlich groß so für das Kino auf jeden Fall. Und dann haben sie da ihren super teuren halbe Millionen Beamer. Aber der macht auch nur ein kleines bisschen mehr als Full HD letztendlich, ja? Also wenn du da vor der Leinwand stehst, siehst du halt schon den Pixel wieder so Fingerguckengröße oder was auch immer. Nee, war schon ein bisschen kleiner, aber du siehst es halt, ne? Und da denkst du dir natürlich schon, ok, jetzt ist bei einer 21 Meter Leinwand jetzt Full HD oder ein bisschen größer halt ist jetzt nicht mehr so doll. Also da ist dann 4K natürlich schon eher strebenswert.
Oh ja, dann sehen doch bestimmt manche Filme noch ein bisschen bekloppter aus. Also ging doch hier dieses Gerücht rum, ob da nichts gesehen, dass irgendwie hast du mal gleich den neuen Film hier von Herr der Ringe?
Der soll ja in 48 frames per second kommen.
Ach, das Thema hatten wir glaube ich auch schon. Ja, ich hör zu viel Moe.
Aber ich hab noch eine kurze Geschichte für Kino. Und zwar der Batman, der ja gerade schon draußen ist, den hat der ja, wie heißt dieser Typ? Christopher Nolan, hat er jetzt anstatt 35 Minuten so wie beim letzten, so hat er ca. 70 Minuten in diesem IMAX-Format gedreht. Und es gibt auf dem Europa-Festland, glaube ich, kein einziges Kino, was das abspielen kann. Und man muss wohl nach London fliegen, wenn man das im IMAX-Format sehen kann. Und da läuft der Film wohl an irgendeinem Kino rund um die Uhr. Und wenn man sich morgens um 6 Uhr so ein Film aussucht, dann kriegt man doch ein Kärtchen. Und es gibt Verrückte, die fliegen dann nach London und gucken sich dann den IMAX-Format an.
Das ist aber schon beeindruckend. Also ich hab in San Francisco Prometheus gesehen, in IMAX 3D und das macht eigentlich schon mal, das ist einfach anders. Was ist denn das für eine Auflösung ins Hirn?
Na IMAX ist einfach...
Wegen 3D hüpft es dir ins Hirn?
Wegen Größe und 3D dann.
Die machen auch die Auflösung... Die Leinwand ist auch deutlich höher.
Der macht nicht das normale Kino-Breit-Format, sondern auch ein bisschen höher, weil das IMAX-Kino ist halt auch so... Nicht 4 zu 3, aber ist irgendwie so ein bisschen mehr...
Also so Full Line of Sight sozusagen.
Genau, und die Kamera ist halt auch ziemlich fett. Die ist auch wohl ziemlich teuer. Und jetzt haben sie auch nur eine weniger, weil bei einem Stunt ist eine kaputt gegangen. Aber das sieht schon richtig gut aus. Es gibt... Ja, ich sag's jetzt mal... Bei Pirate Bay gibt's eine IMAX-Version zum Runterladen, wo halt die das nicht weggerendert haben. Beim normalen Kino schneiden die oben und unten einfach ab, weil die können das halt nicht zeigen. Also das ist halt im Film nicht mehr drauf. Und es gibt bei Pirate Bay... Oder auf Blu-ray... Genau, kauft euch die scheiß Blu-ray. Und da ist auch eins mit dem IMAX-Format so... Also das Bild an sich sieht besser aus. Selbst wenn das oben und unten wegschneiden würdest. Das ist sowas von Glas, klar und super sauber. Also die nutzen ein anderes Filmmaterial. Da werden die Bilder seitwärts gespeichert und nutzen den kompletten Platz oder irgendwie so. Also die nutzen viel mehr negativ beim IMAX-Aufnehmen. Und das macht sich echt bemerkbar.
Ja, ich meine, das siehst du ja dann eben auch bei so Filmen wie bei 2001, diese Blu-ray-Version. Diese Neugeskennung, das war ja auch 70mm-Film.
Und das war eine Weile in den 70ern oder 69 war ja hier. 2001 war das mal angesagt, später haben sie aus Kostengründen, weil sie ja meinten, sie können aus 35mm ja doch genug rausholen, haben sie das mit den 70mm wieder eingestellt.
Aber wenn wir heute halt wirklich so diesen 2001, diesen Blu-ray-Rescan und so weiter angucken, der sieht so krass gut aus, der könnte von heute sein. Also wirklich, das sieht so brillant aus, so super crisp, so schöne Farben, der ist wirklich, also das ist echt eine Wonne für die Augen alleine. Und mehr auflösen ist immer besser. Auf jeden Fall, auf Film wie auf Sensor.
Wir wissen uns eigentlich, wir wollen mehr Pixel.
Ja, wir wollen halt solange mehr Pixel und mehr Audio-Quality und weniger Frames, solange unsere Augen halt das noch irgendwie ein Stück mitkriegen. Und noch kriegt das halt mit.
So, ich glaube, jetzt sind wir durch. Ich wollte jetzt hier noch, ich hab ja noch überlegt, sollen wir hier nochmal irgendwie eine Umfrage starten, was dir irgendwie was gewünscht ist? Mit MM100?
Na im Chat war schon die Idee, dass ich alle Zuhörer auch gleich mitbesaufen, mit Qualitätsprodukten. Also grundsätzlich, was auch immer wir machen, würde ich das erstmal auf jeden Fall anstreben.
Genau, aber ich mach das ja mal jetzt noch nicht gleich, sondern ich denk mir da mal so ein bisschen so einen kleinen Fragebogen aus. Und das findet ihr dann irgendwie auf Twitter oder keine Ahnung, im Blog oder so. Wir haben ja noch ein bisschen Zeit. Also ihr seht das natürlich jetzt nicht, aber so wie ich das so sehe, haben wir's.
Ja, aber das mit der Zeit, also ich würd da nicht zu viel Zeit auch den Zeitstrahl runterträufeln lassen. Also das kommt dann in dieser hundertsten Sendung. Das geht dann schneller als man denkt.
Achso, aber ich mach jetzt hier keinen Schnellschuss, bevor ich nicht mal in Ruhe drüber nachgedacht habe, was ich da eigentlich fragen will.
Ich soll Gitarre spielen, weil ich da eine hundertste Sendung nachher muss. Ich muss ja aber noch ein bisschen üben.
Ja, du könnt auch ein paar Minzblätter verteilen.
Ja, ein paar Minzblätter in die Runde, das ist auch gut.
Spiel mal Gitarre, das ist eine gute Idee.
Genau, jeder spielt sein Lieblingsinstrument.
Was ist denn das bei dir, eine 303 oder was?
Weiß nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich bin sehr unbegabt, was das betrifft. Ich hab nur mal so ein paar Wochen lang Geige gelernt, ansonsten im Chor gesungen, das war's dann im Wesentlichen. Ich bin musikalisch total in Niete. Aber so richtig. Ich könnte vielleicht noch eine Maultrommel-Performance hinlegen, aber das ist auch eher elend.
Bist du so Ableton Live oder Traktor oder irgendwas?
Ja, ich kann nur reden. Genau, ich mach euch den MC.
Dubstap, das sah heute nicht so schlecht aus, war hin. Du kannst die Luftgitarre machen.
Genau, ich rappe.
Wenn ich singen kann, der rappt.
Haben wir's.
Ja, von mir aus.
Noch ein empathisches Tschüss.
Wir sehen.
Ich hab noch einen Tipp zum Schluss. Und zwar hat ein Freund von mir eine Google-Map-Kollaborativ zusammengestellt von guten Bäckern in Berlin, die noch selber backen.
Da hast du wieder ein komplett neues Thema auf.
Ich weiß, aber das ist nur ein ganz kurzer Link, den ich hier poste. So, da ist der Link im Google. Da sind jetzt für Berlin schon so einige Bäckereien eingetragen. Bei einigen von denen war ich auch schon und kann bestätigen, dass es da tatsächlich sehr gutes Brot gibt.
Wie ist das definiert? Als Bäckt selber nach irgendwie?
Also zum Beispiel einige der Bäcker, die haben halt, also einer weiß ich, der hat einen kompletten Steinofen, so richtig voll aufgebaut. Und die meisten haben halt selber nur irgendwelche Industrie-Backöfen, aber stellen sozusagen das Brot selber her. Das sind keine Aufbäcker, wie so die meisten hier, weißt schon, Steinkampf und so weiter, sondern die kneten den Teig noch selber und stecken ihn noch selber in den Ofen.
Da fehlt aber hier dieser Hacker.
Genau, und du kannst tatsächlich also selber da jetzt auch neue Bäcker hinzufügen.
Also das lässt sich offen editieren sozusagen.
Ich glaube, du kannst auf Bearbeiten klicken und selber neue hinzufügen, ja.
Wie kann man die...
Boimer und Lothar musst du auf jeden Fall mit dazu.
Wie blendet man die in der Karte ein?
Wie sind die nicht per Default eingeblendet? Also bei mir schon.
Aber dieses Happy Toast Brot-Icon passt ja nicht so ganz.
Happy Toast Brot ist ein bisschen...
Also musst du mal rauszoomen, vielleicht ist an der Stelle keiner.
Schau mal hier, ich klick eine ein und da ist gar nichts.
Tja, bei mir...
Die nachfolgenden Sendungen verschieben.
Also, ist eine Karte, man kann da auch eine super Web-Up draus machen, das kann man alles noch viel schöner machen, aber es ist mal so ein erster Versuch, zumindest dieses Aufbäckertum so ein bisschen im Zaum zu halten und mal den Leuten zu zeigen, dass es immer noch echte Bäcker gibt.
Ja, und vor allem, das muss sich ja nicht auf Berlin beschränken, weil ich hab da gerade rausgezoomt, da ist ja noch mehr Karte dran.
Ja, definitiv. Also wir haben halt tatsächlich erstmal mit Berlin angefangen, weil hier bei WUGA so die ganzen Leute so irgendwie, ja hier Brot und so soll doch ganz groß sein und dann waren sie dann nur bei Steinkampf und so und dann dachten wir, jetzt müssen wir mal...
Du meinst deine nicht-deutschen WUGA-Kollegen?
Genau, ja oder auch Leute, die von aus Bayern oder sonst woher kommen, die wollen halt auch mal lecker Brot essen. Und irgendwie hat man ja bisweilen den Eindruck, es gibt eigentlich gar keine richtigen Bäcker mehr, aber zumindest in Berlin gibt es doch noch ein paar.
Ja, ist ja auch so. Also es gibt immer weniger und das ist schon ganz schön lame. Also Leute, die heutzutage ein Brötchen essen, die wissen noch gar nicht, wie ein Brötchen wirklich schmeckt.
Ja, genau, könnte man auch eine Open Street-Map natürlich machen.
Wow, da sind echt zwei um die Ecke.
Siehste, da hab ich noch mal so zum Schluss sehen.
Veganische Croissants, vegane Croissants, koschere Bäckerei.
Die sind ja dann ohne Butter, das geht ja gar nicht.
Sojamilch oder so.
Sojamilch darf das nicht mehr heißen.
Okay, check das einfach mal aus, letzter Tipp.
Genau, das war's.
Danke, dass du hier bist und wir sehen uns bald.